e
e e
good morning everyone uh the time is now
uh 10:04 um I'd like to open the meeting
and I would ask representative leus to
lead us in the pledge please
thank you everyone and just so everyone
understands the mission of this
committee we are a bipartisan committee
tasked with investigating and evaluating
the stains response to the co 19
pandemic the committee will function in
a science-based fact-f finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all related
information pertaining th to areas of
particular Focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impacts on
New Hampshire
uh I would like to welcome our speaker
Erin Siri if you uh if you're ready you
have the floor and um before I I'm sorry
I don't mean to interrupt you but do you
mind if we ask questions while you are
presenting thank you so much and make
sure you turn on your
mic is oh red is on oh good I got it all
right
sorry okay um
just going to pull up a PowerPoint um
see if we
can
okay and you could tell me if you can
see that on your screen over
there and uh I presume that comports
more or less with your mission
hopefully when I uh I've I've you know
in putting this together I've thought
about the mission and uh I've tried to
put a
presentation that comports with the
mission of the committee
um uh within the context of Co
vaccinations as that is the um the area
of expertise that I was asked to testify
about um so I'll give you a little bit
of background about myself um I um I
work at a law firm that has 60 folks
about 40 of them do pretty much
exclusively vaccine work so our firm I
believe has the largest vaccine practice
in the world that does not represent
pharmaceutical companies so we have a uh
Department that handles just vaccine
injury claims um and you'll hear more
about that later we don't bring those
claims against pharmaceutical companies
we bring them against the federal
government um we have a policy practice
and exemption practice and and various
other intersections of the law and
vaccines
um I um
I went to Berkeley for law
school and uh uh and uh over 20 years
later I uh I I find myself doing an area
of law that if you told me I'd be doing
when I was in law school I probably
would have laughed and said is there
such a thing called vaccine law what is
that but but here I am that's that is
what I am doing now it's not what I've
always done I clerked for the chief
judge at the Supreme Court of Israel
after law school for a year and then I
worked late milwa Walkins one of the
biggest firms in the country
representing Goldman Sachs lar Ellison
for about 6 years after which uh I left
uh I was working too much and my wife
wanted me home more I don't think that
worked out either uh started my own
practice um was still doing commercial
litigation and eventually um ended up
doing this work starting about 8 years
ago and have been doing it increasingly
so where that's now pretty much the
primary focus of my practice
um you might know some of the work we've
done um you our firm handled for example
the
um the lawsuit against the air force
that got a national injunction
preventing the Air Force from kicking
out over 10,000 members of the Air Force
who did not want a covid vaccine due to
their sincerely held religious beliefs
often because of the intersection of
that product and
abortion uh we brought the lawsuit
against the FDA when they didn't want to
release the clinical trial data that
they relied upon to license the covid-19
vaccine um we handle a number of other
lawsuits all around covid vaccines
during the last few years and one of the
things I'll say about the lawsuits that
we do bring with regards to vaccines is
that um since I don't have a PhD after
my name or an MD or do uh I don't get to
just say things about vaccines I have to
prove them with clinical trial data data
high impact journals um or they're just
not going to work in a cart setting so
um in
that um in doing those types of legal
work it's
really forced us to be I I guess you
would say you know real critical
evaluators about the products for better
or worse and at the end of the day that
is something that that I do think the
public loses sight of sometimes not
always is that these are products um
like kind of any other products and they
have
a safety profile they have an efficacy
profile they have things they can do for
sure and they have things they can't do
um there are things that people think
about them that are accurate in some
areas and not in others um and sometimes
often there's just not information not
enough information to reach a conclusion
about some things with regards to the
products um and so um with that uh sort
of brief introduction
uh I will uh go through
um some of the uh information about
vaccines and covid vaccines that I think
are going to be helpful to understand
the government including New Hampshire's
response during the covid pandemic um
Siran glimp that's the name of my firm
and a lot of the vaccine work that we do
is on behalf of I can and you'll see uh
that's a nonprofit and you'll see a lot
of the things we discussed today were
lawsuits and information gathered in in
in lawsuits on behalf of I
can okay
so to understand covid-19 vaccines in my
opinion you have to understand vaccines
in general from a legal perspective and
how they're treated in this country for
decades before if you want to understand
how the FDA responded Visa V covid
vaccines how the CDC how 50 State Health
departments how various uh um organs of
the state and and and
agencies acted regarding covid vaccines
they didn't just act tabularasa they
didn't just step into a zone that they
had no precedent
for they stepped into
basically in my opinion for the most
part uh um business as usual so to speak
with how they proceeded Visa covid
vaccines people look at covid vaccines
and say there's something extraordinary
I think that um from the from a
regulatory legal perspective um they
weren't that uh uh U unique and and I'll
walk you through that and I think that
understanding that um how vaccines were
treated pre covid helps put in context
how they were treated during
covid now
um I'm going to start by focusing on
product safety um because I know that's
been a uh little bit of a topic of
debate around covid
vaccines and um you know the question I
start with is how is product safety
assured in
America how's this make sure cars are
safer every product you see in your
house is safer your oven pretty much
every product you see in this room over
time over decades they've gotten safer I
mean cars fuel tanks used to blow up
right we don't see that anymore and so
forth and what drove that product safety
the primary thing that drives product
safety are Market
forces companies exist for the most part
to make a profit if they're going to
make a product they'll be profitable
that
drives their conduct if there's going to
be
liability or they anticipate liability
beyond what the revenues are they don't
make that product they also don't
continue selling that
product Market forces Drive product
safety when you look to use cars as an
example and actually in law school they
use a lot of car cases as the you know
prototype uh cases to teach you know
there was this uh you know one of the
classic examples there was a car company
where um the internal valuation found
that it would cost more to fix this
component that made gas tanks explode
than it would to pay for around the 10
people that died every year from those
explosions so they didn't fix it it was
was a it was a cold hard calculus to be
sure I I I hope Corporate America
doesn't typically act that way but it
did in that situation what's that I'm
sorry it did in that situation um but I
think it's it's reflective of the kind
of calculus that happens every day in
Corporate America um and to be sure
that's good that's capitalism we want
that we want companies to have a
financial interest to drive Innovation
it's a good
thing um and then the push back they get
is they know that if they hurt people
they can get sued and that often
conforms their CCT their conduct before
the market the product even gets to
Market certainly after it gets to Market
but but also before it gets to
Market a far weaker way that we assure
product safety are Regulators no offense
to in government in any way um but you
know when you when you do look at take a
careful evaluation um and most
Industries and you look back at what has
conformed their conduct what has driven
safety uh it's typically been Market
forces when you think about um most
products you think about class actions
you read in the newspapers about oh this
product has an issue you don't hear
about that typically from a government
warning you typically hear about it from
The New York Times or the CNN reporting
on OIC having this or that issue and so
forth and then even more so product
liability and class actions attorneys
will make sure you see an ad about that
injury online because they want you as a
client you can't avoid them if you use
that product um no knock on
lawyers so
um when it comes to Market Force
assuring product safety I think
understanding how um Market forces work
with other vaccines will help put
how covid-19 vaccines were
treated in the early 1980s there were
only three routine vaccines that's it
there's dtp MMR and
opv that's the sum total of all of the
routine vaccines in the United States of
America
and the damages they were having to pay
and the liability they were incurring
from the injuries for those products
resulted
in either the manufacturers going out of
business for those three products or
stopping to make the products to the
point where it reached a crescendo where
there was one manufacturer left for each
of those three
products um you can see I've got a quote
there from Bruce szv W that's a US
Supreme Court decision
that explained that the remaining
manufacturer of dtp vaccine estimated
that its potential Tor liability exceed
its annual sales by a factor of
200 and The Institute of medicine
explained how by 1986 litigation costs
had driven
manufacturers essentially out of
business from making those products well
Congress in its wisdom instead of
forcing those
manufacturers to do what every other
product manufacturer has to
do when their product causes more harm
than it does good is measured by dollars
and that For Better or Worse How We Do
It in
America um decided instead to pass the
national childhood vaccine injury Act of
1986 and what this law provided was that
it's okay for the companies that made
those products continue selling them
they don't have to worry about liability
exposure it's provided in the act it
immunized them from finan fincial
liability for the injuries caused by
those three products this way they
didn't
face the financial
exposure representative
Penza thank you madam
chair in your expertise in research is
there any other industry that you know
of that gets a blanket
liability like this any
yes so when it comes to products um and
I'll distinguish between products and
certain services but when it comes to
products the only other product I'm not
aware of any product none that enjoys
the level of
immunity to having to pay for injuries
that vaccines enjoy and it um it applies
to Childhood vaccines and any childhood
vaccines used by adults so pretty much
all vaccines now when it comes to guns
for example which has talked about what
guns have immunity the immunity that
guns have is if the gun is used in the
commission of a crime the manufacturer
has immunity to liability for the most
part but you can still as a consumer if
I buy a gun and has a a design defect I
can sue the manufacturer of a gun for
defectively designing a gun I can sue
them for other types of claims but when
it comes to vaccines
and it's right there in Bruce SZ V Wyatt
again the US Supreme Court affirmed
because it was challenged that the law
shouldn't actually provide this it says
the vaccine and vaccine act preempts all
designed defect claims against vaccine
manufacturers for injury or death caused
by vaccine side
effects design defect claims are the
primary way we assure safety it's the
way that for example the car I example I
described earlier the uh uh there was a
say a better way to make that gas tank
there was a safer way to make it and the
primary claim there was a design defect
claim I mean that when you think about
saws that now have shields on them
that's because the lawsuit said hey whoa
you you sold me the saw it does what
it's supposed to do thank you right but
if You' had put like a three Penny
plastic piece on it I still have my arm
right there are uh when there are ready
ways to improve a product you can sue
for a design defect claim but you can
never do that for a vaccine forever
meaning the state of the those productss
in 1986 is essentially locked in at
least from the perspective of being able
to bring a
claim to on the basis that you could
have made it safer um so the answer your
question is no I'm not aware of any
other product that has the immunity
enjoyed by vaccines
none
followup so that of course that's for
the United States of America are you
familiar with so are other countries
able to go after because of course um
you know fiser madna all these other
companies uh have products that went you
know to other countries as well are they
able to um to go after these
manufacturers um so if you're asking me
specifically about covid-19 vaccines we
have copies of the contract procurement
contracts from many of the countries
around the world and those contracts
explicitly provided in almost in all the
ones we've seen and that's and it's a
lot of countries just like the
procurement contract United States and
actually it's one of my slides later it
um provides that the comp the country
will either give immunity or indemnify
essentially hold the company harmless
for injuries caused by the covid
vaccines used in their countries
contractually but I think your question
might have been broader in the first
instance which is do other countries for
other vaccines have um a immunity and
many of them do have the similar scheme
that that we have here in the United
States it's been very very effective and
so it's it's it's been exported to lots
of places in the
world um separately you know class
actions and the type of
um justice system that we have here is
not the same in other countries so you
can't bring the type of claims you can
in other countries as you could here um
or as effectively but many of them also
do have that kind of um liability Shield
as well um um yes do you have so based
on the
implementation prior to the National
childhood vaccine injury Act of
1986 you had the previous slide that
said that the tort would exceed their
annual sales by a factor of 200 do we
have any idea of the injuries that were
happening the
numbers um before this was
implemented
um the dtp vaccine in particular I could
tell you has been withdrawn from the
United States so that's no longer here
since 2000 essentially they it's not
used
and um even I guess you could call it
the the regulatory Health establishment
decided that the benefits that the risks
out way the benefits at least Visa
favoring a cellular protest dap DT
little AP vaccine so that did change
over time um the uh the level of harm
caused cused by That vaccine there's no
uh there's no debate that it causes harm
that it causes harm yeah the level
debate that you can uh uh that is a sign
to that is something that that was
debated um and different studies were
done um there were studies done by
federal health authorities who were
promoting mandating pushing mandates of
the product and there were some
independent studies done and I can tell
you they reached different results um
and you know but I I'll leave that for a
scientist to come and debate which one
of those was better studies better
designed uh but I can't tell you that at
least for That vaccine it's the
wholesale protest vaccine is no longer
used in the United States and I I have a
slide or two about that later as well so
I'll hold on on the rest of my comment
on that if I
may um well that brings us to covid-19
vaccines so I just wanted to make sure
you have a back sh of what the 1986 Act
was and so the 1986 act applies to covid
vaccines as
well um the immunity under the uh 1986
act
arguably applies when um it is added to
the routine childhood schedule by the
CDC and specifically as at the advisory
committee on imization practices which
is the cdc's advisory vaccine committee
uh when it's added the
uh uh essentially the the immunity
attaches I qualify that only because
they're also supposed to be an exed tax
passed by Congress for covid vaccines
which hasn't happened yet but that's um
a separate question as it stands right
now um I think many would argue that the
86 act Community does apply to covid
vaccines but it is a somewhat of a of of
a theoretical question because
the covid vaccine is afforded a separate
level of immunity and that is something
called a prep act immunity um and that
is a um it's the you know public
Readiness and emergency preparedness act
that is a law different law passed by
Congress which provided that um if the
secretary of the Department of Health
and Human Services declares that there
is an emergency and obviously there are
different emergency declarations the
president can make one different FDA can
make emergency youth authorizations
those are different this is under the uh
the relevant us code under that under
that act the Secretary of HHS can
declare an emergency and with based on a
perceived or potential pandemic a
pandemic or other threats and declare
that any counter measures developed to
address
that um that uh uh what it declared is a
threat will be afforded basically
blanket immunity for the most part for
any claims on the safety side as well as
the efficacy side as well as the
advertising side which is what the
statute provides and at the very very
beginning of the covid-19 pandemic the
secretary of the Department of Health
and Human Services declared covid-19 a
emergency and declar that any counter
measures developed in response to
covid-19 would be afforded that IM
community and that was done right at the
very beginning I've got the US code
provision there 42 USC 247 d6d and it
says manufacturers of any vaccine used
to treat prevent or mitigate covid-19
shall have liability immunity including
from suit and liability under federal
and state law with respect to all claims
for loss caused by arising out of or
relating to or resulting
from the administration to or the use of
an individual of a and then I covid-19
vaccine but it's broader than that it's
also drugs it's masks it's anything that
was used
okay so you have basically a product
that's being developed in with what I
would consider a moral hazard the
manufacturer stands to make billions of
dollars but as they're developing it
before they've even started they're
really just sted making it they already
know that when they design it when they
manufacture it when they trial it when
they push it out they don't have to
worry about being sued for injuries
their products
causes that that my opinion creates a
big moral hazard and it doesn't exist to
your point representative with any other
product that I'm aware of on the
market and as I noted earlier not only
did the prep act immunity apply the
manufacturers of these products wanted
to make sure that the prep back immunity
would apply in in fact that which is why
in their statements of work at least on
the US side procurement contracts and so
forth they had most of them had a
contractual provision similar to this
this I believe was the fiser contract
one of the the initial I believe fiser
procurement contract and it says the
government may not use or authorize the
use of any product or material provided
under this agreement which were covid-19
vaccines unless such use occurs in the
United States and is protected from
liability under a declaration issued
under the prep Act or successor covid-19
prep P Declaration of equal greater
scope it literally the United States
government guaranteed that nobody would
use the products that they were
procuring unless prep act immunity
applied and um uh uh and the government
was one buying all the covid-19 vaccines
so they were the uh point of origin for
all covid-19 vaccines United States as
far as I'm aware operation warp speed
took over the whole procurement function
and um purchased the vaccines that were
then distributed in the United States
okay
so with that backdrop about um immunity
you know and I think that's an very
important point to consider when you're
thinking about laws regulations around
these products obviously you know I
think the reason there's so much debate
around vaccines is because the main
difference between a vaccine and a drug
or a medical product or food or water or
anything else is that is a legal issue
legal distinction it's because people
try to mandate them try to force them on
others many states have um using School
vaccines as a as a
proxy uh many states have philosophical
exemptions parents can just opt out at
will and even in those States most
School vaccination rates are very
high mandates are not NE which which are
you know proof in the pudding that you
don't need mandates to persuade people
often but there are a segment of
population who often and we could tell
you that from our clients every day
shouldn't get
vaccines either they or they watch their
children get
injured and they don't want to continue
participating the problem often comes
that for those folks sometimes depending
on the vaccine depending on where they
are depending they may not be able to go
to school get a job and during the co
pandemic we saw potentially participate
in all forms of civil society and
obviously that that's a problem for for
some folks not for for the others but
for some and um you know the whole idea
of Rights is is about
protecting a minority right we don't
need rights to protect majorities
typically because they're the majority
they can kind of get the laws they want
often have the influence they want not
always but they're really about
protecting the minority and protecting
them from government intrusion right
overreach and that's the whole Bill of
Rights reform limiting the government's
ability to infringe on those I don't
think we have to be so scared about
stomping out the speech of what 90% of
Americans want to say it's it's what the
10% want to say that we need to protect
right often because 90% will get their
way all right um so what is the impact
of giving Immunity on liability well
again I think um it's instructive to
look at how clinical trials were
conducted before covid-19 for other
vaccines to then understand how clinical
trials were conducted for covid-19
vaccines because there's a lot of debate
around those trials and I think putting
them with in the framework of what's
done with other vaccines will help
understand what it is the FDA was doing
at the time um so you know why are
clinical trials critical um I think
that's an important question to to
understand the answer
to to determine whether something is a a
a alleged injury is
causally not correlation causally
related to a product you typically need
typically need a
prospective study that compares and
Expos and an unexposed group okay
looking at data
retrospectively backwards
epidemiological
studies are always viewed as being
unable to determine causation okay so
when you uh with that and you can bring
an epidemiologist to say that which
they'll readily all say um and we
litigate that issue all day in vaccine
Court
uh uh the only time you really do a
prospective a forward-looking study with
vaccines is in a clinical trial meaning
you it's forward-looking and that you
enroll
people you give one group The vaccine
you give one group you don't give the
vaccine and then you follow them and you
statistically compare the outcomes
between the two groups okay by doing
that you have the ideas to remove bias
the ideas to then see what does the
outcome look like the moment you instead
say we're going to take an existing data
set and we're now going to try to
evaluate that set for what happened
meaning looking based on the data what
happened in the past there's always
confounders and those confounders are
viewed as as tainting those studies and
hence you can't determine causation from
them well did you did you select people
that were too old they were to Young to
this I mean you saw these debates happen
I think they spilled over into
mainstream meting which was interesting
to watch it's interesting to watch the
discussions about clinical trials in
mainstream media so um so clinical
trials are
critical because it is the only time you
can do a placebo control prospective
study of vaccines pretty
much once they've been
licensed it is considered
unethical to do a placebo controlled
clinical trial for a vaccine
it's considered une ethical to do a
study you need to get something called
IRB approval okay where you get an
Ethics board to approve it universities
and so forth IRB committees all around
the
country I'm not aware of a single IRB
Committee in this whole country that
will approve a placebo control clinical
trial of a vaccine after it's licensed
after it's liced so if you want to
really understand the safety profile of
vaccine and you want to be able to know
what injuries it actually caused is not
what it's alleged to cause but actually
causes you need a really good robust
clinical
trial and I can tell you clinical trial
dat is at our firm when we get a parent
call us up and say well my child got a
hepb vaccine and now suffers from this
type of neuropathy or doodia or whatever
it
is ideally we'd love to just go to the
clinical trial data and see well what
did it that show between the exposed and
unexposed okay uh so representative
beler thank you madam chair apologies uh
for interrupting I just wanted to
clarify a little bit because I want I
want the cause of this to be very clear
for anybody who's here and watching is
it correct that the reason it would be
considered unethical to do this
controlled study after licensing because
the license brings with it a presumption
of efficacy which would then cause the
withholding of that medication from the
placebo part of the trial uh is that
where the unethical part comes in yeah
once they're licensed they're deemed um
effective for the indication on the
package insert and that indication for
example if it says to prevent fusus
disease um it is now considered
unethical to withhold a product from a
child that has an indication that can
withhold protest that it can prevent
pressus disease right it's because of
the efficacy component even if you so
that's that's why you can't do it
um and and clinical trials for for most
vaccines really focus on the efficacy
components of it I mean that's how
they're typically
designed um they're they're not um and
and we I I don't want to make conclusory
statements I'll let you judge for
yourself let me just I'll show you what
the data shows um and you can make your
own um conclusions on that um and so why
is liability critical to how clinical
trials are conducted liability from the
manufacturer is critical because if the
manufacturer knows they're going to be
liable for the injuries that you know
the V that the product they're making is
going to cause if it's a drug for
example they want to
know the safety profile before that
product goes in the market because they
could be facing company ending liability
if it ends up hurting to many people I
me the whole reason drugs and vaccines
are licensed because they can hurt some
people that's the idea right that's why
you have to get them licensed but they
want to make sure it doesn't hurt too
many people right in terms of the risk
benefit analysis that's what often at
least the FDA would tell you safe and
effective means and so if you take away
that liability though from the
manufacturer they don't have that
incentive it has a direct impact in how
they conduct clinical trials and we can
see that in
practice so on the on your screen you
can
see um this is from money in.com I I
don't know how reliable that is but I'm
going to assume it's reliable they this
is what they say are the five most uh
top selling drugs of all time from fizer
these are fizer's top most preo 19 okay
um and so according to money Inc these
are the ones that that made fiser the
most money well let's look through this
list um on this list you could see four
of the products have a little bit of a
different clinical trial that was relied
upon to license this product when um in
the First Column you could see is the
name of the drug in the second is the
safety review period This is how long
Adverse Events were looked at after
administration of the drug in the
clinical trial relied upon to license
that product you could see the very last
uh footnote in the in this is the FDA
website. goov you can go to the FDA
website and you can open up the package
insert for every one of these and in
section 6.1 as required by federal
regulations it summarizes the clinical
trial relied upon to license each of
these products so you could see those
numbers for yourself you do not need to
take my word or this uh pinkish chart
word for it um it's right there all on
the FDA website and you could see that
for most of these um it was a multi-year
period of review after looking for
Adverse Events and that they
compared the group getting embro with a
group getting a placebo elquist for
seven years with a placebo and so forth
and it's also they're also blinded so
the clinical trial investigators they
don't know who's getting the placebo
who's getting the drug they follow them
for that period of time and then they
eventually unblind it and they compare
statistically the differential between
those two groups they do it
statistically because you don't want to
introduce bias the manufacturer is the
one who does the trial and so this way
you don't even you're not really sure
what the drug will have effect on human
beings and so this way by by doing it
this way you could see based on a
baseline of placebo what does the safety
profile look like how does it impact the
cardiovascular system how does it impact
your nervous system how does it impact
your digestive system go down the list
of every organ system in your body and
they do that cancer rates and so
forth when it comes to
vaccines the design of these clinical
trials are not as robust pcv13 that
prear 13 is given to babies at 2 four6
months of life and then another shot
later
um that's the only vaccine on this list
and you can see the safety rep period
was half a year and the control used was
the
pcv7 which was the prior version of
prear 13 which is probably okay if prear
7 had been licensed based in a placebo
control trial which we'll take a look at
in a minute but the thing is a half a
year is actually pretty long for a
safety repaired in a vaccine clinical
trial these are the uh safety review
periods and the control used to license
the vaccines given in the first six
months of Life each of these
vaccines are given three times each in
the first six months of life and I can
assure you that if those numbers look
incredible to you that there was only
five days of safety review for the
hepatitis B vaccine given to a newborn
baby uh it is incredible and I didn't if
you told me that without showing me the
proof I wouldn't believe it either and
I'll show you the proof because if I was
trying to make make something up about
vaccines I wouldn't made that up because
it doesn't sound credible or believable
but um I I'll show you that right now in
a second but before I do that I just
want to highlight the difference between
how drugs the clinical trial used to
license drugs versus the clinical trial
relied upon to license most
vaccines in terms of three features how
long um the safety review is at meaning
how long do they monitor for a after the
injection what did they compare it
against and how well powerered it was
meaning how many people were in the
trial those are three features of what
make a good clinical
trial so
um let's take a look at the first one he
be and I'll just show this to you
directly because
um let's just uh I'm going to just go on
the
internet um so everybody can do this
themselves too can you see my screen
there so we're going to go to FDA
license vaccines okay we're going to go
to the FDA
website and these are all the licensed
vaccines in the United States so anybody
wants to go and see what was relied upon
to license any vaccine license it's
right on this page for the most part
Excuse me yes um the only thing we see
is google.com unfortunately oh sorry
um it's not uh going to the
browser let me see if I escape the
presentation oh I know I'm sorry sorry
uh let me see if I do
this can you see a browser
now okay can you see Google Now Okay the
source of all truth here we go uh
sorry uh so we go to FDA licensed
vaccines right here um so you can just
search for FDA licensed vaccines here is
the FDA website right here you could see
at the title it says vaccines license
for use United States
this page has all the vaccines licensed
in the United States by the FDA if you
scroll down what you will see is there
are four Hepatitis B vaccines listed um
two of these are only two of them are
licensed for newborn babies or Comax HB
and andrix spe the other two are just
for adults so we'll click on the first
one Rec Comax
HB then you can go to the package insert
now you know whenever you get a drug
there's a little piece of paper inside
the pack Inside the Box well if you open
up that paper um as long as it's not an
older drug that has hasn't been updated
most of them have been it will have a
table of contents like the one you see
on your screen right now and if you look
at this table of contents you will see
section 6.1 has a clinical trial
experience Federal Regulations require
that the manufacturer summarize what was
the clinical trial allowed upon to
license the product so the manufacturer
prepares this document the FDA approves
this document so we'll go down to
section 6.1 for recova
HB and when you go down to section 6.1
you will see this is the entire summary
this section right here other than the
issues that they did note during the
clinical trial it's just listed 6.2 is
the postmarketing
experience and this paragraph describes
the clinical trial loton a licens this
vaccine for
children I've highlighted it and I'll
read it
now it says in three clinical studies
434 doses of a Comax HB 5 micrograms
were administered to 47 healthy infants
and children up to 10 years of age who
were monitored for 5 days after each
dose now the first time I read that too
I thought well there must be more why
would the FDA license this product for
injection to babies with five days of
monitoring because um you know most
autoimmune issues take weeks minimum to
rise I mean you know we we deal with
vaccin all the time so just like it
takes for example immunity the vaccines
can provide against disease it takes
weeks for those antigens to BU
antibodies to build up self antibodies
antibodies that might attack self those
take at least weeks and then many immune
disregulation like asthma take you know
chally not diagnosed till a few years
old developmental issues you name it
most health issues are not going to be
diagnosed in a newborn within 5 days if
it's caused by the product it can take
months take years that's why for example
on all the other drugs we looked at they
review safety for years against the
placebo so here on the other hand what
are we looking at in terms of how well
powered it is it's only got 147 children
that's not statistic that does not
provide enough power to detect virtually
anything even if it were there's no
control group and then separately the
monitoring is only five days we foed the
FDA and so we've been doing this before
covid we foed the FDA for the actual
documentation just like we did for covid
vaccine that the manufacturer submitted
presuming that in the documentation you
would find safety monitoring review
Adverse Events assessment that went on
beyond the five days and it's five days
of safety monitoring that's what it is
um and and again you don't need to take
my word for it I have um let me go back
to the slideshow I will you can pull up
the um I've got links on every slide in
this presentation I have links typically
to government or other similar sources
where you could see so um you could see
over there I've got the first link is to
the actual package inser we just looked
at the second link is to the clinical
trial report that is on the ican website
because we got the Via Foy request but
obviously if you click on that what you
will see is the first page is that it's
from the FDA and then you will see the
actual clinical trial reports and you
can go into thousand something Pages if
if you if you're inclined you can look
through them yourself and see exactly
what was sub submitted because remember
the FDA doesn't conduct clinical trials
I'm sure you guys know that already the
FDA just reviews the data submitted by
the manufacturer to assess whether to
the level that to the FDA standard of
safe and effective it meets that
standard that's what it's doing
representative Penza
please um this was a hard one for me uh
my daughter is uh vaccine injured from
the hepe so um and I didn't know this
level so there was no Placebo at all in
in in any study she's 17 now so do you
know when this you know study was done
was this when they first were rolling it
out I believe the uh yeah I believe the
the first Rec com back HP I believe was
licensed in ' 89 I believe nxp was
licensed in 91 those would be the only
two Standalone hey vaccines given to
newborn babies
followup and I know that this is kind of
going into what you're going to talk
about in regards with um with covid yes
um
so were there have you seen just in time
from what it used to be of course prior
to
1986 um a level of um speeding things up
in a sense of whether there's no
clinical trials or very minimal in time
frame as as we get close closer to um
here we are you know in in Co speeding
things up in terms of I'm sorry with
rolling things out whether it be you
know vaccines and other types of drugs
that does it seem like things have gone
faster uh um so since things have gone
faster since
1986 but I don't I mean if you look at
the vaccine schedule since 86 it's just
been a straightup trajectory in fact in
the 90s many 90s and 2000s many of the
vaccines currently on the childhood
schedule came about but for the covid
vaccine which I think if you're asking
me about that I don't see the covid
vaccine as rushed in the same way that
the public from my
perspective as being rushed in the same
way that it's been um in in the news all
vaccines um vaccines have different
technology I mean people use the term
vaccines as a general term but for
example this vaccine is a Rec com is a
recombinant technology it's recombinant
DNA so this he type of hepati B vaccine
um uses a very different technology for
example than a measles vaccine which is
an attenuated vaccine or tetanus or
deria which is a toxoid vaccine they all
have very sorry very different
Technologies and often those
Technologies took very decades to
develop so they were working on Rec
combinant DNA technology for a very long
time before they finally came out with
this ATB vaccine when it comes to the
MRNA if you're focused at least on the
fiser and the Mna products obviously J&J
astroica others had more traditional
platforms but the MRNA platform had been
in development for decades right I mean
it took the science that underpins the
creation of mRNA technology has um has
they've been working on that for a very
long time I mean first they were try to
figure out well how do we keep the RNA
from not falling apart because the body
immediately attacks it so they they took
out the urine right and they replace it
with with a synthetic iDine as one of
the amino acids in it and so the body
doesn't recognize it and then they're
like well that's still not good enough
we need to get it into the cell so they
you know positive negative when they're
when they're in contact on the cell
membrane they'll they'll let things in
and so they have the lmps the ban
particles with a different charge that
they put the uh um the the the synthetic
piece of mRNA and so forth that didn't
happen and that didn't like covid-19
didn't come around and they boom they
came up with all that Tech and there's
ton of other Tech related to that that
was decades of development the um Barney
Graham at niad the national insute of
allergy infectious disease he runs the
vaccine Development Division there
that's fou Institute barard gr's been
working on a um mRNA vaccine for the
First Co for for SAR COV 1 for a long
time along with madna before covid SAR
suv2 came around before current covid
virus came around and so um in many ways
they they just kind of took the once
they had the sequence they kind of
that's why they were able to create it
so fast they they pretty much have
developed it so uh I mean from my
perspective it uh no not it's not that
different I mean and the clinical trials
also for the covid vaccines I mean if
you're looking at clinical trials I mean
compared to any other vaccine they were
pretty robust in my opinion if I'm going
to take a vaccine based on how robust
the clinical trial is I'm taking a covid
vaccine every day based on the clinical
trial meaning how long was safety
reviewed covid vaccines was often six
for many of them six months how many
people were in the trial how well
powered they had all 30 to 40,000 people
and whether what was the control they
did have a placebo control fiser madna
they just vaccinated them after an
average duration of two months once it
was emergency authorized so um I don't
know if that that's my perspective on it
I I I think see I don't know there's um
a lot of media Outlets that might
disagree with my view on that
followup based upon some of the research
that I've done uh in regards with just
the technology the MRNA technology um
there's been a lot of information
showing you know what happened with
animals and um and so I I you know we
yes that it had been studied and worked
on and researched for a long time but it
wasn't ready for prime time just because
of you know many of the animals died in
those you know ferrets and and whatnot
in in studies where created a
hyperimmune response and then um yeah
yeah I mean you know um just to make
sure I'm not talking about Mercury at
the Marisol right now that's been pretty
much removed from vaccines in 2000 but
aluminum
adant which is aluminum hydroxide
there's a few different kinds those are
used to to create for example the help
create immune response if I just inject
you with a bunch of dead protein snippet
your body will probably just gobble it
up and get rid of it so if I just took
uh you know a portion of the prosus
bacteria um which is you know basically
it's all amino acid chains right
peptides proteins and I it's dead it's
not replicating it's not taking over
your cells and you just inject it into
you it's going to have uh a minimal
immune response because your macrofagos
your dendritic cells will gobble them up
get rid of them um so you need to create
an an immune response and and how does
the body know that there's danger to
have an immune response you need
cellular death okay viruses infect cells
they take them over they take over the
machinery and they replicate themselves
and the immune system then attacks them
bacteria cause cellular death and when
you do that
debris it causes your you know uh the
inflammation that you see which is
basically the blood flowing in nutrifil
come pouring out of your blood into that
area you cre inflammation you have an
immune response um and if it's sustained
long enough your body goes oh this is
bad it will start grabbing some of the
pieces there and take them to your lymph
nose looking for the correlate antigen
to then create immunity right which we
think of as adaptive immunity right
versus the immunity that happens just at
at the site so um i' say all that to say
aluminum aivant which are still used in
U many
vaccines as the primary ingredient one
of the primary as an active ingredient
to create an immune response because
aluminum adant cause cellular death
that's why an aluminum can can Preserve
stuff for forever it kills everything
it's not human beings have never been
exposed to aluminum all of human history
they're they're locked up with silica in
the ground uh we are you know it's only
in very very modern history for the
first time human beings have ever been
we have a use for iron in the body we
have a use for magnesium our bodies use
all types of different kinds of metals
there's no biological use of aluminum in
the body none that we're aware
of so um but yet that's in vaccines and
if you want to induce um
autoimmunity to something in a lab
animal you know what you inject them
with Lun managements you pair it with
what you want to create the the the the
you know the sensitivity to you and
there are you know lots of studies out
there so yeah you can find studies that
show components of vaccines can cause
harm out there and and I don't you know
I'm not sure it's Unique to covid
vaccines per se I think a main
differential a covid vaccine if I may is
that you know with lots of these like
you with he be vaccines are given to a
tiny cohort of children every year very
small per and and healthcare workers uh
a very very small percentage of folks in
America get that product every year so
it takes you know uh uh decades before
you really get broad coverage um on the
and so if there are going to be issues
with that product well you're not going
to know from the clinical trial
unfortunately um and if it does happen
within the population it's going to
happen at a slow accumulated rate where
it could potentially bleed into the
background rate covid vaccine it was
given to almost 300 million Americans
very very rapidly so the issues that
that product did have um you know just
focusing on the ones that are not you
know Health authorities are willing to
agree are causally related like Martis
pericarditis um thrombosis thrombopenia
so on and so forth um were hard did not
BL bleed into the background it's
possible for example covid vaccines had
slowly been you know introduced in one
court at a time and myocarditis among
children had slowly increased over two
decades U the the ideology of that
increase may have not ever been
attributed to covid-19
vaccines um so U but that's speculation
just to be sure what I just
said
okay um so U this is a deposition just a
little clip of a deposition I took and
and of the world's Premier
vaccinologists so Dr Stanley plin he's
the developer of the rubella vaccine
he's worked done numerous other vaccines
you can go down the list um and
literally the medical textbook on
vaccines is called plins vaccines which
you could see that to the left and this
is my exchange with him with regards to
precisely the hepatitis B vaccine Rec
combo vac HB we just looked at and I
think that that exchange helps bring
home the importance of a clinical trial
um so we'll we'll do this we'll look at
this this is just a few minutes we'll
look at maybe two other vaccines super
quick and then we'll move on to covid
vaccine clinical trials I just want to
make sure I set the table in terms of
clinical trials how the FDA looks at Co
v u trials and so forth to help put the
covid-19 vaccine trials in
context
my
open world
[Music]
inval virus vaccine Ries he has earned
the distinguished physician Award of the
pediatric infe disease Society the
Finland award the national foundation
for infective diseases the H Award of
the American society picology the French
Legion of Honor and the Bruce medal in
preventive medicine he's a member of The
Institute of medicine and the French
Academy of Medicine one of the very
special about him is global impact that
he head not just from the products but
from his book he developed a standard
textbook for vaccines 1988 Bill Gates
calls his book The Bible for
vaccinologist I hope you all have indeed
read the book uh and I hope it's more
accurate than the Bible he trained just
a generational scientist included myself
to uh to think like he
think
Dr specified that there are two heavy
vaccines in the market one by Glo GSK
that's NX and the other one is by
Mer HD right yes this is the product the
manufacturer insert for comx HD correct
yes and the clinical trial experience
would be found in section 6.1
correct yes
in section
6.1 when you look at the clinical trials
that were done preure for comac HB how
long does it
sayit five days is dayss
long to
neurolog does not mention
any you turn to section
6.2 under immune system
disorders does it say that there were
reports of hypers sensitive reaction
yes that's whattis
like Sy
vtis
potis
correct yes that's what it states and
also states
that multiple
sceris exacerbation multiple sceris
sey
weak correct
these
after in order to establish whether it's
between the vaccine and condition you
need a random a
randomized and given that thex now
appears on the CDC reced list isn't true
that it would now be considered
unethical to conduct such a study today
it would be
yes so I think that that you know that
highlights put in this way it's it's
always good to read and see kind of so
to speak both sides of it but there you
have it directly from the world's
leading
vaccinologists terms of the importance
of clinical trials how you show cation
um and the issues with having clinical
trial that short I didn't even talk
about the fact it was underpowered in
that in that
clip take super quick look at two more
and then let's turn to Clin uh covid
vaccines fizer's PCV 13 this prevenar 13
vaccine um this is the one we looked at
earlier remember on that chart of five
purportedly fizer's five bestselling
drugs um and so um here it is on the CDC
childood
schedule now
um when you look at at the very top
that's from the package insert of prear
13 all right there is actually a newer
version I reached and came out prevenar
20 but prevenar 13 um is still available
and when they did the clinical trial for
prevenar 13 they did six months of
safety
review still not long enough in my
estimation for a baby but at least
certainly for the work that we do we'
like far longer safety review
against a proper control but 6 months
nonetheless and in that clinical trial
you could see in the very top it says
serious Adverse Events reported
following vaccination and infants and
todders occurred in
88.2% among pror 13 recipients and 7.2%
among prear that's prear 7 recipients
Now understand a serious adverse event
means something very very serious on the
F for the FDA it's
I uh let me see it's worth just stopping
for a second and opening up the FDA
website and looking at what that
definition
means um here we go what is a serious
adverse event is a technical term used
by the FDA um typically for clinical
trials it means death life-threatening
hospitalization disability or permanent
damage congenital anomaly birth defect
requireed intervention to prevent
permanent impairment or damage or other
serious it usually requires one of the
other conditions above along with with
another feature so when you look at
serious Adverse Events serious Adverse
Events means something very serious and
um these are typically you only enroll
children who are healthy in these
clinical trials so you have healthy
infants and toddlers who within 6 months
8.2% of them have a serious adverse
event um if uh a .2% of all infants and
todders had a serious adverse event
every six months that would be pretty
bad in this country um but that said um
it's deemed safe by the FDA because the
comparator group and that's how you you
do safety and clinical trials you
compare the experimental group that
getting the experimental product along
with the control group um and in this
instance they receive the standard of
care which is considered appropriate um
prear 7 and it could have have been
appropriate absolutely if prear 7 had
been licensed based on a placebo control
trial itself that was properly powered
and so forth so you knew the safety
profile provar 7 that in my opinion that
would have been a valid comparator but
let's take a look at what the clinical
trial was relied upon to licens prear
7 in the chart right below that um you
can see this is an excerpt from the
clinical trial for prevenar 7 that
clinical Tri reviewed safety for 30
days and the control group received and
you can see right there I highlighted in
the
footnote right you can see it says
control dose one you can see prear 7
control prear 7 control right and then
it's got a little like a um cross looks
like and if you go down it defines what
the control is and the control is an
investigational meaning not licensed
meaning
experimental investigational Menin
cockle Group C conjugate vaccine mncc
this product was never
licensed so in the clinical trial to
license perar 7 and if you want to know
why they did this you got to talk to the
FDA but they did facts are just there in
black and white they licensed prevenar
7 based on a clinical trial that
compared
it to another experimental vaccine
again if you told me this I wouldn't
believe you in the street but I I'm this
is on the FDA site you could see the
links right there at the top of each of
them you can go look at these yourself
and you can also pull out the
underlying documentation from the
manufacturer
um it's interesting because too because
when you know when we are doing uh we
got a lot of injury cases from this
product and when we do them and you look
at the uh uh you know to PubMed and you
look at the postmarketing license U
literature the fact that this was not
really studied before it was licensed
properly is actually ubiquitous in the
literature itself um but in any
event so um that's prar 13 and then
we'll look at last one is daap you know
this is um this one was compared against
dtp so again to highlight the importance
of what the control group receives
because otherwise so what so you know
you get one group got 7% adverse event
one's 8% you say well that's similar so
it's safe might be safe by FDA standards
but I don't know how safe it would be
from the perspective of a typical
parent question please yes
representative thank you um just uh for
clarification because I'm taking notes
so with the prear uh the PCB 13 you said
serious Adverse Events was 8.2 and in
the um prevenar 7 control what was the
rate uh uh yes it's on the screen 7.2%
among the prar seven recipients it's the
top uh slide oh you can't see it I'm so
sorry we'll get we'll get these later
right uh yes and this you'll get the
whole slideshow later and this is on the
FDA uh website do you want me to go to
the FDA website I've I've been pulling
it up thank you okay I just wanted to
get it in my notes thank you sure no
problem okay and then you've got dtp V
dap that's the one that um was disced a
bit earlier wholesale protus vaccine
which is stopped being used in the
United States um and uh and actually
there's no developed country that uses
dtp anymore it's only used in developing
countries around the world and
interestingly it's uh and the current
daap vaccine using the United States you
might say well that's
better it's better in terms of safety
profile and dtp from um the data that's
for sure but the dtp yes sorry
so um I'm trying to
understand
if they
understood that the tort
liability for
dtp was times 200 and it was causing
adverse effects yes but then in this
chart they Ed that as the control
yes right and um that's
uh
yes and and and maybe more troubling is
the fact that um one of the one of the
renowned um clinics in uh in Guinea BAU
it's they're from they're Danish um who
experts in vaccines and so forth Peter
AB he world renown uh until he published
this study in a series of studies like
this then he was not so world not
anymore EXC represent
po thank you Madame chair and uh thank
you for your presentation help me
understand this question about large
thoughts potential thought against
vaccines is it unique for this product
because we know that many other medical
products have side effects and sometimes
it takes time like we know that aspirine
can have some severe side effects we
know that many people take stattin and
there are some new research that statins
might be not so effective and have some
side effects so what is it about
vaccines that manufacturers were uh
feeling threatened by that amount of
potential t uh against
vaccines they were causing
injuries so um the worst the injury the
more damages you get and the damages um
and the injuries were were severe so um
U you know at that time two of those
three products are no longer with us opv
and
dtp though the D and the T part are
still part of
dap um I mean maybe I could answer your
question a little bit of a different way
and say look there's um there are a lot
of drugs that are made all the time and
a lot of times those drugs are made for
very small populations they're not meant
for millions of people every year in a
guaranteed Market where it's mandated
right often um and yet pharmaceutical
companies find a way to make profit from
those even when they're given to a small
group of sick people right so I I you
know the argument often made is that
well they need to make money well
they're making a lot of money on
vaccines in fact the it's an increasing
percentage of the portfolio of Merk
fiser copi and GSK particular Mna is a
newer player um so um U excuse me but
also yes it means interrup if if you
didn't finished we have another question
oh yeah sure uh so I you know obviously
I don't know what's in the hearts and
minds of the Congress when they passed
the 1986 act though I can say that in
the 70s there was the swine flu vaccine
debac you may recall that and it caused
GBS and other issues and CDC you know
denied it then admitted part of it and
so um the manufacturers were afforded
immunity remember back then cuz they um
and and that worked out well for them
and so you know from an industry
perspective the 86 Act made sense again
you know you guys know this legislative
bodies are complex lots of people lots
of Interest lots of moving pieces uh I'd
rather litigate all day long than than
than to hang out in uh the halls of what
you folks do I give you guys a lot of
credit to get along and it's wonderful
um but um uh yeah I mean I think that
that I think that could have been instru
Ive and certainly helped Drive the
industry also the parents at that time
who had vaccine or children actually
also were um helped
drive drive the the adoption of the ACT
but when its initial iteration didn't
include immunity liability its initial
iteration was intended for compensating
injured children in something called the
vaccine injury Compensation Program the
uh the liability protection was added at
the last second so you know um it was it
was a debated point but you know there
was a there was a Confluence of
interests of different people who wanted
different things and you ended up with
what you ended up please I'm sorry
representative Penza thank you madam
chair um my research on DPT and I I just
wanted to um if you are familiar and I'm
sure you are um wasn't wasn't we were
kind of like forced into it there were
wasn't there decades that went by where
other countries had dropped that and we
were
still yeah so Japan was the first to in
the 70s um to switch off of wholesale
pusis and um other countries as you
noted um dropped it um by the 90s I
don't think there was virtually any
developed country that was using I think
we were probably one of the last ones I
would want to verify that um but um I
would have known this at one point
because we had a long exchange with
UNICEF about this precise product
because all the studies um
show there's a dozen studies that show
that actually kids you get dtp versus
not have increased overall mortality
there's less deaths from tetanus less
deaths from pusis and less deaths from
deia but all C mortality amongst those
who get dtp versus not in this
particular study you could see right
here in Guinea that was done by Peter AB
you had 10 times the number of kids 10
times kids who died who got TP
only versus um kids who got nothing so
um this has actually been a big
controversy at the who um and UNICEF
because UNICEF is the main procur and
distributor of dtp vaccine worldwide
it's the most common widely used vaccine
in the world um the in in in I don't
want to get too far astray from covid
vaccines but in 200 The Who convened a
they have bunch of advisory vaccine
committees and they convened a committee
to actually specifically look at what
they call the non-specific effects of
vaccines death
beyond all cause death would be
considered a non-specific effect meaning
it's having effect that's not intended
by the product and the question was you
know do does does this vaccine increase
or reduce mortality the uh wh report
from 2016 I
believe found about 15 studies I think
around 12 of them showed an increase
risk three showed I believe a decreased
risk and they found it inconclusive now
all those studies mind you are all and
this goes back to what we were talking
about earlier they're all retrospective
epidemiological studies as they must be
they're not prospective they're not
clinical trials so proven causation it's
very difficult right even though this
study right that it's on your screen
found at 10 times risk even that from an
epidemiological perspective cannot prove
causation because it's looking at it
histo typically historically I mean
sometimes a body of evidence is just
overwhelming and they'll look at case
reports they'll put in all kinds of
other things that they look at or and
especially when they can find a
mechanism of action so with all of that
said the conclusion that the who reached
at the time was they said
well there's three
problems with all of these studies
number one they were introduced along
with opv vaccine so we don't know what
the effect effect of opv is versus dtp
one number two they were introduced in
an environment where deot tennis and
prosus were not common anymore what
would the numbers look like if you did
the study when there was no vaccine
around right meaning when the vaccine
was first introduced because that is you
have a different background population
and
disease um and those are the two uh and
the third issue they took was they said
it's not randomized sufficiently okay so
uh these folks AB again you can look
them up you can look up Peter AB
Christine Ben they are uh I mean they'll
tell you measles vaccine is the best
thing since sliced bread right they'll
tell you that um attenuated vaccines
have uh uh the opposite effect right um
they're they're incredible that means
they they're no uh they're in any event
the the important point is this they did
this study to address exactly those
three
issues one they looked at it without opv
as you can see on this chart two they
looked at the data from when dtp was
first introduced into Guinea basau to
get rid of the background rate issue and
the way it was introduced was is that
they vaccinated kids based on Bas
essentially birthdays which is
considered a valid form of randomization
so they said hey look who UNICEF we
addressed your three issues uh so we we
actually our firm had a long exchange
with the wh excuse me with UNICEF about
this we said here it is this is the best
data you're ever going to get unless you
do a clinical trial which you're never
going to do this is it you're never
getting better data than this uh UNICEF
engaged in an exchange and then decided
that there they um they didn't have a
respon there is no there is no better
data we demanded it over and over they
wouldn't provide it we actually
petitioned the uh um the
ICC um which has jurisdiction over
UNICEF uh but they declined to
investigate further anyways that's a
that's that's a digression but yes dtp
DPT was used as the control for daap and
so this shows you I do all that to show
you know this was all the exchanges we
had with the government I I do all that
to show you the I just want to highlight
the U wow that was lucky
take lucky take lucky over good any day
um uh the the three real features the
important features of a clinical trial
which are how long the safety was
reviewed what was the control and um
[Music]
uh and and uh the duration of excuse me
and how powered it is how many people
participated and I show you what that
looks like in the world of vaccines
versus drugs and I think think that
could help put into context how the FDA
then approached covid vaccines drugs are
licensed in the there's a drug division
at the FDA and then there's a biologics
division and the biologics division is
just separate and the biologics is
primarily vaccines there are other
biologics Beyond V biological products
um but um um that is for them those type
of Trials are pretty typical if uh I
I'll throw this out there too if anybody
wants to see any all the specific
specifics for each of the can you see
the chart on your screen yeah um this is
the you can go to this chart and this
chart has for those who are interested
every single current vaccine and it's
got a link to the FDA website to the
clinical trial data that was relied upon
to lient as well as a summary chart you
can see what the control was you can see
how long the safety review period was
after injection and you could see the
sources all back to the FDA or in some
instances the sources are back to the I
can website because it was done via Foya
we foyer for most of these underlying
documents to see and you can and a
little note there that kind of gives
some context for some of them to
understand what was it because um the
current product if they're testing
against a prior product then you want to
know okay well that prior product what
was that tested against and obviously
that's good that that's important to
know okay covid-19 vaccines so uh here
we are um for the fer madna there were
about 20 15 to 20,000 folks in each in
the experimental group versus the
placebo group we mentioned this earlier
already on average there was a placebo
control group on average it was for two
months um meaning once it was emergency
youth authorized they vaccinated pretty
much the entire placebo group um
Des despite the FDA actually kind of
pushing them car compies not to do it to
to the fda's credit frankly um but they
did it anyway um they send letters out
to all them essentially saying hey you
can come and get this more or less and
when I say an average of two months just
make sure what that means is some had
been in the trial for four months some
had been in for one month but on average
the placebo control group had been in
for around two months okay so there were
some that were more than two
months okay um and obviously that's in
contrast to the other vaccines so from
the fda's perspective despite the public
saying these clinical trials are not
robust enough they don't meet to
historical standards these CL trials are
incredibly robust based on historical
standards certainly from the FDA perspec
certainly from the perspective of Dr
Peter marks who runs the biologic
division the vaccine division the FDA I
think he thinks these trials were
incredible from his perspective and when
you know beyond what they typically had
done historically certainly from
virtually all the childhood vaccines um
ju just a quick question on that now you
mentioned that the FDA pushed back and
asked them to keep the placebo group is
that my understanding yes the the FDA
preferred expressed a preference and we
I we know this we have you know um we do
a lot of FO requests on the internal
Communications they expressed a
preference and this was also spilled
over into the media too this was not
just in the internal documents they
expressed the preference that the
placebo group uh remain
intact um obviously not to the degree
where the uh the for government felt
they must
but they did Express a preference C at
least certain corners of them did and as
you know there was also an inter you
know I familiar with Dr guber and Dr
Krauss at the FDA they were the they
were the the P the two people directly
below Peter marks they quit and you know
in the middle of it and anyways um there
are committee hearings like this right
now where Peter marks and all those
folks are being hauled in is my
understanding and closed R rooms though
right so
I guess my question is is if the
FDA could they have insisted or did they
have any control over it um and saying
even though it is going to be used as an
emergency use you still need to keep
that placebo group intact so that we can
so the procurement contracts had already
been signed Pharma companies had already
received billions of dollars um the
presidents of the United States first
Trump then Biden had both widely touted
promoted these products to the American
public assured everybody to get it
operation War speed was in full was in
full swing um I don't think the Pharma
companies were probably very worried
that the FDA was going to pull their
authorizations going to speculate that
I'm going to go on limb represent Penza
thank you madam chair
um based upon um specifically the the
control group and keeping that in a
sense pure
um
doesn't history compared to other I
don't call the covid injections uh
vaccines I call them experimental gene
therapy um I don't like using the word
vaccine for it but in any case is there
history of that happening um does that
usually happen in any other um you know
in history with other quote unquote
traditional vaccines I'm like where
we're keeping things separate so we can
have data stay in a in a in a pure
fashion because after 30 days you're
saying they injected the the placebo or
the control group well
well um they once it was given eua
approval the fiser Mna
respectively I'll say you could say
offered but really I mean when you look
at the way they were offering it they
were really in my opinion encouraging
all of the participants
to um if they
wanted they could they could go to fiser
or mad and say hey I'd like to be
unblinded I'd like to know what where I
got the placebo or the vaccine and
because for the
purposes if they got the placebo to get
the shop and so most of them did
that
followup where where where where well
here's the thing here's part of the I
believe what the f day was was I believe
was was saying to him said
look we had the Institute of medicine do
this this big study of who should get
the shots because they're not going to
have limited Supply at the beginning so
you recall the Institute of medicine
which is now known as the National
Academy of Medicine uh put out
a report and they assess okay uh first
you know there you know those
prioritizations between the elderly and
healthare workers and so forth you guys
remember that back in December 2020 and
so different cohorts of Americans
depending on their station and what they
did were were supposed to get in line so
to speak and and and get the shot and so
one of the arguments that that was even
made I believe at the time to by I think
the FDA if not directly at least
insinuated this and said look these
clinical tribe participants are not in
that line they're not they're not the
folks who should even be getting it
now right December 2020 why don't you at
least wait for them to get it in the
normal course so when they're when
they're up in the queue and let's say
April after the elderly got it the
healthare workers got it school teachers
got it I don't remember the queue by the
way I I might I might get the order
wrong I don't remember who got what
first um I just I do remember there's a
big report on it
um so fine so if they're a healthcare
worker they should get it when they get
it but if they're like a healthy
22-year-old you know and they're they're
not up until July then let them get it
in July like everybody else why
rush to go and vaccinate the entire
placebo
group why it's a great
question should ask your whoever you
have here testifying to answer that it's
a great question I don't have the answer
though you should but you should
probably bring in uh a pharmaceutical
representative from Mna fiser and ask
them that question it's a great
question I think the answer is pregnant
but we'll I don't want to speculate okay
so uh look uh as we talked about
earlier and now we'll get into some of
the data in the F clinical
trial
um when you do a clinical trial the
whole idea is you are evaluating a
product that's new you don't know the
effects on the human body and hence you
want to avoid bias and you do a
statistical comparison right it's kind
of like the way you design design you do
studies often in science you have a
study plan and you stick to it you don't
change it midc course right uh you don't
want to inject bias
so what is the most important thing that
we're trying to prevent with covid-19
vaccines it was death right that was the
idea um to be
sure 2019 versus 2020 I think something
like an additional 400,000 Americans Di
all cause mortality so in 2019 I think
there was 2.7 million Americans died or
something like that in 201 23.2 million
died Co presumably killed some of those
folks if not many how much of it had to
do with changes that we implemented as a
society that'll be debated probably
forever but what we want to do is avoid
injecting that bias and so in the
clinical
trial here's a report from fizer
in July
2021 excuse me and it was in the New
England Journal of Medicine and in that
report as of July 2021 remember the
vaccine was authorized in December of
2020 so this is now s months later
clinical trial data is finally coming
out in a publish public form and what it
showed was that in the vaccinated grp in
the experimental group 15 people died
died all cause not covid all
cause and 14 died in the placebo group
all
cause they said I believe two died of Co
in the placebo one died of Co in the
vaccinated group so the vaccine was I
that wasn't considered statistically
significant to reduce death so they
never claimed it dead and you can look
at the eua and you can look at the lier
documents they don't claim it reduces
deaths because it's not statistically
significant finding
um and I'm not saying that 15 to 14 is a
statistically significant finding either
because it's not but it it please so
what you're saying
is in their clinical trial in July
2021 15 people that were vaccinated died
and 14 that had the placebo died and it
could have been for any reason any
reason all cause mortality any any
reason whatsoever
okay and but of those
15 that were vaccinated one actually
died of covid and in the placebo group
two actually died of covid that's my
that's my understanding thank
you uh representative
Penza based upon that July 2021 report
the placebo was it still truly the
placebo it yeah it was the placebo group
for the duration that they had placebo
group right meaning it was a it was it
was at this point really historical data
but it but that's when it was published
in the New England Journal medicine so
and I was you know at that point we were
already fighting with the FDA to get all
this data and the FDA and the FDA fought
us and said no we're not giving it to
you we'll give it to you at a pace of
500 pages a month which would have taken
75 years based on the number of
documents they had told us at that point
so um so but here's the interesting part
about this comparison okay when you
drill down and this chart that you see
in front of you is a is a a uh
shows the cause of death attributed for
each one of these people that died so
when you drill down into the causes of
death what you do find is
that those that died from cardiovascular
reasons were dying at twice the rate
pretty much in the vaccinated group so
you know all little Rose in red I don't
know if you could see it but um you know
basically Cardiac Arrest cardiac failure
and so forth you know heart
attacks there were two six seven eight
nine nine folks in the vaccinated group
that died from card cardiovascular
issues but in the placea group one two
three four five died of cardiovascular
issues now that
differential in I and again you should
you you'd want to have an EP
statistician look at that but that
that's quite a differential and there's
one group that's did an analysis of that
that
does provide that it's significant that
but I limited what I was citing here
today to only FDA CDC and high impact
Journal sources for the most part so
that folks everybody can feel
comfortable with the data they're
looking at thank you representative
beler thank you madam chair um I just
want to
get a little bit of detail to
help paint this picture because we're
talking we're talking July of 21 we're
talking the height really of of fear and
panic yeah over Co were talking at the
time where they were issuing an
emergency youth use authorization for a
drug to treat this pandemic that was a
lot of fear being struck into people's
hearts first can you tell me am I
accurate that the total size of this
study was was roughly 60,000 is that uh
the total size was about 40 43,000
people okay 43,000 so about 21 it's you
could see it at the top there at the end
there's about 21,900 in each of these
two groups okay and the total length of
the study was about how long
um so the uh at least the safety review
period was six months six months at
least at least pursuant to the the study
plan
so to really clarify at the height of
the pandemic in a clinical study in
which over 40,000 people a pandemic that
was striking fear into the people's
hearts that this was going to be rampant
and and kill tons and tons and tons of
people we had a total of 29 deaths
occurring out of
43,000 over a six-month period in the
clinical trial yes thank thank
you now um represent POS off oh
please thank you for taking question
just to clarify I understand so
21,000 people in the placea group they
were observed for six months but they
were vaccine free only for first two
months on average they were yes that's
right they they um when they crossed
over so they turned it into a crossover
stud
first place when they crossed over into
the VAC became vaccinated they continued
to follow them so um actually within the
the folks in the placebo who became
unblinded there were five additional
deaths in the vaccin group but obviously
it's hard to compare that to anything
because there was no they were the
placebo group but yes on average two
months yeah they continue to observe
them um interest interestingly when the
FDA apparently crunched the numbers they
issued a report on this data so what I
just showed you here this is what fizer
told the public in the New England
Journal of Medicine in July 2021 you can
read the article yourselves in New
England Journal of
Medicine then you can go and on the
bottom left there is the link to the FDA
report so this is the FDA summary report
with regards to the fiser trial and in
the FDA
report it said 21 people died in the
vaccinated group and 17 died in the
placebo group During the period that
they were meaning they they matched them
up so that they were looking at them in
like
durations right meaning it's not the
vaccinated group the 21 deaths were not
continuing to look Beyond when the
essentially the VAC placeo group was
vaccinated so here you are in November
of 2021
and the FDA is finally releasing what
the clinical trial data shows and from a
statistical comparison which is the way
these trials should be
done you had 21 according to the FDA
deaths in the vaccinated Group 17 in the
PBO group all cause mortality if the
purpose of this product was to reduce
deaths the trial certainly didn't show
that on an all cause mortality
basis now what's extremely concern and
there's the quote from dose 1 through
March 31 2021 date data cut off date
right there were a total 38 deaths 21
the commodity group and 17 the place
group N deaths were considered related
to vaccination well who did that who
considered them unrelated
visor it is under the fda's regulations
for conducting clinical trials it is the
sponsor so the who guidance would
actually have left it to the principal
investigator of each clinical trial site
which would also be paid by foser but in
the US the FDA um actually leaves it to
the sponsor themselves to to make a
causality
determination here's the interesting
part from my perspective for what it's
worth when it came to for example
determining this vaccine was e
efficacious at reducing symptoms right
what did they license it based on not
reduction of mortality remember if
anybody read the eua documentation at
the time not reduction in serious harm
but on the reduction of of symptoms
and they did that by doing a comparison
where they said there was about I forgot
the number now six seven or eight folks
in the vaccine group that had symptoms
that tested positive with some symptoms
and there were about hundred something
in the placebo group who tested positive
with symptoms putting aside that there
were about 600 other people who were
never tested who had symptoms and there
were a few thousand people with symptoms
in the study that they put us and and
this is all done by Peter Doshi at
University of Maryland after we got all
the data from the clinical trial from
the FDA you could see that there were
thousands of individuals in this trial
who should have been tested too and who
knows what the outcome would have been
but they did a statistical comparison
between those numbers and they said 95%
effective because you had only had about
you know whatever six or seven in the
VAC in the vaccinated with some symptoms
that tested positive and about a 100 in
the placebo that uh had some symptoms of
tested positive
they didn't look under the hood there
they didn't do a individualized inject
your judgment bias into the study to
make that comparison they said nope 95%
effective but when it came to the deaths
the more important number then they let
fiser inject its bias and do a death
byde assessment of whether it's related
and lo and behold despite 21 deaths in
the vaccinated in 17 the placebo out my
numbers fda's numbers it's on their you
can look at it
yourself they let fiser conclude that
none of them are related to
vaccination um um yes excuse me
so when did the FDA know I mean this
they're saying that this report was
November 2021 and the other one was July
of 2021 but when did
fizer I mean the FDA actually know what
the numbers were do we know
that I don't know the precise state that
fizer submitted the data to the FDA or
when Marx grber Krauss or their
statistical reviewer FB teams finally
looked at it and crunched it but
um I mean this is also just to be sure
not uncommon um in the sense that the uh
assessment of causality unfortunately it
shouldn't be this way and I don't know
why it is but is left to the
sponsor for things like
this uh represent
leus has any um followup been done as
far as who those 100 people were and who
those six or seven people were and their
characteristics and how they were chosen
any of that yeah uh uh yes uh the
uh the British medical journal the bmj
considered one of the most prestigious
journals in the world um not in a
peer-reviewed studies in that journal to
be sure but in pieces published by at
least one of the members of the
editorial staff uh Dr Peter Doshi who is
a pharmacologist at the University of
Maryland he took an interest to his
credit in looking at those numbers
carefully and what I was saying to you
earlier about how when he looks at the
data they let let me put it this way we
had millions of Americans test all day
long every other day right they could
have easily just had all 43,000
participants tests once a week done
easily right then you would know whether
the vaccine stop transmission you would
know every instance of somebody who had
symptoms whether or not they had uh
where they were in the VAC whether they
had Co or the vaccine unac but they
didn't do that they didn't do that they
only tested in certain instances in the
clinical trial and so that's why you
ended up with those small
numbers to be sure a lot of like I was
saying before there were hundreds of
people that had symptomatologies
consistent potentially with covid in the
trial that were not tested that
that's that's just what that's just what
the clinical trial documents show uh why
that's another question that you maybe
you can ask you know you should bring in
Peter Marks here and ask him why would
they do that it would have been so easy
to just test everybody once a week but
representative
po I think what you just brought up in
regards with testing is is huge um just
to kind of I'd have to go look it up but
when um when did the whether it was the
CDC or the FDA come out with and and
basically pull the PCR test wasn't that
in was that December of 22 when they
came out I know they came out with a
statement several months earlier because
um they knew that the tests were not
accurate it of course it depended on how
the Cycles were um it you know you could
test positive for covid even though you
might have had Co and you had antibi all
of that kind of stuff so kind of
understanding that um yeah I I it's a
it's a great question actually I don't
know the interplay between the timing of
these study these trials and uh when
they updated and and um corrected the
PCR testing um I I don't know it's good
question though I don't know followup
thank you madam chair um my other
question is okay so this report came out
November
2021 and from their quote from dose 1
through March 13 2021 so do we know when
that dose one was
so yes so what was the time frame from
dose 1 till March 13 2021 and since
you're from answering before you said it
was historical are we sure that those
that that placebo group was not injected
from dose one to March 13
um they
so uh
they were there were folks in the place
group that were injected during that
period but this comparison is is is is
um doing a comparison basically on a
times sensitive basis between the
placebo and the vaccinated group it
would be
invalid invalid to compare the
vaccinated group for the entire duration
of the trial against just the placebo
group for a limited which because it was
a more limited time period so they you
you time adjust it to add to end up with
basically uh apples to compare to Apples
so these are supposed to be comparison
now also this wasn't to to be sure this
wasn't retrospective in that the trial
itself was prospective and had they just
an arate statistical comparison that
would be what you're supposed to do in a
prospective trial by letting fiser
inject its bias it basically converted
it into a retrospective study like going
back to this chart from July where you
could see had nine deaths from
cardiovascular issues amongst the 15
that died in the vaccinated and five
deaths in the placea group from
cardiovascular issues like that should
have been a statistical comparison that
should have been done and it wasn't it's
just teased out we teased it out but
it's in there it's sitting right there
in the reported data because they just
say they just let fiser conclude none of
these are related shouldn't have done
that in my opinion they should have done
is just forced the statistical
comparison okay we had nine card
cardiovascular deaths in the vaccinated
five in the placebo group that's a
pretty big differential that's something
we should you know uh uh that could be
statistically significant or at the
least say look whole point here is to
reduce mortality and if it's we're
having more deaths in the vaccin group
that's an issue maybe we shouldn't let
fiser determine causality you know it's
not like these F it's not like 10 folks
in the placebo group were in a plane
crash
okay they were dying of things actually
that you could and we now know can be
ascribed to the vaccine in some degree
right cardiovascular issues for example
okay so
um we asked the SDA by the way this
precise question we said are you not are
you is it too small on the screen oh
okay so so I we sent a letter to the FDA
and you can there's a link to it we said
why are the death data from a randomized
control trial treated like a clinical
case series like a retrospective study
rather than an RCT when it comes to
assessing causality right they didn't do
that for the other stuff but they did it
for death why so the fda's response was
uh we're unable to respond substantively
at this time due to Resource constraints
and the ongoing pandemic response and
now that was years ago we followed up
numerous times since then um they they
still have no answer to that really
important question and of all the
questions you don't have time for they
should had an answer to this question on
they should have had it like this it's
not something you should have to look
into but there's still no response to
that they complain they also went on in
the letter to complain about how much we
sue them and and Foy of them but you
know uh in any event um uh excuse me
representative Belcher thank you madam
chair and I I want to quickly return to
kind of what I was trying to get at
before which is we have this study
43,000 people over a period of six
months at the height of the fear of the
pandemic um we have a grand total of I
believe it was 29 um deaths during that
period of time of which three were
attributed to
covid
now I understand because you as you
mentioned there was some perhaps
somewhat convoluted rationale given for
approving the emergency youth author
authorization for the drug but I'm
actually want to go one step back from
that and say in six months 43,000 people
being studied three died of covid what
was the justification for the emergency
in the first
place um I mean the just
uh I'll answer like a lawyer uh the
justifications are set out by the
president in his Declaration of
Emergency the secretary and his secretor
HS in his and in the FDA and their uh in
their rationale for granting emergencies
authorization I mean they're they they
do lay them out why they believe these
were emergencies at the
time represent TZ thank you um thank you
uh you've been laying out a lot of
really helpful information so what I'm
wondering is a couple things is were
there other clinical trials and then by
July of 20121 how many people had
received a covid vaccine worldwide and
what kinds of impacts did we see and
then related to the last question what
was the sort of um population of
participants in the clinical trial
versus the people who were actually
dying from covid um let's focus on the
United States because you know we we we
already agreed there were people who
were more at risk yeah um you know age
other things yeah yeah I mean according
to the CDC I believe the average age of
somebody dying from covid is pretty
close to the average age of people who
just die in General on all cause basis
um so obviously it it the the average
age of death from covid was really high
so to answer your last question in terms
of what is the demographics of those in
the clinical trial versus the
demographics of those in the general
population um uh the clinical trial.gov
would have a copy of the uh should have
that information um how much of a
onetoone it is I don't know offand but
that can be easily uh assessed um I I
mean I'm I'm C I do know that certain
high-risk groups are not included in the
clinical trial because that creates
complications though there were some
folks um in terms of your other two
questions I think my next slide might
two slides might answer that your I
think might answer your question um and
that is um if you look over here you
know you can debate all day long whether
or not somebody died of covid or did
they die of covid vaccine or did they
die of lockdown or you know you I'm sure
you all are familiar with this debate
out there there's been a lot of debate
about how do you attribute the
deaths um did we more people die because
they now didn't have aners to can Cancer
Care did they die because they didn't
have access to what have
you
um one number that's hard to debate
typically it's typically binary is death
either you died or you didn't die and so
looking at all cause mortality just
meaning all deaths period I think helps
provide uh not a perfect way to look at
the answerers to your question
representative but um but but I think a
window into an answer to your question
so in 2019 this is all CDC data and got
the link right there it said that preco
there were 2.85 million deaths deaths
registered in the United
States in
2020 there were 3.38 million deaths so
um and and um that's when Co was raging
through the country if you watch the
news um and presumably those who are
most susceptible to covid would have
died during that period That's when
there was the nursing homes and a lot of
folks were were dying who were elderly
the first covid
vaccine was authorized in December of 20
December 20th I believe of
2020 and pretty much nobody got the shot
until basically
2021 and so if covid vaccine was going
to have a significant reduction in
mortality in America you would
presumably see it in the all cause
mortality number right I mean look you
did
there were what is that
like uh about 500,000 more deaths in
2019 2020 it's a lot more deaths right
so that's way above
Baseline you'd expect a reduction
especially because presumably those who
are most susceptible to death from covid
would have succumbed in 20120 but yet in
2021 when we went and we vaccinated
most of America and to answer your
question if you look on the left that's
a chart of the daily covid-19 vaccine
doses administered so um every it's
supposed to be a daily data point I mean
at that there was one day alone few
months into 2020 where they vaccinated
3.5 million Americans this is just the
United
States so you know in the first few
months they vaccinated I don't know the
remember exactly but it was a lot of
folks um you know going through 2020
they basically had fully vaccinated I
mean majority of Americans had gotten
the sh a super majority of Americans had
gotten the
shot but yet you did not see all cause
mortality go down you in fact saw it go
up the CDC registered in 2021 after we
vaccinated the whole country 3.46
million deaths
and the part that I think should have
been alarming to health
authorities is that the average age of
deaths
skewed towards a younger curve so you
had more younger folks as compared to
2020 dying but even if we put that
aside if you want to argue that covid
vaccines reduce mortality I think these
numbers make give make it a harder case
to make um and and you know I I use
these numbers because I've you know when
you look at all the studies out there
you've got the clinical trial data that
clearly shows far more people died in
the vaccinated group then what are you
left with you're left with again people
taking historical
data and introducing their bias to it
epidemiological studies and there's lots
of them out there and they by the way
they cut both ways there's all kinds of
studies about mortality and covid
vaccines some of them
um huge cohorts some small cohorts some
more robust than others but most of them
historical except for a number of
countries who were publishing weekly or
monthly statistics on mortality
hospitalizations cases and transmission
like England like Scotland and when the
numbers inverted between the vaccine
unvaccinated group all those cohorts
disappear we have copies of those if the
committee would like them um and they
sto publishing those numbers again just
that's just a historical fact so um so
uh the numbers interestingly in my
assessment that you see all CA in a
population basis in the United States
comports actually with the clinical
trial data on a statistical level
um
and you also if you look at the you
might say okay well maybe more people
died overall but maybe we had less covid
deaths this is also far from uh I
wouldn't get on a stand and testify to
this under a Darbo standard in federal
court but you you can eyeball this chart
um you know and you can look at the
cumulative confirmed covid deaths
according to our world in data okay as
reliable that is they they say it's wh
covid-19 dashboard so they're sourcing
from The Who and they're saying and you
can look actually starting when they
started the vaccination the death curve
doesn't flatten in fact if you look at
it
um uh after you know this the peaking
covid vaccine
so in any event you can make any
epidemiological studies show anything
you want um the large numbers on the
statistical basis I think are are
probably more reliable to look at okay
and really um you know we I'm not going
to say this again but really why bother
conducting a clinical trial if the num
if when the numbers you when the numbers
don't show what you want then you do a
subjective assessment but when they show
what you want you do it
statistically doesn't make sense to me
um and um I'm going to show you just uh
uh I'm going to go through a few more
little data points here about the trials
one is and then we'll wrap up the
clinical trial piece of this um so um
the fiser clinical trial there was one
for for 16 and older that's what we just
looked at separately and that's what it
was authorized for in December 20 2020
for 16 and older separately to get an
authorization and lure for 12 to 15 year
olds there was a separate clinical trial
okay in this clinical trial they
vaccinated a grand total of 1,131 kids
Maddie Deary our client is one of those
children okay you could see a picture of
her in October 20th doing a handstand
January 16th this is her doing a Tik Tok
video
and this is January 20th she goes in for
a second fiser dose not as just a person
in the public as a clinical trial
participant do you know how I know her
parents were not uh against
vaccines she participated in a clinical
trial forget just get the vaccine right
they wanted to do their part they wanted
to step up and help
this is Maddie you can see in the video
on the left she had within 24 hours she
was in an emergency room a Cascade of
emergency room visits that eventually
resulted in her being in a wheel chair
and have a feeding
tube she basically has a form of you
know neurological disorder which is
common type of injury at least when
there's a vaccine injury right so a lot
of vaccine injuries that we deal with
are immune or immun mediated
neurological issues like gomber syndrome
transmis you can go down the list um
it's basically where your immune system
attacks your nerves um you know in the
case of for example GBS starts in your
periphery Works your way up you could
recover you can get paralyzed we have um
all types of GBS cases at our firm that
we bring so um now the fact that Maddie
was injured by a vaccine
is okay drugs injure people it
happens the real concern from a
regulatory perspective is how the FDA
dealt with it that is the real
travesty not in any way to minimize the
pain and and harm to uh to
Maddie
so this now that we got all of the
documents that fiser submitted to the
FDA license it's covid vaccine this is
what
this is what the FDA report excuse me
fiser reported Maddy's injury to the FD
they reported it as functional abdominal
pain they did not say she's in a
wheelchair they did not say she couldn't
walk they did not say she has a feeding
tube they basically said it's in her
head and she's got a tummy
ache and uh it's it's a uh the reason
that it's a siral LLP link not a FDA
link by the way way is because we had to
file a lawsuit in southern district of
Ohio to get these documents from the
FDA what did fiser tell the public about
Maddie well here's its published report
in May 27 2021 it says there were no
vaccine related serious a events in a
trial that's what it told the
public believe that's uh again the New
England Journal of Medicine
now we at our firm I mentioned earlier
we do vaccine cases we have three
medical professionals on staff we have
uh you know lawyers and paralegals and
we litigate vaccine injuries all day we
don't do them against pharmac companies
you can't because of the 86 act we do
them in a little Federal program called
the vaccine and Compensation Program
I'll tell you about that later but we
review medical records all day long to
assess causality and whether we can
prove causality in court if I could
bring a case from Maddie in court I
could easily prove that no question the
fizer's vaccine is the causal reason
there's no differential diagnosis
there's no other reason and and there's
a biological reason plausible reason for
how it was caused and all the records
showed uh the that the ideology was from
the from the from the vaccine in any
event we sent numerous detailed letters
with access to all of madd's medical
records to the FDA saying hey hey hey
hey FDA um uh you know this this is what
the FIS telling the public and and
here's what fiser told you and I'm we're
telling you this is not true this is not
true fizer Maddie was seriously injured
and you know what even if fizer doesn't
think it's from the vaccine the
reporting requirements required it
provide that information that's the
whole idea of a clinical trial you
assess you gather all the reactions now
you want to then say it's not the
vaccine fine but you got to report it
we said either way even if you conclude
the vaccine didn't cause it which I
don't know how you do that fizer should
be in huge trouble huge trouble for not
telling you about this not just not
telling you misrepresenting to you that
this was functional abdominal
pain that first link you can read all
our letters and they're detailed they're
medical I had our medical professionals
detailed all of it you know
um and we finally got a response in
February 26 2022 so months
later and you can go and read that
response
yourself the response from the FDA was
have Maddie follow V's
report I I literally can't make that up
you should I encourage everyone to read
it that was their response
here's here's what's
incredible an onslaught of folks kept
contacting the FDA about
Maddie and in June of
20121 and this is from our lawsuit in
the southern district of Ohio we sued
the FDA because they wouldn't give us
the documents thank God for Foya freedom
information act and we finally got all
the internal emails within the FDA
regarding Maddie de Gary including email
Communications where um somebody who's
very very very wealthy emails Janet
Woodcock who was then the acting
director commissioner of the FDA and so
that apparently finally prompts her to
then email Dr Peter marks the head of
the vaccine division who then emails a
bunch of other folks and say uh can you
guys look into this our letter didn't do
it Maddie being on national news didn't
do it but apparently this did it I don't
know
why they email fizer and they say fiser
what what's up with this situation with
Maddie fizer emails back a detailed
report for the first time explaining all
the issues she had okay for the first
time if I'm at the FDA my respon
response should
be what the heck why didn't you tell me
this before and what else are you hiding
from me but that's not the exchange that
link at the bottom I encourage everybody
to read you want to see how the FDA
works you want to see the sausage is
made you should read this internal Email
exchange about MADD dear when you read
this assessment by
fizer you would think oh my god there it
is fizer's admitting it was the vaccine
because that's the way it reads and at
the very end it says the pi the
principal
investigator uh who's paid by
fer did not feel did not feel the
subject's
symptomatology that's how they spelled
it was consistent with a vaccine related
adverse
event and that was it that's where the
chain ends they email that back up the
chain and they just accept that
conclusion there's nothing in the
communication to see that fizer is going
to be investigated fizer is going to be
in trouble for this are they going to do
another audit of its documents are they
going to look further into this are they
going to contact mad's family they're
going to contact us nothing I'm sorry
please um what do you mean he did not
feel he didn't
feel I didn't feel like having coffee
this morning I felt like having two he
didn't feel that her injuries were
consistent with the VAC out it isn't
incredible it's incredible because
remember remember you're you're you're
talking about a product that's new the
whole point of the clinical trials is to
see what issues it could cause that are
unknown and he says well this doesn't
fit with what basically I understand a
vaccine to be able to cause so it's not
vaccine related so just to follow up on
that so as an investigator who's paid by
the company that's making the
vaccine isn't it his job to assess and
not
feel that was his
assessment representative
Penza thank you madam
chair I you I just kind of wanted you to
repeat this because I think it's it's so
important for it to be said this is um
was authorized under emergency youth
authorization it was done in a way that
pushed things out before really having
enough knowledge I believe
and it was it's not doesn't fall under
any sort of
traditional quote unquote vaccine so
you're telling me they based it off of
let's say for
example uh an
MMR of adverse effects because it didn't
follow some of those things and that's
what they based upon in a sense I I um
well I think you might be giving um Dr
Frank too much credit there um I it's
his assessment of what he he feels is a
vaccine related adverse
event follow up thank you madam
chair the documents that came out that
fizer was withholding for a period of
time that was I believe almost nine
pages long of different side effects
that you could have was that released at
this
point
um so the it wasn't fiser withholding by
the way it was the FDA because it was
fiser has no obligation to with to
produce documents to the public uh the
only reason the FDA had to produce those
to the public was because the because of
the freedom information act and I don't
think our lawsuit had yet received an
order to produce the documents at this
point and um
um you're testing I yeah I'm not I'm not
sure if that page of potential Adverse
Events that boser had listed was public
yet thank you I'd have to check
representative beler thank you madam
chair and I apologize for interrupting I
just wanted to take just a second I have
up here a uh website article I wanted to
quickly um note in the record
statnews.com August 9th 2021 indicating
as the FDA was searching for a new
commissioner there was a letterwriting
campaign undertaken by uh those who
statistically had significant ific um
Financial contributions from the uh
pharmaceutical Industries indicating
significant pharmaceutical industry
support for uh commissioner Woodcock to
be named as head of the FDA thank
you yeah I mean I for what it's worth my
assessment is actually that um when you
look at all the internal emails person
really calling the shots in terms of
authorizing licing these vaccines at the
FDA was Dr Peter Marx not do not not Dr
woodcock um to be sure she actually had
to sign it at the end of the day I
believe um though actually I think it
was Dr Peter marks who signed the
authorizations my recollection Serv but
he was the one really when you look at
the internal documents uh my assessment
is he's the one who really made that
decision I mean he's the one who decided
really at the end of the day I mean
there is the there is verac which is the
advisory committee I mean uh within the
FDA that
advises the FDA about whether or not to
license or not license and so so forth
but at the end of the day it's it's Dr
Peter marks who made the decision of
whether or not there would be a verb
back hearing or not and then uh um
really what would happen and uh when
guber and Strauss um for example his two
subordinates would not uh uh I think um
would not as the internal email show
license excuse me authorize and and then
license on a timeline that he wanted
that really is what led to I believe
their uh going out the internal
Communications reflect them emailing and
taking significant issue with Dr marks
trying to move up the licenser timeline
because among other reasons he believed
that once it was licensed that uh
there'd be more mandates and so he
wanted to try to accelerate the lure
process and guber and Strauss pushed
back and they ended up on the outside of
of the uh on the other side of the FDA
front doors um but but going back to
Maddie excuse me one moment represent
Venza
you might get to hear in your
presentation I just um and I think it's
really important because it's kind of
like there were no one's talking about
um the J&J the one shot at all which of
course fell under emergency youth
authorization um our committee had
someone here that was vaccine injured
her daughter was from that I know
several other people here in the state
um that were uh that were injured from
that shot and um we PR Ed that a lot
here in in New Hampshire and I just was
wondering do you have any information on
that specifically because it was like
here it got pulled it got put back and
then now it doesn't even exist anymore
yeah I mean I focus on the fizer madna
in particularly fiser because that is
what most Americans receive very small
percentage of Americans receive the J&J
shot and then there's the Novac shot
which even smaller percentage got and
astrazenica was never authorized a
license here so um yeah I mean J&J use a
bit more of a traditional platform but
it had similar issues I mean look
I again from my perspective I don't
really view the the what you call you
know the MRNA vaccines is any really
different than most of the other
vaccines or like the J&J I mean uh to
the extent that um you know I mean using
DNA technology like I said Rec combinant
DNA vaccines are used DNA technology I
mean they take basically snipp of the
DNA they take they take it yeast DNA
they take out a slice they slice in the
the um the the antigens that they want
to
create and they I mean it's it's kind of
a DNA technology too and we've been
doing that since you know for 30 years
so I mean if we're going to
differentiate vaccines based on the
technology that they used to make them
um then it's hard to actually label
there's a lot of silos for vaccines and
again my assessment is not that there
were Rush the J&J vaccine had also you
know had had had different types of
issues in particular TTS
right um and what made TTS so
interesting is that it's it's not normal
to have reduced platelet counts right
but yet increased clotting so normally
somebody comes in with clotting you give
them a blood thinner because you you
figure they're having too many platelets
problem is is that uh people presenting
with blood clots they were giving them
blood thinners now realizing their
platet counts already low and then
killing them in a hospital by mistake
unintentionally using you know they they
thought they were doing the right thing
and and because it's not a common event
it's not going to hide in a background
rate that's stuck out like a sore thumb
TTS and that's why it made the news
right away was identified and and um
Adverse Events that are common in the
background radar are far harder to to
tease out so to speak but on J&J at
least TTS was obviously recognized which
is why they pulled in then it came
back okay um
so anyway I think I'm about to wrap up
the clinical trial Section almost by the
way M de Gary adding insult to injury
was censored all over the Internet for
just telling her story they all of her
posts were you know censored you were
throttled you people were kicked off for
doing it and you might say well why wh
why would the FDA do this I can't answer
completely and I think I've given some
Snippets as to it but here is Dr Peter
marks this is the man who really decided
whether authorize and license coac he's
the one in that email chain I just told
you about with Maddie way way after what
after he'd already gone to the American
people and told them you should all get
this shot before it was even licensed
this is Dr marks in a YouTube video this
is him I he made this the FDA made this
doing just a minute this is the person
who's supposed to impartially
objectively coldly look at this data
decide whether millions of Americans
should get it and he's out there
promoting the
vaccine that creates an inherent
conflict he goes and he tells everybody
to get it is he really then going to go
oops sorry I messed up he should have
been nowhere near promotion of this
product no place the FDA doesn't go out
and promote drugs that's why they don't
have as much of an issue to pull those
products they say oh yeah obic yep
oopsie yeah we messed up we licens it
but we didn't know this FDA doesn't go
and create advertisements doesn't have
this on their homeage page this is the
homepage of the FDA this does not look
like a regulatory this looks like an
advertisement and amazingly it was for
the B veiling vaccine it wasn't even a
licensed product meaning it hadn't yet
been shown to be safe and effective just
to make sure where we understand each
other when you eua when you authorize a
product emergency use authorization
authorize a product it has not yet been
shown to be safe and effective pursuing
to the FDA
standards later if it's licensed it's
met that FDA standards so this didn't
even meet the FDA standards yet and yet
here it is being promoted it creates a
real serious conflict for the FDA to
then say oops
sorry um and and separately forget what
the FDA itself does it has an advisory
committee that advises the FDA and you
probably have seen those those were what
were all over TV with Paul offit and
some of the other you know
vaccinologists have a whole you know
interdisciplinary Committee of of of
medical profess professionals that sit
there um I'm I'm almost done with this
clinical trial Section and uh this is a
congressional report that looked at the
fda's advisory committee and this is
what the FD this is what the uh
Congressional report concluded the
overwhelming majority of members both
voting members and Consultants have
substantial ties pharmaceutical
industry I've deposed a number of these
vaccinologists and folks who sit on
these committies and it is incredible
actually the same people who conduct
clinical trials are paid by farmer
consultants for them are also sitting on
this committee
despite the fact that you often hear
that it's independent I I and and here's
this not me that's that's a
congressional report reaching that
conclusion you could read the report and
you could read in detail the incredible
amount of conflicts um and then you
think they'd clean up their act but
here's again this is the HHS Inspector
General again finding nine years later
the same type of systemic conflicts
going on I'll show you this one video
and then I'll wrap up the clinical trial
Section I'm sure you guys have heard
enough from me this morning
want to eat something um so this is the
U so we talked about the FDA itself and
Peter marks we've talked about the
vaccine Safety Committee uh the advisory
committee there is also when a clinical
trial is ongoing there's something
called a data safety monitoring board an
independent data safety monitoring board
the purpose of this board is supposed to
be objectively an independently review
the safety of the product while the
vaccine is undergoing clinical trial
okay Dr uh uh Katherine Edwards she's
the third author on plins vaccine editor
she is a world renowned vaccinologist
she runs the cdc's sisa program which uh
evaluates specific vaccine injuries um
she's done a uh probably I don't know
involved in half of the clinical trials
involving childhood vaccines that are on
the schedule I could be wrong about that
but I think that's what she told me and
when I deposed her and um here's a case
where she's on the stand and I'm asking
her specifically about her role in the
data safety monitor board with regards
to fizer's covid-19
vaccine um yes I can try to do that let
me see if I turn it up on my machine
does that help
ready
you're one of the only five members of
that
dat right
yes that's supposed to be
independent data
it
is all of us in
America are hoping on and ring upon
going to independently make sure that
safety is properly
supposed to
beend that members of that independent
data safety board are in fact
dependent of
the being Valu correct
that's isn't it true that directly
coming am the
independent advis
supp question
was before you became a member of
independent data saf
isn't
it
that you were an
advisor
to yes sir I think what you're consuming
is
that what they want me to say is and has
never
my I say what I believe on my
expertise you don't think that
Financial incentives
can people judg at all it does
not
because mean folks who were never
advised to
she I think she really believ she's
independent she does I I have no reason
to doubt that she sincerely thinks she's
independent but you know we all know
that that bias can creep in right it can
corrupt in ways that are conscious and
and often
unconscious um and so now we've gone
through The Regulators the independent
board the data safety monitoring board
um also the C da we've talked about this
fought us forever in court to release
the data and that really brings us to
the end of clinical trials and I'll stop
there and I'll just say this much to be
clear to be sure I'm not you know the
whole reason of showing all this is not
to take
uh I genuinely believe anybody who wants
a vaccine should be free to get one you
know if you want to you know uh stay at
home and wear six masks and vaccine
every day should be able to that's
Freedom that's America should be able to
do that but I think that those who want
to let's say look at some of this
information who understand let's say how
clinical trials are done who look at
this and want to come to their own
conclusion should also be free to do
that and and and to be sure if anybody's
thinking about well don't they stop
transmission we'll get to that um at
part four and I'll talk about
postlicensure safety uh when we get back
from
lunch thank you very much um I'd like to
recess for lunch uh 115 will that work
for
everyone okay I'll I'll see everyone
back here at
1:15
e
e e
my wife
uh being uh excuse me being 125 I'm
going to call this meeting back into
order um Aon Siri is our presenter and
we are on part three covid-19 vaccines
post licens your
safety your mic
uh nope this
one sorry there we go okay I do a lot of
people tell you the they think the red
means no and okay sorry
okay keeps it interesting um okay so we
went through the
pre-licensure with regards to
safety but also some efficacy components
as well and now we'll talk about
postlicensure because you might say to
yourself look um all right so you know
maybe the trials weren't great but after
license you're definitely studied right
and um in order to look at that I want
to look at how other vaccines are licens
excuse me studied after lure and I think
that will give you a baseline to a
assess and think about how the CDC and
the FDA
approach post-license or safety now
post-license or safety is typically the
purview of the CDC so the FDA does the
pre-licensure CDC does the postlicensure
typically um and ah has some involvement
um but usually they just stle out money
and so
um as a proxy
basically for assessing how
robust is the quote unquote science that
studies vaccine safety after lure I'm
going to use the uh the
claim that rest assured vaccines do not
cause and I bet you guys all already
know the word that's in the blank it's
autism right vaccines do not C autism I
think is a good proxy for how well
vaccine safety is really studied after
licensure because it is the claim that
public health authorities Federal all 50
states you name it you talk to the
average medical doctor they will tell
you that question has been
thoroughly studied and absolutely
debunked that vaccines do not cause
autism and we know it because we have
study that issue period and we have the
science the studies the data to prove it
um I'll play a little Montage that this
is the hom page this is on the CDC
website vaccines do not cause autism
there's no qualification
scient Community what causes autism but
we know that vaccines do not vaccines
are really the one thing we have looked
at cusing we know that vaccines don't
cause autism the science is clear
vaccines don't cause autism I do not
deny in any way that we need to do more
about autism but it has nothing to do
with vaccines let me be clear vaccines
do not cause autism vaccines don't cause
autism
absolutely sure okay vaccines do not
cause
autism so I'm going to use that uh I'm
not here to I'm not trying to debate the
question of vaccines cause autism I'm
just using that as a proxy to see let's
look at what the state of the science is
on that question is a proxy for what it
looks like for the numerous other health
issues that parents will routinely at
least call our Fir and will have
complained about as vaccines potentially
causing now there are a number of PS
studies that have surveyed parents with
children with autism and asked them what
do you think caused your child's autism
and despite
the almost endless campaign by public
authorities to convince the public
vaccines do not cause autism 40 to 70%
depending on the study of autism parents
still blame vaccines for causing their
child's autism and when you ask them
what vaccines they
blame this all the ones that I just
highlighted and read if you could see
those are the ones that they will bring
up they they will bring up all the shots
in the first 6 months of Life heppe daap
Hib pcv13 and ipv each given three times
as well as MMR MMR is given no earlier
than 12 months okay we know autism can
often typically be diagnosed with before
one year of age so if you're going to
study whether vaccines cause
autism and your parents are saying they
believe vaccines caused autism you
should probably study the vaccines given
in the first six months of Life at the
least if you're going to claim vaccines
do not cause autism you should have
studies that show that vaccines don't
cause
autism
well let's see what's in fact been done
in that regard and I'm going to go
through a quick little timeline here
starting with the 1986 act that's the
national child vac indri act we talked
about that earlier that gave immunity to
pharmaceutical companies set up a
vaccine court and so forth well at the
time that it was ped it directed our
federal health authorities to study what
was then presumably The 11 most common
claimed injuries from vaccine all the
way back in the
80s and and one of them was whether or
not protus this vaccine causes autism
and I'll read the language in the
federal law at the time the Secretary of
Health and Human Services shall complete
a review of all relevant medical and
scientific information on the nature
circumstances and extent of the
relationship of any between vaccines
containing
pusis including wholesale and specific
antigens meaning whole and uh um attent
like the ones we have today and the
following illnesses and conditions 1
through 11 number nine being autism okay
this is a decade before uh Andrew
Wakefield this is a decade before MMR
controversy this is all the way back in
the80s okay
so the uh Federal authorities went and
they commissioned the national well the
uh what's then known as The Institute of
medicine now the National Academy of
medicine and they paid them to conduct a
review of all the existing literature
with regards to those 11 conditions to
see whether or not what does the
literature the the peer viwed science
actually show and what um uh they found
was that for
autism there was no evidence bearing a
causal relationship meaning they did not
find a single study that had studied the
question that doesn't mean vaccine's
cause
autism didn't mean protested SE cause
autism but it means the question had not
been
answered no category of evidence was
found bearing on a judgment about
causation all categories of evidence
left blank on table 1-1 so here we are
it was they went they looked they looked
through all of the studies the science
the data and they could not find a shred
of evidence to inform the question of
whether or not protus vaccines cause
autism that was
well in
2012 CDC and HR say hrsa Human Health
Resources Administration that is another
agency within HHS that administers
actually vaccine court hrsa and CDC
jointly funded a study by The Institute
of medicine to look at what they said
were the 150 something most commonly
claimed injuries from vaccines that's
they said not me CDC hrsa and one of the
claimed injuries continued to be whether
pertusus vaccine caused
autism as well as deia and Tennis
vaccine and so the Institute of medicine
convened a panel of you know
interdisciplinary panel that looked at
all the science out there and they
looked at the epidemiological evidence
and when you read that section if you if
you you know have a moment oh I don't
have a link here to the report well I I
can provide a link to the full report um
and uh the epidemiological evidence they
only found one
study by guy and Guy it actually showed
there was a correlation between DTaP
vaccine and autism but they uh the threw
the study out as unreliable because it
was based on V's data so that was
discounted they could find no other Epi
studies they could find no mechanistic
evidence meaning it just wasn't looked
at and so their causal ity conclusion
again this is the Institute of medicine
saying this not me is the evidence is
inadequate to accept or reject a causal
relationship between deia toxoid tetanus
toxoid or a cellular protus containing
vaccines and
autism that's not vaccines don't cause
autism that's we don't know if vaccines
cause autism well let me be let me be
actually more specific we don't know
whether prosus deor or tetanus vaccines
cause autism which are
vaccines hence hard to make the claim
vaccines so cause
autism okay so um I had occasion as you
saw earlier to depose the world leading
vaccinologist and I actually had an an
opportunity to ask him about that exact
finding from The Institute of medicine
maybe he knew something we didn't maybe
he had a study we didn't know about
right let's see what he had to say and
how he dealt with that
conclusion in that Institute of medicine
review just I just to really put this
into context these Institute of medicine
reviews they are you know uh uh hugely
funded things by the by by federal
health authorities the purpose of these
studies is uh in the vaccine Court hrsa
wants to be able to defend against
vaccine injury claims when we sue them
so they commission these studies hoping
to find the conclusion that the vaccine
does not cause X Y or Z issue okay all
right I'm GNA play
this this is an excerpt from the I's
report mhm right yes can you read the
causality conclusion with regard to
whether dap and Tdap cause autism the
evidence is inadequate to accept or
reject a causal relationship between the
theia toxoid tetanus toxoid or a
cellular protest containing vaccine and
O if you don't know whether dap or t c
autism don't you
wait until you do know until you have
the science to support
it to then say that vaccines do not
goed do I wait no I do not wait because
I have to take into account the health
of the
child and and so for that reason you're
okay with telling the parent that dap
Tdap does not CA
even
though the science isn't there yet to
support that CL
absolutely this is an excerpt from the
I so
um so fine maybe Dr plin is not aware of
studies that exist I don't know so we
decided is we're going to go straight to
to the source and we foed the CDC
directly for all studies relied upon by
CDC to claim that the DAP vaccine does
not cause autism it's on their website
vaccinees not cause autism we also asked
for all studies the CDC relied upon to
say that endir being recom those are the
two he vaccines remember we looked at
those earlier when we looked at
movac prear 13 Hib and ipv as well as I
asked we asked for all the studies that
show that cumulatively those vaccines
don't cause autism those are each of
those shots given three times in the
first six months of life okay so we foed
the CDC CDC says vaccines don't cause
autism they wouldn't uh provide any
studies we eventually appealed
administratively they didn't provide any
studies I sue them in federal court on
behalf of I can um and uh finally the
Department of Justice um offered up 20
studies this is in a stipulated order
it's on your screen you could see that
it's uh signed by the Department of
Justice signed by me on behalf of I can
and it's sign entered as an order by a
federal judge and this lists the 20
studies that they say they rely upon to
claim vaccine don't CA autism for those
early shots here's the thing I had a
call with the Department of Justice
attorney before this order was uh
finalized and I said Hey listen are you
sure your client wants to sign a an
order saying that these are the 20
studies it's like why I said because
none of them involve the vaccines in the
first six months of life I said all of
them involve MMR vaccine which is given
at one year or involve V Mercury which
was taken out of vaccines back in 2000 I
said so you're you're providing studies
that are not relevant to the question in
the Foy request I said in fact I said
and
ironically you you site the 2012
Institute of medicine
review that found this this is one of
the 20 Things They cited I said so the
only study in this list of 20 that
actually refers to a vaccine given in
the first six months of life now on the
current schedule is this study and it
says it doesn't have a study to support
vaccines cause
autism well you could see what the doj
and CDC decided to do they just want the
lawsuit gone so they signed it so I want
to reiterate and and anybody could read
these studies they're they are in
English they're available there's a link
down there you could pull it up just
read them maybe they thought we wouldn't
read I I don't know but um there they
are and 18 involved the Marisol MMR one
involved antigen not vaccine exposure
and that study even sayic doesn't
discuss whether vaccines cause autism it
can't because it doesn't study vaccines
and one involved MMR the mar and dap
that's the 2012 I report we just looked
at okay and I and I want to put a finer
point on this that 2012 IAM report had a
section on MMR and autism and it
concluded that it threw out all the MMR
studies except four and it said based on
those four Epi studies its causality
conclusion is that MMR does not cause
autism so it can make that
determination science can conclude that
a vaccine doesn't cause autism it did it
in that 2012 irm report but it hasn't
done it for daap or ipv or prear or
pcv13 or Hib it didn't or or he be five
shots even three times each in the first
six months of life okay so
um okay well maybe the CDC doesn't
know and then we'll let's flip to to
uh well I'll show you one more
deposition clip this one again is Dr
kather Edwards this this isn't a lawsuit
that actually involves vaccines and
autism Dr Edwards was brought in as the
vaccinologist the expert on the question
of whether or not this particular child
ended up with vaccines from autism okay
and here is my exchange with her when I
deposed her on this precise
question according to your profile you
have done most the
trials many of the VAC on the
market yes sir so
highly experienced conducting clinical
trials correct I highly experienced
conducting clinical
trials and you're familiar with many of
the clinical trials that relied upon to
license many of the vaccines currently
on the market correct I
am in your
opinion did the clinical trials relied
upon license the vaces that Gat many of
which are still on the market
today were they designed to rule out
that the
vaccine youed me into answering the
question the way you want me to
but is it is that testimony
yes in the extra disclosures for this
case it asserts that among other things
you will testify that quote the issue of
whether vaccines CL autism has been
thoroughly researched and rejected end
quote it's your testimony that MMR
vaccine cannot cause autism that's
correct your testimony that head vaccine
cannot cause autism that's correct your
testimony that I cannot cause autism yes
is your testimony that H vaccine cannot
cause autism
yes your testimony that vac cannot CM
yes your testimony that trar vac canot
cuse autism yes it's your daab you
cannot cause autism yes and you have a
study that supports a dtab doesn't cause
autism do not have
DET do you have any study one way or
another whether I
I no I do not sir do you have any study
one way or another of whether in B caus
off I do not have any uh evidence that
it causes ontis more than it does and
what about
hi vacine any evidence one way or
another whether
it what about prar vaccine any evidence
one way or another no sir no sir and how
about vac let me just finish are there
any studies one way or
another whether it does or
doesn't mm but but not
as no do
no there have been studies that have
found an association
between um do
not feel credible and which study which
study do you are you referring to when
you well why don't you show me the study
then I'll see whether I agree with
it so you know we have it from we have
it in a stipulated order from the
federal judge we have it from uh the
leading experts in in vaccinology
honestly I don't know where else to look
it's not like we're not we're not trying
to hide run from the evidence or data or
studies
we'd love to see the
studies love to look at them please so I
just want to understand make sure I
understand what I just saw Yes um so
there was a document and it looks like
that was initialed that someone said
that it said that those vaccines do not
cause autism is that what I was looking
at or no I'm sorry that that was just
the vaccination record of the child at
issue uh that that you know I was
brought in just to do this just to
depose the vaccinologist in this case
that involved lots of other things so
you know I just I I I don't if you got a
hard issue don't talk to me I don't know
anything but but vaccines I know a
little bit about so um I was asked to
depose the vaccinologist that was the
kids that was the child's records at
issue and so you know we were just going
through the vaccines which Mo are most
of the vaccines on the current schedule
today and may I just follow up with
something so it seemed like she was um
quite up upset uh that she had to answer
these questions I didn't um and really
didn't want to I mean
and I guess the underlying thing was is
she couldn't say one way or the other
that they caused o she couldn't say that
it did and she couldn't say that it
didn't right mean but what we're hearing
is that they
don't right they're they're telling you
vaccines do not cause autism
categorically end of story
they will tell you they insent medicine
will conclude there are studies that MMR
doesn't but for the other vaccines it's
not like there's a debate like okay we
have one study that shows this they
didn't do the studies and that's what
you're hearing so my point that I want
you know I'm just using autism I'm I'm
not debating whether vaccines cause
autism I'm just using vaccines cause
autism claim as do not cause autism as a
proxy for the state of the science the
science
with regards to how well our federal
health authorities the medical community
NIH funding how much does it go to
actually studying vaccine safety and
what I'm telling you is that you can
look at the clinical trials we just did
that and if you go on to go to PubMed
and research vaccine safety you're going
to uh be a really shocked at how limited
and the dir of studies are actually done
please um yes so
um for me you know we're supposed to
trust what we're
reading from the
government and if they absolutely state
that something doesn't cause something
then they should be linking the studies
to that to prove that yes um but they're
not um how do we know going
forward that we can trust
based on evidence that we I'm not saying
that they do but I'm not saying I mean I
don't know based on what I just heard
today right so I guess the question is I
could I'll say this much I I do think
vaccines are truly unique in my
assessment with regards to at least
products on the market and that's
because usually and I go back to my
first slides you know you have a moneyed
interest pushing both ways there's no
conspir
it it there's you know you have moneyed
interest battling each other so normally
you have on the one side you have the
companies want to make money on the
other side you have the product
liability and class action attorneys and
you have The Regulators who are sitting
somewhere here on the side of the
consumers this is the only product that
I know of where you have the the you
have one side you have the the
pharmaceutical companies um the the the
class action and product liability have
been neutered they can't do anything so
they're out of the game and The
Regulators have a statutory obligation
to increase vaccine uptake and we'll
talk about later they are who you sue in
federal court it's not even a court it's
a you name the secretary of the
Department of Health and Human Services
when you bring a vaccine injury claim in
the vaccine injury Compensation Program
that's part of the federal court of
claims which is the only Court in
America where you typically cons Su the
federal government for money so if you
if they do studies that show vaccines
cause
harm we use that as evidence against the
government it's the only product I know
where the government defends the company
against the consumers if you're injured
by a
vaccine government doesn't come and
protect you they protect they they they
defend the product so when we sue the
Secretary of Department of Health Human
Services for a vaccine injury for a
little baby or a child who's the defense
Council it's a little Law Firm it's
called the Department of Justice have a
lot of money a lot of lawyers and that's
who defends against vaccine injury
claims they have an entire vaccine
injury Compensation Division at the
Department of Justice they have a lot of
money they hire all the experts so it's
uh when you say what can I trust I I I I
do think that your worldview doesn't
need to explode over this at all in my
opinion I think that this is a this is
really a it's a unique thing it's and
it's ironic because the claim the
vaccines cause a saying anything about
vaccines and autism makes you
anti-science makes you antivaxer makes
you into a category of being a nut but
ironically incredibly and I understand
it can be a bit can cause cognitive
dissonance I'm certain for for for many
folks when they see this because you're
like like what you just said well if I
can't trust that their vaccines don't
cause autism not claiming because they
haven't done the studies what else can't
I trust I I don't know I I really do put
vaccines in their own kind of box when
it comes to products because they are in
that category if if if they didn't have
the 19 sax immunity you wouldn't be in
the scenario to to undo the issue with
vaccines in my opinion all you got to do
is lift the immunity let the market
forces do what they normally do and and
and get rid of the government defending
vaccines in vaccine court and so forth
let let them operate like any other
product let them rise and fall on their
merits which is what we've always done
right we you rise and fall in the merits
not not based on coercion and mandates
and bullying and kick them out of school
and kick them out of work I mean that's
what bullies and Thugs and dictators do
throughout history when they can't
convince on the merits thank you
representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and for
perhaps the eenth time today I'm
somewhat shocked by some of what I've
just seen and I'd like to just offer a
summary to see if this is accurate for
what you're what you're seeing and what
you've testified and what you've shown
us which
is trusted experts within the field
making unqualified objective claim
claims as to the lack of a causitive
factor between this medical product and
a and a
disease asserting it
definitively then admitting in
deposition that there is no not just
definitive but no real evidence
suggesting those claims
are
correct which leaves you guessing why
would they do something like this but
then again we don't really have the
guess because there was another death
position of a
gentleman in which case he seemed to
suggest that the noble
lie was
warranted to
manipulate people into increasing the
uptake of this product because it was
because he assessed that on the on the
total scale of things that he believes
people would be better off with it than
without it is that generally what we're
seeing here I think the word belief is
apt and I will tell you that is a lot of
what I see in this Arena uh about
vaccines there's a lot of beliefs around
the product and they really are in many
instances like religious belief people
get upset they get angry sometimes when
you say things about vaccines that they
think are right or they think are they
think they're wrong um because they
don't really have in my experience folks
get upset in depositions because um you
know uh I depose lots of different
medical professionals and you know when
they then they don't have a a knowledge
based face to draw on they don't have
the facts the data themselves they just
believe it then they can only draw on
their emotion to respond they can't draw
on their intellect and that creates some
of these uh more interesting moments and
depositions in my
opinion I I don't know if that answers
your question but yes yes it is it I I
it is it is a um yes it's it's an
unfortunate State of Affairs thank you
and if I made just one followup would it
then be your opinion that um that there
is at least at times in entrenched sort
of I don't know if party line is the
right word it's not a party but an
entrenched
ideological line that is expected of
people in this profession to follow
oh absolutely and you can bring on a um
a whole Litany of folks who are medical
professionals um who up until the moment
in time when they said something against
the grain about these products were LED
in their profession considered experts
but cutting across on this issue is very
problematic um you know car
manufacturers do a very good job
protecting their product they have
billions of dollars every year they put
that money into PR campaigns with Fifth
Avenue firms to promote their cars to
make sure that good things are said
about them and then when the headline
comes out about car having this or that
issue they go into they did pharmaceu
companies do the same thing and it's
smart it's just good business they spend
billions of dollars every year promoting
their products they have a kitty they
have PR firms but they just do it
through um their their chosen method is
basically to do it through uh um what
they what they
cons folks who are viewed as uh experts
and trusted Professionals in in out
there it's not nefarious it's just the
way it works in the sense that they hold
conventions they hold meetings they have
Symposium you know they're they law the
products your typical pediatrician I
think is a good person they they don't
they just don't know they don't they've
never looked at the clinical trial data
I've deposed pediatricians who've gone
their whole career never looked at the
packager at one time no clue in fact I
don't think I've ever depos a
pediatrician who knew anything about the
clinical trials of these products or any
or any of that so they yeah you know
they're going through the day they're
just they have they trust what and and
the truth is is that how could they get
through their day without it they open
the physician Desk Reference guide
there's a million things they got to do
every day diagnose and look at right um
and so they get through their day by
just following what the guidance
provides it's similar in this product
with regards to these products except
that um they really just don't realize
the the the complete imbalance in in how
these products uh are operate in the
real world that started slowly in the
80s with the immunity and has just it's
just gone it's just really gone wild in
my opinion over the
decades representative
Penza so just while you're talking I
just did a little quick search and um
this is a um it is a 501c3 organization
it's called immun immunize.org and so I
just want to read this medical and legal
authorities it's first the title is
evidence shows vac vaccines unrelated to
autism
medical and legal authorities agree that
no evidence exists that vaccines cause
autism The Institute of medicine is an
impartial group of the world's leading
experts that advises Congress on science
issues after reviewing more than 200
studies in
2004 and more than a thousand studies in
2011 their report strongly stated that
the evidence did not show a link between
vaccines and autism in 2014 researchers
from the Rand Corporation published an
update date to the 2011 Institute of
medicines report in a systematic review
of The Evidence published on vaccine
safety to date they found the evidence
was strong and then they go into that
the MMR vaccine is not associated with
autism now they didn't talk about that
this kind of goes back to what you were
saying how they jumped to MMR but why
not go after so if we've got the
government that has you know uh or the
back vaccine manufacturers that have
this blanket immunity why not go after
this why not we know that what was just
stated here is a complete lie this is a
501c3 organizations that is promoting
that and they are blatantly providing
misinformation and this is just based
upon looking at this quite a big um
organization so that's just one example
I'm sure of probably a over a thousand I
I I believe that the the solution to
speech that's wrong is more speech never
censorship certainly not by the
government ever way you view is you know
danger today by speech everybody thinks
the other person's saying something
that's dangerous so I I never I think
the big greatest danger is always the
cent of speech Free Speech comes with
dangerous to be sure but the greater
sens sensory and that's a really
interesting quote actually because they
were talking first about the 2004 I
review which had didn't which involved
MMR in the Marisol they then they talk
about 2011 or 201 12 it's um depends on
where you look in this sometimes I I
call 2011 what we just looked at it did
not conclude that dtab doesn't catism
and the 2014 one is super interesting
because what they're talking about is an
as ahrq vaccine study if I could pull it
up if if I'll get lucky and I know that
study the one that they talked about and
that study from 2014 was an update to
the HHS one and it again concluded that
they don't have any evidence for daap
but what's great about that one is if I
if I could find find it is that they
looked at and autism too and for
they only found one study this
Goodman study that found a three time
risk amongst kids that got headb and who
didn't get headb and so here I'll even
see I could pull it up right
now
um oh this is the 2021 version oh they
probably took down the 20204
version all right well I'll have to do
that another time then because it's not
going to be on their site anymore uh but
if you look at the 2014 version which I
it has a whole section he be and
autism and that's what it shows so it's
quite ironic that that that's what they
say but that's but that's what you'll
typically get um you'll get these
conclusory statements if you look under
the hood like we did the at the direct
primary sources you get a different
conclusion represent
Penza thank you madam chair yeah so
there's a point where something's Free
Speech right but then there's a point
where isn't it I mean that is that is
blatantly saying that that there
were 400 you know excuse me 200 studies
and more than a thousand which those
don't exist and then they're basically
saying that what the report says is
definiely saying that there is um no
evidence when that's not what the report
said so there's a point where it's it's
lying it's not just Free Speech though
and we're I mean this is affecting
millions and millions of people that are
making these decisions and that's why
people should always have choice in my
at the end of the day solution to me in
my mind is less government not more and
um and they're just conflating and I
agree misrepresenting because they're
saying hundreds thousands they mean in
the report in total which covers lots of
other things and then they digress in
that quote to talk about autism making
it a appear as if those studies are all
about autism they're not the whole the
quote you read is incredibly misleading
in my opinion uh so I I agree with you
but but here here it is I mean this is a
private organization do we really want
the government sensor listen in the same
way that the government probably says if
you say vaccines you know uh just look
at Brian look at um Maddie dear just for
telling her
story they said that's false information
and they censored her her mother and
anybody that sought to repost just their
own personal story she say this is what
happened to me it's always dangerous in
my opinion it's it's the greater danger
to censor speech always um and you know
represent leus yeah I did notice that
they worded it very carefully so that
they did not actually lie they said
there was no evidence to link them what
they didn't say was that there was no
evidence to the contrary either right so
it makes it sound like it's fine they're
not related just but what we saw from
what you had was yes there's no evidence
either way but they carefully just gave
one so it wasn't a lie it was just
misleading is that what the language
said no link yeah so the um the header
is evidence shows vaccines unrelated to
autism and then it's says medical and
legal authorities agree that no evidence
exists that vaccines cause autism yeah
but they don't tell you there's no
evidence that it doesn't cause autism I
and I would I would tell you that there
are a uh a lot of medical professionals
who would take strong disagreement that
there's no evidence that vaccines have
potentially I mean look we know this
much and really I didn't want to debate
vaccines and autism but um you know
autism is a dsm5 diagnosis it's a
psychiatric diagnosis right so really
yeah it's in the dsm5 so it's a it's a
symptomatology and if you meet those
those three categories of symptoms you
get that diagnosis it doesn't that tells
you nothing about the ideology doesn't
tell you anything about what causes it
if you have lead poisoning and you end
up with those symptoms you can end up
potentially with that diagnosis but
they'll really just say you have lead
poison
right so so saying autism is just it's
just a set of features basically so for
example we know prusa vaccine you look
at the Pack's insert it will tell you
right a contraindication is if your
child has had here I'll pull it up let's
we could look at it together quickly um
but so that you
know so we can go to FDA licensed
vaccines um
and if we go down and we look at you
know at a a deept
vaccine can look at that we go to the
package insert here it is this is given
a 24 and six months and it will tell you
directly
that
if contraindications so it says incopy
which means coma decreased level of
Consciousness and prolonged seizure
within 7 Days of a previous dose of
protest containing
that is not attributable to another
identifiable cause is a contr indication
administration of any protos Vine
including dapto cell that's the way
dapto cell describes it and then I'll
just to show you that the other one also
infinis similarly has the same conations
of both of the DTaP vaccines also says
in section
4.2 it
says same
thing you could read it there so in
sopath means brain damage that's what it
means all right um en sephtis means
inflammation of the brain incopy means a
pathology of the brain so you have some
actual brain damage now coma decreased
level of conscious prolonged seizures
are the softer uh uh examples of incopy
there's worse and there's been a lot of
cases compensating the vaccine injury
Compensation Program of children who
have significant debilitating brain d
image after a pressus vaccine containing
vaccine who've been compensated in
vicp and um um and for those children
there have been a a num many of them
also had
autism because they have the
features the symptoms that give them
that diagnosis now the vaccine court is
not compensating you for autism
compensate you for theopathy for the
brain damage right because that's the
actual physical manifestation the fact
that you end up with a psychiatric
condition that can be diagnosed as
autism that's not what's can be
considered directly compensated but I
mean did the vaccine which caused a seal
opathy result in the autism well you can
read a peer riew there's a a Law Journal
article by Mary Holland where she
actually documents she had her uh her
law students at NYU when she was a
professor at NYU they went through all
the case files and they found a few
dozen cases where really based on that
laww article they said yeah they were
compensating for autism but they just
they just hid it in other conditions
right so um uh with all of that said you
know
um you know it the important point
though is is really that you know when
when the medical community says oh we
have you know we we thoroughly study
vaccine safety like they do with covid
vaccines oh don't worry we thoroughly
studied covid-19 vaccine safety because
right um
I I I I use autism as the way to show
that there's question marks when they
make that claim and I don't think that
any government should force anybody to
get this product they should let them do
their own homework because even with the
most the claim that they the the injury
they claim they have most thoroughly
studied autism they haven't done it um
this is the childhood vaccine schedule
right now actually without covid vaccine
and you could see they've studied MMR
the yellow and that's of the ingredients
they studied that one the marasol that's
what they've studied for
autism um I could show you a video of
why it's important to you know to study
this if you would like this is a family
with triplets um who all three of their
kids developed autism shortly after a
det after a prevenar vaccine or do you
want me to keep
going
okay we have triplet two boys and a girl
Richie Robbie and Claire every day in
our life was a party every single day
they were smiling and laughing and
looking at each other engaging in each
other on June
25th 2007 we brought him in for the numo
shot my daughter still has the mark on
her light from the shot she was the
first one to get it and she screamed and
never really stopped screaming after
that but we Contin we didn't know we did
the boys as well
by noon Claire shut completely off it
was as if she was blind and deaf and all
she did at that moment was stare at the
ceiling van so that was at noon we had
the shot at 10:00
a.m.
2:00 we watched Richie shut off they
lost all their reflexes um I'm an
educational audiologist I actually did
the test for the stapedial reflex which
is a little muscle in the middle ear
just to see if a muscle they can't
control was still working and it it
didn't um The sedal Reflex dampens sound
so your ears don't hurt from a really
loud sound and both of them had no
stapedial reflex they stopped blinking
stopped yawning stopped coughing stopped
sneezing the worst is we the shut down
we were told it was genetic and then we
were told by geneticist that there's no
possible way three children would shut
off on the same day so we had severe
autis
um Spectrum Disorder for all three kids
entering kindergarten we have spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars trying
to them the only person that we got back
is Rich
Robbie the one that was last to shut off
Richie can only say singles maybe two
words together Claire is still
completely nonverbal not P trained and
Robbie is approaching grade level but
severe OCD what do you do Property
Management
um want me tell you what a day in our
life so you got say a six or seven or
eight year old child who's not potty
trained and a two or three 4 o' in the
morning they build their diap assum it's
pretty uncomfortable so they take it off
pretty soon pretty soon it's all over
them it's all over the bed in shorted
order it's all over me it's all over her
uh I'm snapping at her she's snapping at
me we're both snapping at the kid who is
the only innocent party in the whole
scenario and the one thing that's
conspicuously absent in that scenario is
uh is anybody who told you that shot was
safe they're all asleep in their bed
they haven't got a problem in
world I think that Dad said it best
so when you think about
um
uh what the science Community or the way
the FDA and CDC and NIH and all of them
approach vaccine saf
Vis
autism it it it gives you a backdrop in
which and how they approach covid
vaccine safety and if you think autism
is an aberration even though it's the
thing they say they've studied the most
I'll quickly run through just a few
other things for other vaccines and then
we'll switch it over to to covid vaccine
okay um so um going back to the 2012 ior
report we talked about earlier
so I noted to you then that the CDC and
HRC paid the to review what they said
were the 158 most commonly claimed
serious injuries from vaccines now these
are the ones that they say are the most
commonly claimed
injuries in that review the I found that
for 18 of them evidence supported a
causal relationship and these are
serious reactions okay so they said yeah
vaccines cause
18 which is
troubling five of the issues they
rejected including MMR and autism was
one of the
five but this maybe is the most
troubling for 135 of the most commonly
claimed serious injuries from vaccines
by their admission the evidence was
insufficient to reach conclusion they
hadn't done the studies they don't know
because their clinical trial data is
vacuous as we've seen and they just
don't do the studies otherwise for the
most part just like autism there's a
link to the in medicine report you could
see it directly and I would focus on the
uh uh uh on there's a summary table
where you can look at all of the
conditions by vaccine and what the ca
Sol conclusion
is if that's not suff so that gives us a
sense of again that they're not studying
the again it repeat it shows again
they're not studying even the most
commonly claimed injuries what injuries
can vaccines cause okay now in the
package insert we looked at se 6.1
before remember and it that showed the
clinical trial experience well in
section
6.2 is the postmarketing
experience okay and that is after it's
licensed the manufacturer if they have a
Bion to believe there's a causal not
correlation causal relationship between
the vaccine and the injury they're
supposed to put it in section 6.2
they're not allowed to put stuff in
that's just correlation how do I know
that I'll read you the Federal
Regulation this is the code of Federal
Regulation section 21 CFR 2 1.57 and it
provides that package interest vaccine
should include quote
only only those Adverse Events for which
there is some basically there's a causal
relationship between the drug and occurr
to the adverse event not correlation
causal relationship and I can tell you
in practice in practice from my
experience and you can go and look at
the licensure documents so forth they
really only put stuff in vaccine package
inserts where they really see a causal
relationship because under the 1986 act
for the most
part you can still get them for fraud so
if they have they know it can cause and
they don't put it in there you can you
can potentially sue them but otherwise
they're not really concerned about
putting it in there so really when they
have evidence and and here's a let me
show you the reflection of that here is
Spike fact this is mad's covid vaccine
this is the only issues they disclosed
at least when I took that screenshot in
section 6.2 post marketing they got
myocarditis pericarditis right
anaphylaxis and synup meaning fainting
that's it that's all they
disclose now we know a lot of the there
are a lot of other injuries neuropathies
and so forth but they're not in this
because madna didn't reach the point
where they have like you know they they
really only put stuff where they feel
like they have to admit it okay
here's that here's what's disclosed for
that hepatitis B vaccine that we looked
at earlier a combox HB given to a one-
day old
baby these are serious
conditions I'm not saying I don't I
can't tell you the rate at which these
happen but I know they happen enough for
the pharmaceutical
company to believe to have evidence to
believe they're causally related to
disclose them in the package
insert I don't write the federal RS
that's just what they are uh yes so
unless you're actually before you go to
your pediatrician or your doctor or
whatever to get a shot unless you
actually do your research and read this
data technically you have no idea
because they don't really give you this
information at the doctor's so they
won't really disclose it is that correct
uh pediatricians that vaccinate children
as far as I'm aware not provide this
information to their patients before
administering vaccines they don't even
provide typically there's something
under federal law they're supposed to
give called the vaccine information
sheet the 1986 Act created this ADV
required the CDC create a short little
thing called the vaccine information
sheet that has certain disclosures and
under federal law pediatricians are
supposed to provide that before they
administer vaccines and um you know I
don't have a survey but um I I'm I'm I
know that it's common for them not even
to give that minimal
disclosure represent
Penza yeah I was just going to ask about
that disclosure in relation um with uh
the covid vaccines um there was Zero
informed consent with the eua vaccines
but were were they given that kind of
pass as well in regards with that
because of course every every uh vaccine
insert was blank it set on there
intentionally blank I have those um so
and then um I have another question as a
followup but I just you know my children
re you know we received those the sheet
that you're talking about but it did not
give uh the level of information that
would cause a parent to say oh well
maybe we we won't go through that it was
more very minor fever dis comfort that
kind of thing not not those types of
serious things that were on an insert
and um the other piece is too um when
you ask the pediatrician For That
vaccine insert and I've done this myself
multiple times um we were flat out told
no if you could share
what
sorry so yeah if in regards with the
covid vaccines there was no informed
consent no handouts no nothing that was
given I mean in in New Hampshire there
was there was nothing so I kind of want
to in in a traditional sense with
traditional vaccines what they're
supposed to do which is not necessarily
always uh you know um yeah and it's very
very hard almost impossible to find
anything on the internet for traditional
vaccines without just saying do it do it
do it right so um but when it came to
covid even the minimal that we knew
right was thrown out the window um in
New Hampshire I mean we had we had
drivethru vaccination clinics in malls
uh we had it at the New Hampshire Motor
Speedway and you drive up in your car
and you get your shot there was no
informed consent these people didn't
even know what they were doing some of
them that were doing those injections so
I just kind of want to kind of
understand where we were at where we had
something
and then we went into absolutely
nothing I mean the I mean there is a V
for covid vaccines now back then they
did have something that they had put
together for when it was eua for
patients there was a document I'm not
aware of uh if it was distributed or or
I'm I suspect it was given out as
frequently as the VIS was before
covid-19 vaccines was given to parents
for childhood vaccines but those V's are
the approach that that the CDC takes in
terms of Designing them is they don't
want to scare parents away they have a
policy for increasing vaccine updates
they have metrics for how many children
the percentage that they want to hit for
children vaccinated they have no
percentage for how many kids they want
to make sure aren't injured from a
vaccine there's no focus on that
whatsoever that's not where the money
flows it's not where the focus is the
focus is on vaccine uptake and so those
V's are are specifically designed in
fact um you know the VIS has used to
have a bit more disclosure in terms of
harm for example the MMR vaccine package
uh V used to literally say brain damage
as a as a potential harm those are the
words brain damage um Dr Stanley plin
was not happy about the deposition I
think that uh he had with me and I we
have foed for all his emails with this
CDC and the FDA he went on a campaign to
get them to update their V's to remove a
whole a whole host of you know uh
potential harms that are disclosed and
to put them into broader term buckets U
we have we have those emails they
they're quite they're quite interesting
so yeah I mean the disclosure prevx the
disclosures that occurred even before
covid were you know I mean you go into a
typical pediatric office they'll tell
you safe and effective nothing to worry
about don't worry whatsoever um and you
know often times what they'll say to you
is look children have gotten healthier
because of vaccines look look at look
look around kids aren't dying every day
right um well let's talk about that for
one second second and and then I think
we're ready to get back to covid
vaccines um you see in front of you the
difference between vaccination schedule
for the CDC from during pregnancy and up
to 12 months uh you could go down there
there a CDC link you can that link down
there has all the CDC uh vaccine
schedules going all the way back to I
believe 83 so you can go see them for
yourself and this is a representation of
them um 86 there were three routine
vaccines as we talked about GTP opv
there was also MMR but that's after one
year of age this is again up to 12
months um if we did the all up to 18
years we that we would need a lot bigger
picture so this is up to 12 months and
then those are the rest of the shots um
I and I can tell you this thing is is
accurate so um quite a big difference
well you know uh have kids gotten
healthier since the 80s good question
right I mean that's that's what we've
been looking to accomplish here 1986
according to the uh the available data
12.8% of kids had a chronic health
condition in
America we have now in 2017 at least had
53 doses of vaccine
54% um have a chronic health condition
in America as of 2011 according to one
CDC study take out obesity and it's
still close to 50% so high 40s so you
know you've got um a a lock step
increase to be sure I'm saying
correlation I'm saying correlation but
you have a correlative increase in the
number of doses right administered on
the left side to the percentage of
children with a chronic health issue and
I can say this much a lot of The Chronic
health issues that have exploded are
immune or immune mediated issues
something as simple as asthma which has
exploded over the last few decades is an
immune system disregulation that's what
it is right your lungs improperly have
an immune reaction in there um and so a
lot of these conditions something has
gone wrong with the immune system of our
children's including neurological issues
that are immune mediated um you know you
would think the first place you would
look is the product given to them dozens
of times to modify their immune system
they tell you vaccines are powerful they
tell you they're effective they tell you
have systemic immunity right you inject
here and you have immunity in your toes
right they have a systemic reaction well
um you know what other effects can I
have um and so on your immune system and
there's lots of studies out there that
um can be concerned we talked about the
aluminum Aden studies a little bit
earlier and there's lots of others um
the one thing Public Health authorities
have not done is they have not compared
vaccinated unvaccinated well they've not
published any studies comparing
vaccinated and unvaccinated children and
it would be easy to do because you can
just do it using existing Health
Insurance data databases you could do it
retrospectively that data is there The
Institute of medicine in that 2014 I
report that was referenced in that uh
website that Institute of medicine
report would looked at the safety of the
entire schedule that's what that report
was for they concluded there's no
evidence to say it's safe it's not safe
they concluded they don't know
okay but one of the things they said is
that the CDC has something called the
vaccine safety data link this is a over
10 hmos deidentified
ICD9 and 10 codes those are the
diagnostic codes that you Bill insurance
companies with so it Aggregates all that
information for over 10 all for over 10
million Americans and in that database
there are thousands of completely
unvaccinated kids zero vaccines and
they've even validated their un vac by
by doing sampling of their medical
records and so
forth the CDC could in a minute simply
run a compar comparison of all the kids
that got one or more shots to the kids
that got no shots zero and one or more
okay those would be the two comparative
groups and you would say okay what is
the rate of neurological harm in this
group versus this IM immun asthma this
group this group just pick your
conditions go down the list just run
them all and see what the differential
is that study has never been published
after I said they could do it in 2014
the CDC spent oodles of
money publishing a white paper on how
they could do it that study and it's on
the CDC website Stanley pling was one of
the people by the way who it's part of
the white paper uh and still we don't
have that study if they've done it they
haven't published it um
but uh the uh School University of
Jackson Department of epidemiology did a
study small based on
surveys uh retrospective epid you know I
mean it's uh certainly could be far more
robust studies but it's something versus
nothing and it showed that vaccinated
kids at 30 times the rate of rantis is
unvaccinated 3.9 times the rate of
allergy ADHD four times autism azema
learning disability sorry
neurodevelopmental Disorder so this is
actually the one of the only few vacs
versus unv studies I'm aware of and the
findings on it are startling and if the
health department can certainly take
shots I mean you can take shots at any
epidemiological so you can say well you
know it's based on Parental recall it's
based on surveys is how you know how
random is your sampling sure you could
do that but um uh you can take shots at
it but you you know um you know a lot of
credit goes to these scientists who
stuck their neck out to do this study
without Niah funding and knowing they're
going to get Ken for doing it it's
incredible they actually did it frankly
more incredible it exists in any
published literature long story short
short there's no studies that rebut
this and in terms of the the the scope
of the harm so we've looked at what
harms might be caused by vaccines sched
by Pharma companies we've looked at the
fact that they failed to study them um
and and uh We've looked at what the some
of the evidence that might show what
what the health outcomes what the impact
might be of this increasing vaccine
schedule well how many people are harmed
potentially what's you know to get an
indication of that a signal we could
look at vars and I'm going to 2019 pre
pandemic and this is the number of of of
reports of you know to vars of serious
issues death permanent disability
hospitalizations emergency office visits
and I will point out that back then this
was a federal government study conducted
by Harvard it found that fewer than 1%
of Adverse Events are reported to vs I
think it's probably increased since Co
because people are more aware of vs now
but if you you know this is terrible
science by the way what I just did
terrible science I just said right now
but if if it's 1% okay so let's multiply
that by 100 I'm not saying these numbers
are that's right I I'm I'm making clear
this is terrible science but this is
kind of the best approximation I have I
don't somebody's got a better study I'll
take it I'm happy to look at that data
okay so
um gonna now switch over to uh covid
vaccines
okay so there are two systems
and and um that the CDC basically says
they rely upon primarily to assess the
safety of covid-19 vaccines same systems
by the way that they primarily will say
well not the same but uh one is vs the
vaccine adver events reporting system
which is co- administered by the CDC and
the FDA and the other one is a new
system that they rolled out just for go
called vsafe okay it's brand new so and
if you look at the studies that CDC
publishes they primarily focus on vs and
vfe to assert the safety of covid-19
vaccines and I and I as we go through
this um you know uh I've I've took the
time to go through all the other
vaccines so that you're not shocked at
the way that the CDC handled covid
vaccines you will see that this is a bit
of business as usual now starting with
theirs the CDC when truth was original
to them back in December mber 4th 2020
so that's before 16 days before the
first covid vaccine rolled out into
American Arms and December
20th they
published a guide right there's the link
to the CDC website on how they were
going to analyze Bears data oh there we
go science we come up with a plan we
design a study plan and then we
implement it and we then we look at the
results and we take them for what they
are because that's science we don't
change change Midstream we don't like
what we're seeing that's not science
that's the perversion of science okay or
maybe well let leave it at that so here
it is here is their report on how they
were going to analyze vs data let's just
take a look at it signal detection
methods and data analysis I'm going to
read it um it's not this it's not the
most exciting thing but I I'll go
through it quick the analysis for
covid-19 vaccines safety signals will
focus on identifying deviations from
preliminary safety data and possibly
from other vaccines using
disproportionately analysis and
comparisons reporting rates next
paragraph two main approaches to data
mining are here here it comes
proportional reporting ratios prr K and
empirical basing geometric means so
those are two different ways to analyze
the data and vars both have published
literature suggestion criteria for
detecting
signals PR will be used as at CDC for
potential signal detection empirical
basing data mining EB analysis will be
performed by FDA okay after initial
licensure approval covid-19 vaccine
United States initial reports may be too
few to allow for data mining immediately
as the data matures PR and EB data
mining can then be used the data matured
very quickly I think too quickly for
their liking okay so here it is they
said the CDC said they're going to use
PR to a signal detect in vs well how are
they going to do it on this slide on the
left side what they said is that they
would consider something a safety signal
if there were at least three
cases the the uh the chai square was at
least four and the pr was at least two
okay so if you look at column 1 2 and
three it needs to be in the First Column
above a three in the second column above
a four and the third column above a two
to be considered a
signal by the cdc's
standard for what is a signal in vs well
let's see what they found oh and by the
way what you're seeing here on the right
this chart CDC didn't just hand this
over this took a lot of Demands fighting
and CDC finally coughed this over long
after it had this data and and and
demands were being made for it all kinds
of I mean we were not the only ones
going after lots of folks going after
this data and they finally had to cough
it Senators newspapers uh and so forth
well let's just look at it cerebral
thrombosis 194 that's a little more than
three cases the chai square is 69.7
eight a little more than four and the pr
was above two and the pr is really the
main thing they focus on anything above
a two is a signal they had a 73 for Cal
thrombosis look down this list these are
all
serious conditions abnormal uterine
bleeding
30 in fact it's so long that actually I
had to make a second page and then it
keeps going so this is the second page
you can go through this list but these
are these are serious
issues and the
CDC based on the way science should be
done is you come up with the design how
you're going to approach it and you live
with the result while the result did not
fit the policy CDC a policy organization
these numbers do not
fit
so what did the CDC do about this very
very troubling set of numbers and and
findings and
signals this is a um a letter from the
US Senate committee on homeland security
and government Affairs which I think
Senator Ron Johnson is the head of and
he wrote them and he said the J now he
used the January
2021 uh um criteria which is identical
to the one you just saw from December by
the way okay I don't know why he used
the January one but whatever it doesn't
matter
sop described the types of data mining
analysis CDC and FDA conduct to identify
potential safety concerns linked to
covid-19 vaccines these analyses
included PR we just looked at that and
EB data mining which is what the FDA is
supposed to do in a September 2 20122
response to my request CDC director
rable inform my office that so here's
the head of the CDC walking back the
whole PR thing because it doesn't look
good what does she say quote CDC and the
FDA chose to rely on EB data mining oh
so we're not going to use PR now a more
robust technique used to analyze
disproportional reporting really did it
say that in the initial report no rather
than PR calculations to mitigate
potential false signals given the
strength of the EB data mining method
CDC and FDA plan to continue relying
upon EB data mining moving forward
ah PR gone out the window now we're
going to use EB
analysis fine let's use EB analysis you
know what that looks
like exactly don't know you know why the
FDA won't give it to us we have sued
them now
twice we have I'm sorry uh we sued them
once uh somebody else sued them as well
and uh this is a federal court order
which says they can wait another a year
and a have to give it to
us the federal judge federal court order
you can look at these yourselves um the
FDA complained that they have they're
too busy to produce it um data that's
deid to be clear deidentified data that
discloses no personal indent file
information that is in a spreadsheet
that they could literally go disclosed
and here's the best part CDC has the
data already in their possession the EB
mining data
and the FDA has it too I know they
already have it they they've admitted
they have it to us in federal when we
were uh um litigating with the doj on
this but um um this court decided they
don't have to produce it for now so so
let me understand something okay the pr
data that you just showed us was from
the CDC is that correct yes this is the
yes this is their findings okay
and the numbers are off the charts based
on their criteria their criteria yes
okay but in the FDA which is a separate
branch of government that should be
independent of the
CDC um because one does one thing the
other one does another thing they're now
going to rely on just they're going to
collaborate sounds like because they're
both going to come up with the same
report based on what they're using is
that correct they're no longer going to
rely on PR because apparently it's
unreliable um and and now they're only
going to rely on empirical basing
analysis according to the director of
the CDC and her letter to the uh uh
committee that I just read to you
okay I'm sorry to keep asking these
questions
um because I'm I'm concerned obviously
um because here I keep hearing safe and
effective safe and effective but as I
look at this
information it really there's there's
concerns
um so and now we're trying to push it as
part of the childhood vaccine schedule
it is on the childhood vaccine schedule
yes starting at six months two
doses six months and seven months first
two doses covid-19 vaccine uh
representative Penza
now I have a different qu thank you
madam chair now I have a different
question but um just based upon this I
just want to be clear so these numbers
let's just you know all the yellows that
are off the charts are really all based
upon EVS which um you know there's been
a couple different things that kind of
studied vars for a while uh you know
we're looking at probably still you know
maybe 1% of the reporting so or you know
some people say it's less than 1% but in
all actuality and we've had more Vees
reporting than ever before for covid-19
vaccines I just want you to um speak to
that and then um so if that's the case
just based upon we're we're missing you
know over 90% of the population as
well yeah I I V's reporting preco no
doubt was way in my assessment and
Harvard study by the government found it
was less than 1% was probably way less
1% reporting to vs is no simple task if
you've ever tried to
fill uh the government does not make it
easy to submit a v report you should go
try it sometime um it is very
complicated um they they don't make it
simple at all um most folks who try to
submit it will tell you they have to try
numerous times it takes him a tremendous
amount of time to do it and so really it
takes a really motiv clinician and it's
and and most reports preo certainly the
you know 70% were from clinicians or the
Pharma company so you know this whole
thing of like random people are
submitting stuff it's that's not what
most reports are you need a really
motivated person to submit um those
reports I I will suspect I have no
empirical data to show this I've not
looked at it but I suspect that the
number that for covid vaccines because
there was so much attention on this
product the uh there was a greater I
don't know what it is but I think
there's probably more reporting to Vees
than there was um for other vaccines
historically I I suspect it's you know
but even if it's seven times as much you
might still be under 1% by the way
follow up but I don't know I don't know
I'm speculating thank you madam chair um
yeah that so what you mentioned is just
another piece too and we've heard that
our committee's heard it but um I've
heard it for the last several years um
in regards with uh um nurses doctors
practitioners are not trained I mean
you've got the what the CDC puts out
right but there nobody's ever been
trained and a lot of people are not even
familiar that are in the medical field
of of what VES is absolutely most
medical professionals in my experience
have no idea what vs is never heard of
it and understand that under federal law
the only obligation to report to vs is
is is a
is typically the the administrator of
the vaccine and only for certain
conditions so think about that if you go
through one of these drive-throughs
you're gone so you go see another doctor
that doctor arguably does not have I say
arguably because I I'd like
to to report it but they're not they're
not the administrator of the vaccine so
um you know issues that arise that are
not literally immediate immediate like
immediate anap axis even have you know
um the administrator is not there now if
you go if you get the vaccine at the
hospital at a hospital and you go back
to the same Hospital most people don't
get vaccines at a hospital um you know
then then might be and and you have a
condition that's one of the mandatory
reporting then you might have a
mandatory reporting situation but for
the most part most adverse effects
there's no you don't encounter a medical
professional when you afterwards that
that has an obligation to report to vs
it's actually rare in my opinion in my
experience follow up sorry um yeah thank
you madam chair so what you just said is
so important too because in you know and
I know it was probably like this in most
States but in New Hampshire that roll
out was was fast and furious and of
course it was you know there were
medical professionals that were first
but when it was kind of this um you know
drive-thru type of environment you had
um our our New Hampshire National C was
activated and in doing injections and
there were reports of where people got
slumped over in their car afterward but
that that speaks to none of that none of
those things were it's not like a
computer no none of them were qualified
they weren't doctors or nurses or
anything like that in in administering
these um injections so none of that
stuff got reported and we had like I
said there was at malls and all of these
other things I mean what is the
percentage of people that went to really
like whether it be a a doctor or a
hospital to have gotten a vaccine during
that time I really recall six months of
it being this kind of massive in these
vaccination clinics where these people
wouldn't have ever reported anything
well I actually I mean it's bad news for
those who got who had issues but great
news in terms of answering your question
which is I actually have the best and
most reliable robust data to answer
precisely what percentage of Americans
ended up in hospital after covid vaccine
and that's from the vsafe database and
I'm going to get to that right after the
vs and I'll show that to you I will
point out um that these these numbers
from vs are considered signal detections
they're they're just supposed to be
signals that that supposed to Merit
further investigation but that'll be
maybe too many things for them to
investigate which is why I don't think
they want to do it and um if I would be
uh if I could I don't make a a bold
statement is that you know there's
really uh for the most part
exists um to help affirm vaccine safety
never really to find
issues they will publish studies saying
they looked at vs and they didn't find
anything so it doesn't cause that issue
but they will never look at vs and say
based on vs it does cause an issue they
tell you it's a signal detection system
it can never prove causation but yet but
yet they will rely on it to say that a
vaccine is
safe so you it really when you really
step back from bears you'll understand
it only can prove one thing safety it it
can they will once in a while say Well
it gave us a signal that we then
investigated and found yes it's a
problem but they'll never say ver showed
us there was a problem but it can be
used to show safety um that's the way
they use it representative
Belgium thank you madam chair
um as far as that data goes uh simple
question is obviously we don't have the
uh whatever the EB method the other
method that was FDA originally was using
we don't have those numbers I don't like
the fact or reason we don't have those
numbers but we do have these numbers the
prr method so my question on this is is
there a history behind the pr method has
it previously been validated and
utilized in such a manner yes and and
actually we can look at the cdc's own
words in that regard it says says here
that
um it says both have published speaking
of PR and EB both have published
literature suggestion criteria for
detecting signals uh perer use blah blah
and then
um well it says they both have published
literature and they also go on to more
validate it but I don't have that part
in my slide but yes they both have
existing literature and history of being
used they're not just made up for the
purposes of covid perfect thank you
um
okay so uh uh moving on to uh to vfe so
we now we've covered vs so Vees didn't
look good based on the pr and we don't
have the EB and there's probably a
reason we don't have it because I'm you
know um I'm going to assume it doesn't
again align with the policy that they
have regarding these
products well that brings us to the
other safety system and that's called
vsafe vsafe
was a safety system rolled out
specifically to assess the safety of co9
vaccines okay after Decades of saying vs
is their Premier system they kind of
abandoned it interestingly it was was
interesting to watch it happen and with
the December roll out December 2020 they
rolled out
vsafe vsafe is not like theirs it is not
intended for you to just report when you
have an issue it's intended for
everybody to use and to start using
basically right before you get your
first shot so you sign up you get your
shot and then you get a survey so the
idea is to get a um a baseline
unconnected to let's call it user bias
whereas vs is really just there to
report issues vsafe was there to just
get a baseline of all
users and um they got they have about 10
million Americans signed up for vsafe
about 9 million of them signed up in the
first few months between December and
and May and remember this was the period
of time in America there were no
mandates this is when people were
clamoring over each other dances were
being done on two vaccines you know
there was no uh uh uh nobody who didn't
want one was getting one in fact people
were getting arrested because they were
trying to cut ahead of the line to get
him and so these were the the vaccine
folks who were really excited about this
product they were running out they were
getting the vaccine and and in fact this
was part of that excitement was signing
up for vsafe this was they felt this
part of the civic duty in fact there's a
survey that part of V why'd you sign up
a lot of them said it was part of my
civic duty I want them to participate in
this so um so it's it's far better than
Vees because it has a denominator where
they say well Vees we don't know we we
have yeah sure 30,000 people said
reported death but like I don't know
what's out of how many and you know and
this many reported this condition but
out of how many well for this we have a
denominator we have 10 million users if
a million report an issue that's 10% so
way better than veers in that regard and
I would argue way better than clinical
trial data why how do you know there's
an adverse event in a clinical trial you
ask the participant they show up at the
clinical trial site like Maddie and you
say hey I was injured and you know they
do an excellent job of writing it down
and transmitting it to the FDA I mean
just perfect job so you get uh um in in
a clinical trial you're getting the data
the same way you're getting it from the
clinical trial participant but unlike a
clinical trial where the data goes to
the Pharma company the sponsor filtered
through them to the FDA and then from
there maybe to the public if we sue them
in federal court for a year like we had
to do to get clinical trial data
here you have 10 million folks not
30,000 in a clinical trial doing the
same thing to a standardized
survey and we got access to the data
directly took two Federal lawsuits in in
two years but we got
it okay and I'm going to show you what
this data is right now I'm going to walk
you through it in detail
please good R thank you madam chair just
real quick yeah I was going to ask about
um what the process was cuz I I remember
um I remember the lawsuit the first one
and and about having to get this like
what was the you know kind of what was
the brick wall that you had to go
through the vfe data you mean yes yeah
how did that just quickly like what was
the brick wall yeah oh the Department of
Justice said no and then they said no
and then they said no like 600 more
times eventually they said yes that's
kind of the the way those litigations go
I mean look the the the the federal
government has uh just a little bit of
our money and our resources and
unfortunately they forget that they
serve the public and the people of this
country and they view themselves as
their own independent entity to be
defended and so you know um they they
are
are typically of the of the view that
they'll just wait you out they'll fight
you and fight you and you don't have the
resources to do it but we're very
fortunate because I can the inform and
Action Network funds these lawsuits and
they fund them and they make sure that
we have the resources and the attorneys
um to fight these things for years and
we do we don't let them
go follow up so yeah do you guys
um two years and I can't imagine the
amount of money to be able to get it so
do they are they do they end up having
to pay back those legal fees that
because they they stonewalled the whole
time uh so um so in a freedom
information act yes they do have to um
if you're successful and you meet the
criteria they do have to pay some they
do have to pay attorney's fees but you
can imagine uh first of all are very
high risk cases that most attorneys
would not take on Plain to side purely
on contingency and two you obviously
have to carry the the costs of of your
entire team for that entire time um you
know until that comes at the end of the
day so uh I I you know I would love if
every lawyer in the country decided to
go after the CDC and FDA for
transparency I welcome it please do so I
would be wonderful but um uh it's it's
not um it will not be a lucrative
practice so you know eyes wide open uh
and they know that that's why most folks
aren't going to do it so um so uh I'm
going to play a short video from the CDC
that describes be safe
[Music]
all right there it is that's vsafe
there's lots of these videos go to
YouTube CDC made a bunch of them they
got posters everywhere I think they
really regretted doing that because you
will see very quickly why they think
they regretted it
vsafe like theirs I think was actually
very much intended to be able to just
prove safety but since it was new they
had I think they kind of messed up so
and I'll walk you through that right now
let's start with what did vafe gather
okay it gathered two types of
information check the box data and then
free Tex field data all
right I'm sorry this isn't
more titillating but so in the check the
box data there's two types of check the
boox data that it gathered first thing
we symptoms it had a list of symptoms
you could check if you had those
symptoms all right that's the first
category check the box data here's the
list of the symptoms chills headache
joint pains body aches fatigue nausea
okay these are the very symptoms that
the CDC tells you are totally normal to
have for the first first week after
vaccination in fact they tell you it's
good it's called reactogenicity it shows
the vaccinees working it shows you're
having an immune reaction so having
these symptoms having these symptoms
means the vaccine is creating immunity
in your body and it's expected to happen
at a high rate now they don't want to
have you don't want to have like grade
three or four too many people but they
want if it's fine if it's happens in
grade one or two to most folks okay and
when you look at this
list you might notice there's a few
things
missing how about heart how about chest
pain from our card
pericarditis how about neuropathy right
how about just tingling in your
extremities right how about the symptoms
at least of the things how about transer
my life how about GBS or at least the
symptoms of those conditions you might
say well maybe they didn't know the
vaccine could cause those issues well
let's take a look and before I jump to
do that I just want to make sure you
understand that what they did ask was
totally
useless this data that they collected
for symptoms for the and they only
collected for the first week after each
shot that's it was useless here is who
was the head of the cdc's immunization
office he said vve just not it's just
not designed to directly monitor
specific Adverse Events outside of
reactogenic Adverse Events and you can
read that there's a a link there to this
whole email exchange where basically
they admit like this stuff's pointless
to gather and in fact when you look at
the studies they publish most of these
conditions 40 50 60 70% of people
reported them so what was the point of
gathering them there really was no
point
okay here is a CDC presentation to their
vaccine committee from October of
2020 take a look at what they suspected
the vaccine can cause
this is the preliminary list of their's
Adverse Events of special interest this
is the CDC in the v in their own vacine
asip advisory Community anization
practices their own slide and what did
they say they suspected the co vaccinees
might do oh gomber syndrome seizures
Strokes narcolepsy anaphylaxis acute Mar
heart attacks myocarditis pericarditis
thrombocytopenia go down the list the
very same
issues we saw the vaccine end up
causing did they put these conditions
here
no but they knew about them do you want
to see something even more incredible
you
ready this is the vsafe protocol from
November 19220 remember the vaccine
didn't roll out to December 2020 this is
the last page of their protocol that
they used to design vsafe
this is their Adverse Events of special
interest pre-specified medical
conditions this is in their own design
documents for vsafe look at the
conditions they
listed the same ones again
anaphylaxis blood
clotting GBS go down the list the very
same issues that we saw Americans around
this country suffering but again so here
it is is in the vsafe protocol I just oh
I you won't see my screen if I pull it
up will you okay it doesn't matter you
can the link is right there and you can
pull it up the whole thing but the the
the important point is that they knew
these
conditions could be an issue and they
call them Adverse Events of special
interest pre-specified medical
conditions but did they end up on this
list no did the symptoms of these
conditions end up this no in fact they
just left that list with the things that
I mean were pretty much pointless you
know it's really
hard to prove like men's Rea it's hard
to prove like a a a a bad state of mind
like a premeditated bad conduct to me
this list they had this they identified
them they said these were of concern and
they left them off at least the symptoms
of these from their there lists of
symptoms in vfe to me that's
premeditated potential that's proof of
premeditated conduct yes represent Penza
uh thank you madam chair a quick
question about um when people were
filling that out you had said that it
was one week so how did that symptoms
okay so let's say for example I signed
up yes and um I I filled it out
initially were if I wanted to go back
and give other information was I cut off
from that
um once you submitted you would you
would have to do it in the next reports
so um it was every day for seven days
including the symptoms and then the
other stuff I'm about to show you and
then once a week up to six weeks and
then at 3 six and 12
months after each
dose okay thank you okay so that was the
first category of check the box data I
don't know why they bothered collecting
it and all the studies that they publish
show those rates were crazy high and
they don't care second category data so
here it is this is the only other check
the box data that they gathered it was
three things at the top there were you
unable to work were you unable to do
your normal daily activity or did you
get Med did you go get uh care from a
doctor or other healthc care
professional if you checked that you
needed Medical Care it then would open
up that other list of options that you
can see on your screen did you need tah
Health outpa Urgent Care emergency room
or hospitalization and then you could
check those Okay so remember this system
is called vsafe it's here to assess
safety so presumably this is where they
were going to assess safety where else
would they assess it right so I assume
then and the most concerning one of
these is seeking medical care so you
would assume there was a number there
was a level at which they said okay if
we hit that number problem with the
product will pull it so one of a
thousand people say Medical Care One in
100 one in 50 one I don't know what that
number is but you would assume there's a
number I don't think there was a number
and I'll show you why okay
the CDC while I was fighting with them
for two years to get this data this
check the box data from those 10 million
users they published over 40
studies they said covid-19 vaccines are
safe these are the body of literature
that the scientific Community says they
rely upon and when they did that in
every one of those studies this is what
they did they only reported the number
seeking emergency V uh uh seeking
medical care for the first week after
the shot that's it that's it just for
the first seven days even though they
know even though they had the data for
two week third week fourth week fifth
week sixth week why collect the data if
they're not going to report it obviously
they did it for they did it because they
know Co injuries vaccine injuries can
occur with weeks after vaccination just
like we talked about earlier for example
if you're going to have an immune system
disregulation to a vaccine it often
takes a while for your immune system to
have that issue just like it takes it a
while for it to develop you know uh uh
immunity that's intended to be created
by the vaccine okay and and if you look
at vaccine Court they know that issues
from vaccines arise well after week all
the time known issues accepted issues
but yet they only reported the first
week like in this study five to 11 year
olds they say they reported that
1.2% needed medical care after dose one
and 1.1% by the way I don't know why
that's comforting that's one in 100 kids
who needed Medical Care to the shot but
but apparently they thought that was
okay here's the list of all the 40
studies each of those are hyperlink you
get these slides you can go and look at
every single one of them they're all
there here's the deal these are the two
lawsuits we had to bring to get that
check the box data and when we finally
got the data what it showed was that
7.7% of V safe users needed Medical Care
7.7% and on average two to three times
each
okay and three out of four of those
instances were Urgent Care Emergency REM
hospitalization that's what it showed
that is what the CDC no doubt no doubt
did not want to disclose from the public
in the first six weeks was 4.2% remember
these were the vaccine enthusiasts these
10 million Americans the last place
these folks I think wanted to go was to
a hospital they didn't want to leave
their home I think typically they wanted
to wear their mask stay at home they
were worried about covid to get them to
go to an urgent care emergency room or
or or hospitalized they probably had
something real serious and to and and
that they went on average two to three
times meaning there were about 700
something thousand in Unique Individuals
sought medical care but there were 2 one
or two million instances of seeking
medical care right you don't go back to
the doctor hospital two to three times
because you have something that's not
very concerning and separately another
25% who did not report needing Medical
Care reported missing school or work or
being unable to perform normally daily
activities that brings us to 32% of
folks were adversely affected remember
they said the military has to get this
so we have
Readiness covid did not affect
individuals at that rate and disable
them from school or work performing
normal daily activities let alone send
7.7% of people to the hospital okay two
to three times on average right there is
the link to um this link you can use to
go to um to do to look at this data
yourself I can has done an incredible
job of uh taking all this data and
putting it on the uh on their website um
it's right here we can just take a quick
look at it anybody in the public can do
this you can go to iand decide.org back
v-safe ddata it's taking a minute to
load because I guess I'm tethering for
my phone um but on this you can um it's
a is all of the data it's got the raw
data there too and it also has a
dashboard where you can manipulate the
data while that's loading um I'll just
tell you one or two other things about
this so after we broke this you know and
I can broke this and um I had the
opportunity to go on national news and
discuss this data actually Reuters
reached out to me and said the CDC had
contact had spoken to the CDC about it
and they said well the 7.7% is something
or other and I
said I'm going to put it in writing the
7. % 100% is accurate and here's the raw
data and the CDC had to back off in fact
I have a whole substack I wrote just
about that it was incredible because
they were hoping Reuters would just say
it's misinformation without actually
verifying it it was actually incredible
to watch it in action so here it is you
can see right here Health impacts here's
the 10 million individuals you could see
it on your screen and if we limit it
just to uh required medical care you
could see again 782,000 Unique
Individuals and 2.1 million Total Health
impacts and you can break it down by
vaccine by by anything you want okay so
I'll leave folks to go through that the
important point is um the important
point is that again that
um not necessarily even that the vaccine
caused harm but the fact that the
CDC they they did not they try to hide
it from the public um and when they
finally got caught with it and had to
admit it uh the number is uh is is
really concerning I've just told you
about Reuters There's the link to the
article where you could look at that so
just to put a fine point in this if
you're looking for the data back to your
question earlier what percentage of
Americans who got a covid vaccine ended
up in the
hospital that is the best data you're
ever gonna get on that question the best
data it's not 30,000 people like in aone
TR it's 10 million they're all filling
out a standardized form they are a
cross-section of America Americans there
folks who came went out before mandates
there folks who were Enthusiast to get
the vaccine anything anything that
number is under reported based on those
confounders and so that's really your
best indication of what impact this
vaccine has I'll point out one other
interesting data point from this data
and I actually pointed this out to
Reuters and I think the CDC didn't know
what to do with it but this is for
example when you do some data mining and
this is what the CDC should have been
doing with
vate this is the number of Adverse
Events that were
reported this is the number of excuse me
uh of of individuals three and older uh
from the first dose of the fiser vaccine
that reported needing Medical Care okay
this is not cumulative what you're
looking at on your screen okay and
anybody can go and download the vsafe
data from I website and do exactly this
between day 1 and
7.32% of those who got the fiser vaccine
reported need going to the hospital or
needing medical care or emergency orer
carel Health
32% then in the second week after the C
after the first dose
67% of vsafe users reported needing
Medical Care again not cumulative it's
not cumulative with the first week look
at what happens in the third week look
at the fourth week look at the fifth and
look at the sixth week you have an
increasing Crescendo of individuals who
reporting needing medical care after the
first dose of fizer's
vaccine reporting only the first week is
incredibly misleading but that is what
the CDC did in over 40 studies and that
data point that you're looking on your
screen that should have been terribly
concerning and
investigated but I don't think that was
the point of eafe I think the point of
vsafe was to just confirm safety
unfortunately which shouldn't be
surprising because the CDC is not a
medical organization they're they're a
policy organiz they're an agency they
have a policy they set the policy just
like any agency and then they make sure
everything conforms to that
policy okay question that's V safe um
yes please represent
Penza uh I just had a question
concerning the the vsafe um and I don't
know if you I guess when you got all the
data dump you might have it so you know
how like let's say somebody signs up for
something they might have just reported
within the first week and then they drop
off and they didn't like do you know
like how Okay so 10 million signed up
right how many really went all the way
through cuz that kind of speaks to this
as well so if 10 million signed up and
then they dropped off from Day 36 to 42
right then what that that percentage of
people that were affected by things
obviously goes a lot higher so you mean
like you mean like those who
died correct right yeah and that was one
of the uh limitations uh the CDC figured
out in there in this bsafe protocol
documents obviously yes um yes so in the
data set you can you can I mean if you
do if you crunch the numbers you can see
that obviously there was um some
trailing off but if anything that um
either those it could be because they're
not interested or because they were too
sick to report or because they passed um
but if anything that can only reduce the
percentage not increase because remember
we have a denominator the denominator
stays 10
million okay I'll give you an example we
the 7.7% figure even though we know for
example about 500 something thousand of
those folks signed up for be safe never
filled out a single survey okay they
never filled out one survey so I could
we could remove them and the 7.7 number
would go up but I don't want to include
any and and it would be valid
statistically to do that but we chose
the
most the most conservative number that
required virtually no explanation
including the one I just gave you on
taking those folks out because we knew
that that reuter CNN all of them would
attack this data attack the find even
though it's right there in black and
white in the data set you um so that it
would be super easy to explain that is
the number of unique users who were
signed up 700 something thousand divided
by the total number of users without
backing up if we did what you said if we
backed out for example the 500,000 and
then we did it yes the number would go
up um so I'm just looking at this and so
to me it's saying somewhere between 16
and
177% of the people within the first 42
days had to seek a med Medical Care is
that correct remember uh it could be the
same person okay so they they right so
it could be the same person in week one
and then week five and seven which is is
is frankly more concerning I would I
would be more fored if this was
everybody saw Medical Care one time and
that was it the fact that I there'll be
folks potentially saw it seven eight
times you know one of the folks that
we've we know of um and I don't have her
it's too bad I don't have it here um but
um uh she she gave me permission to
disclose it I wrote a substack about it
and I I put it out she shared her vsafe
entries she was a professor who went and
got the covid vaccine to teach a lesson
to her students on civic duty to go to
get a covid vaccine and after she got it
she had a Cascade of horrifying medical
conditions and her Emil her her her
submissions on vsafe are please help me
please help me she and she does that
over and over and over her six month
submission still nobody's reached out to
me nobody's contacting me help me she
can't drive she can't engage in in
normal functions I mean she was in a uh
um really she had really serious Adverse
Events so um she's an example of
somebody who saw Medical Care over and
over again and would have potentially
been in a number of
these so so I understand it could be a a
person doing it one or more times well
doesn't mean that they're reporting the
same Hospital incidents more than once
it means right right that I understand
but I guess and I know you probably
can't answer this
question and I go I I guess I'm looking
at the childhood vaccine and everything
else at what
point do we
say this is affecting public health and
if we're
in supposed to be looking out for public
health how can
we um even say that these are safe and
effective I don't know if this is the
answer you're looking for but to me with
this SC
screams is is exactly why civil
liberties individual rights should never
be contingent on the opinions policies
deductions pronouncements of any public
health
authority ever they should persuade on
the merits and if they can't that should
be the end of discussion that's the idea
of informed
consent represent Penza thank you madam
chair
um now of of course most of this was
anecdotal but it um you know being very
involved when kind of the whole Co thing
was going on and the vaccine rollouts
there was so many people that um that I
talked to that missed work and I'm
talking about people in the medical
profession as well as um folks that were
you know being pressured into it whether
it be from family members and just in
your time in research um you know the
whole point was to get back right and
and I think that that was so striking to
me and I and they asked that question so
um I just thought that that was you know
I can go on there and pull like specific
data about like people how they missed
work there were some friends of ours um
that were very sick
like people that had had covid and still
ended up getting uh an injection and
they missed work for a long time some
probably that have not gone back so you
know just in your research did you see
that as well oh yeah again the vsafe
data is going to be your the absolute
best data to show what that number is
25 putting aside remember had those
three categories where you could check
right I'm going to go back to it so you
could check you're unable to work or or
School unable to do your normal
activities or use saw Medical
Care 25% of
people who there were 25% of the vsafe
participants checked being unable to
work or perform normal activities who
didn't check needing medical care so
that's
25% add in obviously if you need medical
care you're also not able to do that add
in the 7.7
32% of individuals were needed medical
care or unable to for normal activities
or M school or work 32% that is what the
vsafe data shows and and again you know
uh nobody needs to take my word for it
it's all right there on that web page
all the raw data as well as this uh
incredible uh dashboard where you can
run it 32% school work unable to per
Noble activities so yeah that's going to
be your best indication and yes you're
exactly right the idea was you know to
get everybody back to work or to slow
the spread or U but this product had um
a lot of what they would call
reactogenicity and potential issues of
course part of the thing that the the
the federal authorities would do is they
they would often look at a lot of things
if I can use that term with regards to
covid vaccine only after the second two
weeks after the second dose so all that
stuff again if I can use that term
between the first dose the second dose
and two weeks after the second dose just
kind of fell into this like nether
Netherland you could see it in the vsafe
data very clearly that they did not want
the public to see and fought vigorously
to to hide
representative
beler thank you madam chair this is uh
this has been some difficult testimony
learning about all of this I didn't even
really know anything about vsafe until
today um as some of the people here have
known as I've as I've divulged at least
in part before I received a single dose
of fiser in April of 21 within about 48
hours I was unwell enough to seek Urgent
Care within a week I'd followed up with
my primary Within another week after
that roughly neurology it took almost
four weeks before I was finally
hospitalized um so obviously I
have that experience that you're seeing
right here on this
slide but my question is actually I'm
not even sure you have this information
but it would be interesting to
know do we have any
indication on what date did the federal
government through CDC FDA or anyone
else know that the data exceeded a
safety signal for the very first time
for
anything I don't know the precise date
but I would suspect it was very early
for
prr I mean that that's given the pace
and the number of errs reports that
signal I I wouldn't be surprised if they
knew it within weeks of the roll out uh
in terms of vsafe again I don't think it
your 10 million us you had it
uh by you know let's just call two to
three months there's it's hard for me to
imagine they didn't have this data in
hand and
analyzed um I'd like to just follow up
on something we had T touched on earlier
based on what represent belter just
spoke
about when we're talking about this data
and when did they know it would seem to
me that they know knew pretty early on
based on their November 2020 list of
things that they omitted from the vsafe
form of potential side effects um that
these could be possible
issues um or there would have been no
reason to remove them um I'm just
speculating here but uh what are your
thoughts yeah the the whole reason that
this list exists is because the I mean
that's the title Adverse Events of
special interest pre-specified medical
you know precepts and medical conditions
I mean this is their list this is this
is the cdc's OWN protocol for Designing
vsafe I mean I I don't know if it could
get any clearer in terms of then
identifying what the covid vaccine could
what harms it could cause it's right
there on this list in their own uh
design document for V safe um you know
and and and it follows on to this
October list that they had and there are
other you know I mean I un there I mean
maybe you guys want me here for days I
don't know but there there there are
there are numerous there are numerous
studies that preceded this presentation
and that support why the CDC listed
these that you can look at um you know
they were well there it is right in
front of you clearly aware these were
conditions of special interest that the
vaccines could cause
but yet you know the only place in vsafe
that you could record those specific
harms was in a free Tex field that they
limited 250 characters and they fought
like heck to not redisclose that and I
can tell you that we actually just
prevailed in a
lawsuit uh two two three months ago we
finally got a judge I mean separate
lawsuit than the check the box data they
really fought for the free Tex field
data and uh federal judges ordered them
to produce it all 6 something million
free text entries over the course of 12
months we've gotten the first two to
three we got the first essentially um
they've done the first two that when
we've taken a look at those tranches
about 300 something thousand entries
it's an increasing number we'll have all
around 7 million entries by the end of
like about another 10 months from now
and um there's a reason that the CDC
really really didn't want the public to
see that for example what I told you
earlier that Professor who's saying Help
Me Help Me disclosing a crescendo of of
of really really concerning issues and
also they they they tell real stories of
real people with real harm who all went
out and thought they were engaging in
their civic duty by going to get this
product and then when they went back to
the same Health authorities who told
them it's safe and effective you should
go do this pleading begging for help
disclosing these harms they were just
ignored represent P
off thank you Madame chair so so so you
testified that some some of those
symptoms are blamed on normal uh immune
response expected and desired
reactogenicity so what is the expected
uh period uh for normal
reactogenicity uh I I would think it was
supposed to be limited to just a few
couple
day couple first days or is it is it
normal is it expected for it to last
weeks no it's supposed to It's supposed
to completely resolved within the first
week and they're supposed to generally
be mild you know obviously it's going to
hurt for most folks when they get a
needle put in the arm there's going to
be some swelling in the arm for many for
a large percentage of folks those are
the type of things that they they um
they expect and and they expect them to
subside uh they don't expect things to
continue after the first week
but they didn't track any symptoms after
the first week did
they so
Penza so I have two questions thank you
madam chair I have two questions um one
was the
um and you answered it which was the the
free form and what did you say was the
character limit U well it was generally
250 character character limit for
individuals and there were a number of
spots you could put in information what
we have seen is that some folks they'll
just use any of the free forms to try
and put in and tell their story to the
to the health authorities they a lot of
these folks didn't know where to go or
what to do you know they go to their
doctor they say I got an injury from a
covid vaccine and as you know the
typical Medical Professional does they
say no no can't be you know vaccines are
safe and effective so then they're left
you know looking for help they so they
often will turn back to the very health
authori who told them to get it they
were signed up a vsafe they try to
report it to there
okay so my other question was if let's
say I was a vsafe user and I I I did the
um the um the app or the program
throughout can I go back in and see what
I
submitted um good question I uh I'm not
certain I'm not certain but uh we if
it's but um if you know your your user
ID you can go to Ian site and you can
actually pull up your report and see all
the check the box data you submitted and
by the end of about a year from now
you'll be able to also go in and see all
the free text forms that you
submitted follow up yeah because I'm
just thinking right when you're in the
middle of something these people were
gung-ho they wanted to do the right
thing and and then stuff is not
happening you're not going to think to
screen capture or whatever and right and
you wouldn't if you're not able to go
back in to see that would be um yeah you
know what and I think about it though
the professor who sent me hers I you
know what it's a good question I'm not
sure I could get back to you on that for
sure yeah that would be great thank you
okay okay so uh there there we've got
the two premere of Safety Systems and
what it is we've uncovered regarding
them and you know and if you look at
other
vaccines I don't think it should be
surprising frankly about how they've
dealt with postlicensure safety review
of these products um uh in many ways you
know um religion comes in all forms and
there I really do have religious beliefs
with regards to these products I find um
a lot of the folks who engage in
promoting them on the federal level in
particular um this is just one group
called react 19 um uh started by Brian
Dron who was injured as a uh participant
in the astrogenic clinical trial as well
as Joe wasog who was an orthopedic
surgeon who got the madna vaccine and
could no longer
um performed surgeries because of his
injury from U the madna covid vaccine
that group that one group in America
says that it has over 36,000 Americans
who are seriously injured from covid-19
vaccine they're an amazing organization
they they're focuses to help people
injured with covid-19 vaccines and I
know that they have regular calls and
try been trying to interact with the
federal health agencies and trying to
get help um you know um so I I use that
as an example of again just one group
that is out there and to show this the
scope of the of the potential issues our
firm as well um you know we've get we
can't we don't bring claims for covid-19
vaccine injuries because there's not
really any place to file a claim that's
worthwhile but we get calls all day long
um email submissions and forms from
folks injured by covid-19 vaccines and
then I can as well um gets you know
folks injured with Co Conta them all day
long I mean we're just um you know three
three group one you know two nonprofits
and one law firm and between us the
number of seriously injured individual
covid-19 vaccine is
uh you know equates to a uh um a cade of
pain and suffering crossing the entire
country that brings us then to uh the
issue of transmission and obviously the
whole reason that the
um um they said you you know the the
underpinning argument for why they had
to mandate covid vaccines was to stop
transmission that's typically the
argument for why they have to require
any
vaccine and so um you know um because if
you think about it you know heart
medicine for examples Hardy is number
one killer of Americans every year
700,000 folks does that mean we mandate
Statin does that mean we mandate
exercise you know you name it no because
we all intuitively get it that that
would just be
incredibly destructive to individual and
civil rights like we have intuitive
understanding but the moment for some
reason you slap the word vaccine on
something it's like oh yeah well you
could throw all of your rights away now
I don't you know there's a and that's an
ethos that has developed over time in
part from what I discussed earlier
Decades of Pharma having its way with no
opposition with regards to these
products um what's incredible to me
frankly is that Regulators acted
surprised that covid-19 vaccines do not
stop transmission and we'll go through
that in a minute and the question is
should they have been should they have
been right I I I want to be clear that
even if covid vaccines stopped
transmission I want to be very
clear I don't take an ideological
position about these products in terms
of you want to get them get them don't
get them don't get them they're product
but they should never be mandated even
if they stop transmission that said
these products don't and what's really
interesting to me was that somehow the
CDC director and all these folks seem
surprised when that information came out
and so should they have been do all
other vaccin stop transmission what is
it that they should have already been
aware of with regards to other vaccines
and I think again we'll take a quick
look at other vaccines as a backdrop on
that question um so this is the uh this
is the New Hampshire uh School vaccine
requirements these are the vaccines
required for school in New Hampshire
it's basically you have five vaccines
here that required dap teap polio hey
MMR and chickenpox okay so I'll use
those as the the Baseline if if I may
let's start with polio okay now oral
polio vaccine they used to be given can
stop transmission to a degree because
polio proliferates in the intestinal
Linings it's fecal to oral contamination
that's how it's transmitted okay if a
vaccine only creates immunity in the
blood IGG antibodies and creates no
immunity in your intestinal aligning IGA
antibodies not going to stop
transmission
in America the exclusive vaccine for the
last 24 years given to Children is
inactivated polio vaccine it's injected
does not create immunity in intestinal
Linings does
not stop transmission that might sound
incredible but I'm not going to say it
let's see the CDC say it right here on
your screen with the link to the CDC web
page it says ipv protects people against
all three types of polio virus ipv does
not contain L virus can cannot cause
disease it protects people from disease
but does not stop transmission of the
virus if you have only been injected
with activated polio vaccine it is at
best personal protection that's all it's
like asthma inhaler maybe we want you to
do it but should we crush your rights if
you won't do
it
so and there it is right on the CDC
website that's because it only creates
immunity in the blood it maybe will stop
the polio virus from going from your
intestines into blood and then for
getting to your spinal column and
causing my litis you know uh damage to
your spinal column potentially can I can
I just ask I just want to make sure I
understand this so if you get the
polio if you infected with polio virus
right if you're infected with the polio
virus and you've had the um inactivated
polio vaccine thank you you necessarily
won't get the U polio but you can
actually transmit to that to somebody
who hasn't has been vaccinated is 100%
it does nothing to prevent transmission
it's right there on the CDC website does
not stop transmission of the virus which
is why The Who and CDC guidelines that
if polio virus were to return everybody
needs to get opv vaccine everybody in
America today who's 24 and younger or
longer than that because you're giving
it older um has never received a vaccine
for Polar that prevents transmission
that's Decades of kids in this country
with no uh they may be reduce symtoms
Now understand 95% of people who are
infected with polio virus are
asymptomatic they never show any
symptoms whatsoever CDC another 4% of
POS posy symptomatic a little bit of
symptoms 1% might have symptoms that are
actually of concern and TIY percent are
even more you know can end up with an
issue with that said uh yes for you know
the the vaccine is potentially can
reduce the the the symptoms the disease
as as as you would call it but it
doesn't stop transmission I'm not making
any charact I'm judging on get the
product don't get the product but the
point is one of civil liberties about
individual rights should you crush
people's rights for refusing a product
that doesn't prevent transmission and
obviously the the reality is and then
separately should Michelle wilinsky the
CDC director been on CNN going oh nobody
told me it couldn't stop transmission
maybe right should she been doing that
or should she have maybe known wait a
second we got a lot of vaccines that
don't stop transmission including ones
we you know um so here is uh the global
eradication initiative wh CDC and they
explain it in their own words again
there's the link down there ipv induces
very low levels of immunity in the
intestine as a result when a person
immunized with ipv is infected with wild
po virus the virus can still multiply
inside the intestines and be shed in the
feces risking continuous ulation ipv
does not trans stop transmission of the
virus the reason we don't use opv
anymore in this country is because it
can cause paralysis actually the the the
attenuated version so okay let's move on
to to the next vaccine um on the
schedule is diptheria vaccine now
diptheria is a
bacteria the bacteria itself doesn't
harm you sometimes the bacteria can
release a toxin that can harm you the
vaccine just creates immunity to that
toxin there is nothing in the vial of a
deia vaccine that creates immunity to
the deia
bacteria nothing it's a toxoid vaccine
it only creat immunity to a toxin
sometimes released by the Der bacteria
okay so here's a CDC study explaining
dether toxoid helps prevent symptomatic
disease but does not prevent the carrier
State nor stop the spread of infection
the bacteria will still multiply and
proliferate in your body the known
importance of carriers in the spread of
deia and the demonstrated failure of
toxo to prevent the carrier State lead
us conclude that the concept of her
immunity is not applicable to the
prevention of deia here's tetanus
tetanus is just like deia vaccine it is
a toxoid vaccine it will only create
immunity to a a a toxin sometimes
released by that bacteria okay um
interestingly it has to be lifel lied
meaning it has to actually the bacteria
be infected by a virus to then release a
toxin it's different story separately
tetanus is not transmissible from person
to person Anyway by the way so it
doesn't even matter so the vaccine
doesn't create any immunity to the
bacteria and the bacteria can't go from
person to person in any event so it
doesn't matter so we've now done polio
deia tetanus now we're going to do tus
okay here's prus vaccine I think prosus
vaccine is the most instructive one
frankly because it's kind of similar
like covid in the follow vaccine in the
following
way um prusis vaccine can reduce
symptoms for sure just like covid
vaccine can reduce symptoms to for a
period of time just like tetanus V they
all can they reduce symptoms for some
duration I mean tetanus and deia Wayan
so rapidly you have to get six shots as
a kid and then one every 10 years for
the rest of your life that's how quickly
that immunity wains so again I don't
know why relle willinsky and were
surprised when covid vaccine immunity
weigh but that's a separate story before
prusis vaccine was introduced in the
United States all the studies reflected
that they thought prusis immunity was
lifelong once you had protestas once
that's because you were naturally
continued to be infected afterwards the
thing is is that when they started
vaccinating people with protus they
realized something really strange the
level of U circulating protus bacteria
did not go down they didn't know why
well FDA did a study and in this study
they started with baboons because they
couldn't purposely infect humans and if
you look at this chart on the right this
is an FDA study they found that naive
which means that's the Blue Line those
are the baboons that never had
prosus they would stick a swab up their
nose and they would culture the uh uh uh
to see if they can culture prusas they
were culturing pusas from their naso
fairings for about 30 days okay AP
that's a cellular prosus that's the only
protus vacine used in the United States
since 2000 remember the dtp one that
kills more kids than it saves that they
don't use that here they were culturing
prusas from the nose of the baboons for
almost 35 days they were more infectious
for a longer period of time because a
cellular protestos vaccine actually will
reduce symptoms but it does not prevent
the protestas bacteria from being able
to proliferate in multip
in your n of fairings and for you to
spread it the FDA was shocked by this
finding and what's the most amazing part
is that for decades they claimed
otherwise that was followed on by an
entire International Convention of all
the world leading
vaccinologists protus experts and here's
their conclusion in in you know P study
they say a cell protest vaccine cannot
avoid infection transmission it
protestas vaccines do not prevent
colonization consequently do not reduce
the circulation of board to tasus and
did not exert any her immunity effect if
you take issue with that talk to them
not me that's that is what the data show
yes um
so I don't know maybe I'm I'm just naive
yes but if
it doesn't reduce the circulation yes
and it doesn't exert any hert immunity
what is the point of it it reduces
symptoms it reduces symptoms for a for a
for a limited duration of time so um um
like I said after uh you get it a 2
months 4 months 6 months 18 months 4
years and then you get one at 11 years
of age that's six Doses and within two
years of that um your antibody levels
are basically down to like 10 basically
only 10% of people are still considered
protected from symptoms but protestos is
really only of concern to little babies
protestas is not really of an issue for
adults I mean you can get protestas you
might have a bit of a cough or whatever
but it's really only dangerous for for
little babies and there's a whole
discussion around that but um yeah I
mean it's a great question they tell you
to get protus vaccine to protect for
example they'll tell you oh get it
before you see a baby but actually if
you get it you're more likely to
transmit to the baby because you have
less likely to have symptoms but still
as likely to transmit it they did all
these studies what they called cocooning
where they were like okay let's give
protest vaccine to every the grandma the
mom the cousin everybody around the baby
and did that have any effect on protus
in the in the babies and they found no
cocooning doesn't work act anything
cocooning made it more likely you give
it to the baby
because it reduces symptoms
wonderful but then you don't know you
have it you're not staying home you're
not stopping holding the baby because
you don't know you you're infected in
your transmitting it in your naso
fairings anyway represent Potenza oh
please thank you madam shair I was just
you kind of just answered that I was
just going to say wouldn't that be more
likely that the baby would be infected
then yes it would yes um um so you know
we actually we we Foy the CDC again
asking them come on do you have any
documents show it doesn't prevent
transmission and they sent us the two
studies I just showed you guys we also
this was my favorite one we petitioned
formerly the CD the FDA to change the
labeling on the pusis uh products to add
the warning that you could be more
likely to transmit it doesn't prevent
transmission and they wrote us back and
you right there's the link you can read
this fda's response and they said oh we
don't need to change the landing there's
no confusion in the marketplace
everybody knows it doesn't stop
transmission read it yourself it's it's
it's incredible actually okay uh just
like what we said reducing symptoms
while remaining able to transmit makes
one more likely to transmit and uh you
know in this article it explains that
you know the way that you know how much
circulating bacteria there is is you
look at the inter epidemic intervals
okay the interepidemic intervals meaning
how many cohorts you have that are not
uh uh
U folks who've never had it basically
has either stayed the same or has gotten
shorter now there are less cases of
disease because the vaccine can reduce
symptoms but there's actually apparently
more circulating protestos bacteria out
there and um the problem is that is that
the the the pertusus bacteria has five
about
3,000 antigens on a Surface the bacteria
the vaccine has only about five of those
antigens in the vial okay so it creates
this defective form of immunity called
linked EPO you know linked epitope
suppression so the next time you're
infected with pertusus your body has a
robust immune response to those five
epitopes but not to the other 2,995
approximately so your defective immunity
results in you actually being able to
become infected over and over and over
and over and studies like this one have
discussed this issue and in fact one of
the premier vaccinologists on this issue
according to the medical community at
UCLA has proposed that the only solution
I think apparently is to make a vaccine
that vaccinates you for the other
2995 you don't have to fix your immunity
that they've created which renders you
susceptible if you've got protestas if
you actually had pressus once now you
have immunity and you do not transmit it
and we saw that in the baboon study done
one and done except you know the studies
show that you know like vaccine immunity
natural immun apparently it at least
some of the studies reflect it too can
Wayne but if you're continue to Expos to
it then it stays um robust now do we
exclude those vaccinated for protesters
from the work school military after all
aren't they more likely to spread it
I mean the kid with symptoms knows to
stay home from school the kid without
symptoms doesn't does that mean we
exclude vaccinated children from school
who have protestas because they're more
like to spread it of course not of
course we don't because we shouldn't
exclude
anybody from making a personal medical
decision
okay uh those give us so you know we did
polio we did daap taap um
those are just some there are other
examples we could look at at ninako
vaccine and other ones but let's just
stop there the point is that they really
shouldn't have been surprised that covid
vaccine couldn't stop transmission
because that's true of many vaccines now
measles vaccine can stop transmission
Chickenpox vaccine can stop transmission
but these most other vaccines most of
the vaccines required for school in New
Hampshire for example do not stop
transmission as we noted earlier they
could have easily tested in the clinical
trial whether or not covid vaccine
stopped transmission they just had to
basically test everybody every week in
the trial test just 30 40,000 people
they were testing millions of Americans
every week every five days every three
seconds but yet they couldn't do it in
the trial come
on I think they knew there would be a
problem most likely um here is the FDA
itself saying the fda's authorization
and Licensing standards for vaccines do
not require demonstration the prevention
infection transmission this is what they
told us when we want to add indications
and the labels showing that various
vaccines don't stop transmission they
said well we don't license on that basis
and in fact vaccines are not licensed on
the basis that they sto transmission
they're just licensed on the basis of
reducing uh symptoms for some period of
time and so they knew they did not have
the support to say that covid vaccines
did not stop transmission but that
didn't stop them from saying it did they
because as I said earlier there's
religious beliefs around these products
despite the evidence despite what they
even say themselves they will often
argue well we have to stop the spread we
got to stop we got we got to kick kids
out we got to do all these things we got
to you know fire everybody from work who
don't get a covid vaccine it's not
really about it's about an ideology to
some degree okay here's relle wilinsky
August 5th 2021 and she gets on CNN and
she says quote our vaccines are working
exceptionally well they continue to work
well for Delta with regard to severe
disease illness and death put that
portion aside they prevent it but what
they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission oh she was apparently
surprised why did she say that she said
that because this is a study from the
CDC the next day ma they published this
in which they went out and they
carefully studied this outbreak of covid
and what they found was in a place that
had a 69% covid vaccine coverage 74% of
people who were infected
did had covid vaccine so it was
disproportionately within the vaccinated
and then they did the swabs like they
did with the baboons and they found that
the vaccinated had on average more virus
in their nasal cavities than the
unvaccinated that were infected that's
the cdc's own publication amazing they
actually published this and then here's
another study just August 24th 2021 not
long afterwards they reviewed swab
specimens from 24 counties and they
found a high viral Lo in 158 meaning of
232 unvaccinated 68% of the unvaccinated
had a high viral load in their nose but
69% of the vaccinated had a high viral
load in their naso fairings and they
similarly there was a high viral load is
7 of 24 unvaccinated 29 and uh
um U uh 11 of the fully vaccinated
asymptomatic individuals so the the the
the the first black bullet point is for
symptomatic individuals the second one
was for asymptomatic and frankly it's
the second bullet point that should be
the most concerning among the
asymptomatic they had no symptoms so
vaccine was doing great it was reducing
symptoms but 82% nine of 11 nine had a
high viral load unknowingly spreading
covid in the vaccinated whereas only
seven of the unv 29% amongst the
unvaccinated had that asymptomatic
spread I this study was was I think just
a watershed and in fact it's a great
study because we foiled for all the
inter there was a CDC uh author we said
we foed for all the internal
Communications the internal
Communications on this study are
incredible journals did didn't want to
publish it like they went round and
round and because you know they were
like why would publish this is an
important finding um because it didn't
it didn't fit the policy but they knew
they knew before they went out and they
went and crushed the rights of 100
million Americans with you know with the
o with the social requirements kicking
people out of the military going down
that road they knew this product did not
stop transmission there was no Public
Health imperative to do it yes I'm sorry
represent
blus I recall very early on
um fouchi saying no you have to still
wear masks because the vaccine won't
stop transmission yes do you recall when
that was compared to all of this
I think it was when Melle wilinsky said
this in August I presume because that's
when the CDC she said oh you can all
take your masks off we're all free and
then go she went then they they had this
study in in uh in Massachusetts and then
they all went and they went did a 180 on
that so I think it was very early and
actually I have a a little video I
happened to just find it on on online
last night on Twitter it came my feed
and I I put it in here um and I think
that's where I don't know if it has a
date we'll see in a second where fouchi
says that this by the way those are just
two early Canary and the comont studies
there were large giant studies that
followed all showing the same thing we
had huge exchange with CDC on this point
um it was clear as day this product
would not stop infection um and and what
also made it super clear was just look
at the rates of infections in highly
vaccinated developing countries in other
highly vaccinated countries versus the
rate of infection in countries that did
not participate in these products it's
incredible okay so again representative
beler
please thank you madam chair and I've
got a I've got a couple questions that I
think will help with our investigation
I'll of course ask you between to make
sure I'm good to continue um but the
first
one it was a position of the government
and pharmaceutical companies that the E
UA vaccines prevented Contracting the
SARS Co 2 virus it was the their
position that the eua vaccines
preventing transmission of the SAR Co 2
virus it was the position of them that
they were safe and effective it is still
the position of the government and
pharmaceutical industry that these
products reduce
mortality and that they are safe and
effective my question then is given the
totality of all the circumstances that
you were aware of and have evidence for
do you believe there is a reasonable
possibility that the legal immunity of
either the government Andor the
pharmaceutical companies should not
stand
due to fraud censorship disinformation
on efficacy or risks or any other
reason politically absolutely it should
not stand it shouldn't have been there
to begin with because it just creates an
incredible moral hazard hey you know
what let's go into business and we're
going to create a product and um the
government's going to mandate it really
what is the product Oh you you inject it
oh what if it causes harm don't worry
you'll have immunity oh who the heck
would take that don't worry they'll
mandate it well what if people cry out
don't worry they'll censor and they'll
promote it with billions of dollars yeah
absolutely that is essentially what we
entered into politically speaking it
should never have been there even absent
fraud if you're asking me um with what
we know
now it absolutely should all be
rescinded to the extent the government
can they contractually agree to the
immunity um and uh
um and and and these products should
just be treated like any others I
mean you could sue people you could sue
the maker of this pen for issues but I
can't sue companies that inject a
product into babies over and over and
over again what they swear to you are
safe and effective really how does that
make any sense they're so safe that they
had to take away the ability to sue them
for harm
I I mean if that doesn't create like
cognitive dissonance I don't know what
does it's like you know your head's got
to spin from it so yes politically
absolutely legally that's a more
complicated question whether that is it
would need to most likely happen in from
an act of federal
legislation but there are things I think
on the state level um that can be done
and I'm happy to talk about those
afterwards thank you and if I may
up um so oh please oh I'm so sorry
that's all right so uh the next related
question is um the state of New
Hampshire has a little bit of ambiguity
with our current covid childhood
recommendations for
injection currently we hear there is no
official recommendation that is the
position taken by the Department of
Health and Human Services however the
official website has a section on child
Hood Co vaccination that directs the
user to the CDC guidelines they do so
without explicitly stating those are CDC
and not New Hampshire
guidelines and they do officially the
CDC guidelines that it directs you to
take a recommendation on childhood
vaccination So based on your legal
expertise would you agree that DHHS in
New Hampshire by linking directly to the
CDC website which recommends vaccinees
under the New Hampshire website where it
talks about childhood vaccination for Co
would you agree that they're taking no
position or do you believe that they are
taking a position based on what you just
said uh they are in my opinion based on
what you just said taking a position
that would promote the covid-19 vaccine
because that's apparently if a parent
goes to their site and it leads them to
the cdc's recommendation I you know most
folks would assume that is the new sure
uh Department of Health and Human
Services position with regards to that
product I I don't see how it could be
otherwise thank you and if I may I yes
thank you um we've learned from previous
testimony and I'm I'm going ask if
you're familiar with this and if you
have anything to add to it um let me
preface it with this back when I was a
paramedic years and years ago I was
trained to administer intermuscular
injections and part of that training
process was to locate the injection cell
site spread the Skin Out plunge the
needle syringe aspirate to make sure I
wasn't in a blood vessel before
administering the shot now this
information changed at some point point
shortly before the covid
pandemic and to my knowledge the
covid-19 vaccine was the first that was
if issued Official Guidelines to not
aspirate before plunging the needle the
syringe to administer to shot um looking
at the recommendations from the
guidelines on this I believe it was a
CDC website can correct me if I'm wrong
um the rationale given for suspending
the long process of aspirating to make
sure you weren't in a blood vessel was
done based on no evidence but the
argument that there had been no previous
data suggesting that you needed to and
further that it may cause may not
evidence may cause additional pain that
could put people off from vaccinations
so you should not do this practice is
that something you're aware of or having
comment on I'm not aware of that
actually that's interesting but it does
fit with the the normal rubric um when
it comes to these products in terms of
how safety is approached which is in the
absence of evidence that it causes harm
you say it
doesn't and if I may one last
uh and you may be coming to talk about
this I don't know um but I want to ask
you is this something you're aware of
because I've heard this I don't think
we've received testimony I may be wrong
again on that but I believe that when
these covid vaccines became officially
licensed as an approved by the
FDA uh the manufacturers continued to
provide only the emergency use versions
of them up until the
point that they were adopted by the
childhood vaccine schedule which
conferred a different uh legal immunity
to them so there was no period in which
um the FDA version was given where they
could have might not had immunity is
that something you're aware of yeah the
the the pre yeah there I think there's a
bit of confusion out there in terms of
the the applicable legal
protections the prep act
immunity applies whether the product is
emergency use authorized or
licensed so it didn't
matter whether uh it was on the
childhood schedule or not and whether
the 86 act applied or not as it stands
right now you can't go into vaccine
court for a covid vaccine injury you
can't go into the vicp the program
created by the ad6 ACT you need to to go
into the program created by the prep act
the cicp so the prep act imunity
applies whether it's authorized or
whether it's licensed in terms of uh
after it was licensed what was available
I can tell you that one of the
regulations that's Crystal Clear is that
the military is not allowed to mandate
an a product on its soldiers that that
are not licensed and so um there were
lawsuits that were brought after the
covid-19 vaccine was authorized because
there still wasn't actually vials that
were authorized vials there were still
there were still emergency use Excuse me
licensed vials there were still only eua
vials in circulation there was so much
of it that's pretty much what was
available and when uh the military was
sued by a soldier saying hey you offered
me an eua product the government
responded by saying either one you were
offered a buy equivalent there was a
list uh that when the covid vaccine was
licensed the FDA put out and said these
batches of eua not all of them just
these are the same as the licensed and
can be treated as
licensed and where the soldier was
offered something not in that list the
military somehow
magically uh produced an actual
licensed vial um there were some that
they had available and they would then
offer that to the soldier and we
encountered exactly that scenario so uh
yeah for the most part uh for a long
time there was only you know actually
don't know the State of Affairs right
now because um I know for a long time
there was no eua only eua product
available in the United States um yeah
thank you for clarifying that okay
um so
um uh so you know reducing symptoms
while remaining able to transmit makes
one more likely to transmit we've
covered that and that was true of covid
vaccines should states have crushed the
rights of those that refuse this medical
procedure I think that's
self-explanatory should never do that um
as I pointed out earlier they could have
easily tested for whether prevent
transmission they didn't do it um and um
uh um you know I think that uh this is
the video I told you I had found and I
included it though I I should disclaim I
didn't put this together I just found
this but it looks authentic to me so I
I'll play
it okay you're not gonna you're not
going to get Co if you have these
vaccinations these vaccines are highly
highly effective vaccinated people do
not carry the virus don't get sick
they're really really good against
variants everyone who takes the vaccine
is not just protecting themselves but
reducing their transmission uh to other
people and allowing Society to get back
to normal get your first sh shot and
when you're due for your second you get
your second shot a key goal is to stop
the transmission to get the immunity
levels up so that you get almost no
almost no uh infection going on
whatsoever when people are vaccinated
they can feel safe that they are not
going to get infected if you're
vaccinated you're not going to be
hospitalized you're not going to be an
IU unit and you're not going to die if
you are fully vaccinated you no longer
need to wear a mask anyone who is fully
vaccinated can participate in indoor and
outdoor activities large or small
without wearing a mask or physical
distancing but what they can't do
anymore is prevent transmission we
didn't have vaccines that BL
transmission we got
vaccines but they only
slightly we need a new way of the
vaccine the level of virus in the n Bar
of a person who's vaccinated and
infected is the same level
at the
level sorry for the M dramatic music I
like I said um but I think that that
says it well and that fact you saw relle
winsky in the middle there say what we
had showed earlier um you know she said
well what we know they can't stop
transmission and and there it is foui
confirming what we saw in the study same
amount of of a a virus in the naso
fairings so what's incredible to me if
there's a lesson to be we learn from
from this is that these all these claims
about uh you know uh Public Health we
have to do it to uh protect the public
transmission they should have known
early on it was unlikely to there was
there's never been a respiratory virus I
can think of that prevented transmission
think about flu shot think about
pertusus vaccine respiratory
infections if you you know typically
they do not stop
transmission and then um they could have
done a trial that would have shown it
stop transmission they didn't all the
studies early on showed it didn't all
the big studies showed it didn't stop
transmission but yet with all that data
in hand and even with them admitting it
they went ahead with on the federal
level the OSHA mandates the military
mandates in the face of all of that it
just shows you that um um you know
uh we can't con make civil rights
individual rights the ability to
participate in Civil Society contingent
on what public health authorities say um
that leads me to um a final few slides
and uh you know the other argument and
I'm going to go real quick because I it
it's a little bit later I think um but
um the other argument that they made
about covid-19 vaccine that if you don't
get everybody will die right um we saw
what the clinical trial data showed
regarding deaths already and we've
looked at the alla's mortality so you
know that already undercuts that entire
argument but I I think it's also
instructive to look at again some of the
other vaccines on this point because
they make the same Claim about other
vaccines for example you know they say
everybody's got to get a HPB vaccine to
go to school well we foed the CDC
because we said hey hey can you can you
give us one one documented case of
hepatitis B being transmitted in a
school setting you know Hepatitis B is
typically transmitted by uh uh
promiscuous sex workers and uh
intravenous drug addicts who Ed
needles not the kind of thing I'm I
assume I don't know what goes on in New
Hampshire schools but I'm assuming
that's not common and so we ask them for
documents sufficient to reflect any any
cases of transmission of in any in
elementary middle or High School setting
you know what the CDC told us a search
of our records failed to reveal any
documents pertaining to your request but
that doesn't stop them from the
hysterics of what that everybody must
get a hee vaccine to go to school or how
about chickenpox virus
here's what the package insert says for
Chickenpox virus it says that the
transmission of vericella vaccine virus
meaning the vaccine strain in the vial
resulting in vericella infection
including disseminated disease may occur
meaning after you get the vaccine the
vaccine virus that you've just gotten in
your arm
okay uh between it can be transmitted
between vaccine recipients who develop
or do not develop a veracel like rash
meaning symptomatic ially or
asymptomatically and contact susceptible
to vericella including healthy as well
as high-risk individuals due to the
concern for transmission of vaccine
virus vaccine recipient should attempt
to avoid whenever possible close
association with susceptible high-risk
individuals for up to six weeks
following vaccination with verax now
Chickenpox vaccine is one of the few
vaccines that actually can stop
transmission to be sure it's not endemic
anymore the chickenpox virus has receded
from uh from society now a lot of people
can argue whether that's a good or bad
thing and I'll show you some studies
that show maybe that wasn't a good thing
there might have been a an evolutionary
biological reason why we had chickenpox
but the important thing here is that
people who get the chickenpox vaccine
can can actually give it to high
susceptible individuals according to the
package insert but yet do we exclude
children from
school after for so six weeks after the
get chicken boox vaccine of course not
we don't do that you know why we don't
do that because any child
who could really be injured by
chickenpox or measles or mums orella or
whatever they're not in
school if they're really that auto
really that immuno compromised there's
over 1,400 other recognized human
pathogens that means they you know the
fact that they if they can be hangered
by chickenpox they can be injured by any
one of those um yes may um talking about
the chickenpox vaccine so wouldn't you
think that a school teacher who may be
pregnant would be very concerned about
the children as they may have just been
vaccinated with the chickenpox vaccine I
don't I think typically no because in
the prevaccine era everybody would had
chickenpox by the time they're they're
pregnant so they would have robust
complete immunity and and um and today
they have to rely on either having had
chickenpox um or having had the
chickenpox
vaccine I guess my question is is that
if they're shedding the virus it could
affect the not if they're immune already
okay thank you yeah if they're immune
then they shouldn't which is yeah which
typically not a concern in fact all
pregnant women are typically tested for
immunity to those various so if they're
not immune they would they should they
would typically know it
um uh U that brings us to uh really the
we've covered out every vaccine required
in uh New Hampshire we did we did polio
we did dap we did heppy and we did
chickenpox that leaves us with just MMR
and I'm sure you've heard this
everyone's going to die without MMR
vaccine well let's take a look at the
veracity of that
claim um uh and see and I think it's
instructive to how covid vaccines were
treated based on the CDC
data the First Co the first Chickenpox
vaccine excuse me measles vaccine was in
1963 and only around one in 500,000
Americans died of measles when there was
no vaccine 400 Americans on average a
year died and the death rate between
1900 and 1962 had declined by 98%
without any vaccine you know how I know
that there was no vaccine so it couldn't
have done that reduction um then you've
got Ms and you rebella so you got a
grand total and to be sure every death
is a tragedy
absolutely but 440 deaths total for
measles mums and rebella in the years
before there was a year before there was
a vaccine back when they were still
doing labotomy okay back when Medical
Care was still in its infancy acute care
was still being developed I mean I mean
it's amazing because uh you know modern
medicine it takes a lot of pride in the
advances they've had since the 60s when
it comes to vaccines they don't seem to
want to recognize that not sure why um
many of these folks probably would would
be fine today if they had these
conditions with that said it's far from
the idea of everybody would die right
they said hundreds of thousands died
from covid 440 died they say a year 440
according CC dad had about a year again
not to minimize any deaths but to put
I'm just trying to put it in context
because that's not what they tell you
that is not the impression they leave
you with they don't leave the public
with the Imp impression that only 400
people here died of measles before there
was a measles vaccine they leave you
with the impression that Millions would
die from measles and to be sure in thir
World count developing countries where
there's poor nutrition there's poor
sanitation there's poor issues people
die kids die far more frequently of
measles as well as lots of other things
absolutely and they still do even with
vaccines in the United
States here's this is an official CDC
chart by the way published in 1960 there
is no way this would get published in
the postvaccine measles era okay but you
know 1960 they weren't expecting the
vaccine yet this is their own this is a
CDC at least the predecessor of cdc's
chart and you could see this is the
standardized per 100,000 people the rate
of measles mortality from 1900 until
1960 it went down over 98% without any
vaccine again I I I I've had so many
discussions with medical professionals
and they just it's hard for them to
accept that reality but it just is and
there's no reason to think the same
factors that cause a reduction and
decline of mortality of measles between
19960 would not have continued I'm not
saying that maybe vaccines haven't saved
some of those folks but some of the 400
folks probably would have also not died
based on the natural progression of
where that disease was going as well um
but that seems to be a hard thing to
accept well what have we traded that off
for okay things to consider um and and
and you know this I think is also
reflective Co vaccines they only look at
one side of the picture they don't want
to look at the rest of it so for example
here is a study a prospective study of a
100,000 people in Japan only study of
its kind I'm aware of and they track
them forward-looking super reliable and
what they looked at and this is
incredible finding Actually I don't even
know why they did this but they looked
at those who had measles and mons versus
those that did not have measles and mums
people who had measles and
MPS um uh died far far less frequently
from cardiovascular issues statistically
significant to take a look at all the
yellow statistically significant
findings total cardiovascular disease
and total stroke you are far less likely
to have stroke and cardiovascular
disease and die of it if you had measles
and mums and if you didn't and you can't
say well that's because people that meel
mums died no there only a tiny number of
them died cardiovascular disease kills
700,000 Americans a year if having
measles and Ms of eliminating that
increased the number of deaths of
cardiovasculares by 2% well you you just
went upside down in terms of the
benefits of this product I'm not saying
that's the case that's I'm not saying
that's good science what I just did I am
saying though that if you look at this
this study by mainstream researchers in
Japan looking at a huge cohort found an
incredible reduction I mean when you
look at measles and Ms you are
I mean and you can look at the if you
look at the uh those two line curves and
you could see the percentage of folks of
the men for example after 22 years you
could see that about 5% of those that
had measles and Ms died of
cardiovascular disease but something
like 15% of them died from
cardiovascular disease that didn't have
it incredible finding but it doesn't fit
the policy never seen a study that
contradicts this never seen a study
bunked so to speak because it's nothing
to do with vaccines really they just
happens to be out there in the world
really troubling though for those who
the proponents is and this is a huge
body of science back when all of these
in childhood infectious diseases and
maybe God put them on the planet for a
reason or being you know eliminated like
I said measles mumer Bell and Chickenpox
vaccine they can stop transmission so
they do end up reducing the amount of
circulating virus for those four viruses
as the viruses were seeded and children
didn't have those infections these
studies looked at the rates of childhood
cancers for example 66% increase rate in
non-hot lyoma and 233% increase rate of
hodkin lyoma amongst children that did
not have measles according to um the
international Agency for research and
cancer um and then you can look through
it in ovarian cancer double the rate of
those who didn't have measles and so
forth it's true of of and what they find
these studies are they're consistent and
they were all done often back in the '
80s and and then they stopped doing them
and they're sitting there in Pub Med but
they don't fit the narrative and what
they show is that ferbal childhood
infections meaning childhood infections
like of those that have fever for
whatever reason afford protection later
based on these studies from various
Cancers and other cardiovascular disease
and other issues I'm not saying this
just to be clear this is that's what
these studies
all reflect there might be a reason that
while for example certain viruses and
bacteria come and go throughout history
when you look back on human history lots
of virus bacteria they come and they're
gone these particular ones have been
with us for for forever and might be an
evolutionary biological reason that
they've been here because they might
actually help increase life ins
expectancy potentially um you
know you know
there's no reason I think that somebody
shouldn't be able to look at this data
and make a a health decision um and and
and and and have a a reasonable
discussion about this I mean I think it
would be wonderful to have um one side
of folks come and present the studies
that debunk these and this and and and
the one side that looks at these studies
because the body of
literature I've not seen a body of
literature that contradicts these
findings and so you know when you talk
about saving 400 something Folks by
getting rid of these diseases you might
have ended up causing far more death
through uh cancer heart disease and so
forth is the balance worth it the the
problem is that I'm just a lawyer I
shouldn't be doing that analysis yeah
but Public Health authori should but
they're not going to do that I I can
assure you I there are things that is a
speculation I'm willing to walk on a
Ledge on and say the FDA is not going to
do that and CDC is not going to do that
analysis and I don't and and if you can
get your State Department of Health do w
wonderful um so
um and and you might say well you know
the MMR has been carefully reviewed and
studied has it really I mean we've
already done we've already looked at
this issue we just take a super quick
peek here's the clinical trial relied
upon to license the MMR vaccine 834
children not properly powered no control
42 days of safety riew and by the way a
third had gastrointestinal issues and a
third had respiratory issues in the
trial I don't know what the point of
doing that trial was similar trial for
the 1971 original version um when they
licensed the 71 version which is
basically the same as the 78 version
except they changed out the rebella
component okay um this is what I was
telling you earlier here's the by the
way the vaccine information sheet from
Mel Ms rebella it includes a disclosure
such as seizures deafness long-term
seizures coma lodis and brain damage but
uh they took they got rid of that now
because you know uh so anyway um and
these are all remember we looked at this
these are all the conditions that are
just disclosed that um the manufacturer
say can be caused very serious
conditions um separate from the cancer
stuff separate from the heart disease
stuff these are the ones they have a
causal basis to
include and this is my favorite slide in
MMR and then we'll move on to another
topic is is that there was only one MMR
vaccine for Forever by Merc with that
clinical Tri just showed you that which
was underpowered no control and not
enough safety
review well glos Smith k finally they
went and they licensed an mrr vaccine
well what did they use as a control in
the study they used the Merk vaccine so
we finally could see what is the adverse
event rate amongst the healthy childhood
population of getting these products
buried in a supplemental table not in
the primary study it's right here okay
so you could see that serious Adverse
Events amongst those getting
mmit and mmr2 so mmit is the GSK version
two is the MC version 2 around 2% had a
serious adverse event but here's an
interesting thing by the way I've never
seen this before this is they took uh
Adverse Events prompting an ER visit and
nods this is a new thing new onc chronic
disease they remove those from serious
Adverse Events I don't know why so you
got to look at all three of them and and
and add them up cumulatively okay so
you've got 2% with the series have ver
event we looked to what those are
earlier those are serious you have
another 10% that needed an ER visit
prompted from the vaccine and you had
another three about 3.4% that had a new
onset chronic disease during this the
the the um uh uh during the uh review
period for the vaccine which was
unsolicited 42 days and then AES were
done for 180 days so uh you know I mean
to me that's that should be really
concerning if every few months every
child 3.4% of children in America had a
chronic disease that arose every person
America would have a chronic disease
over a longer enough period of time
so anyways I'm not looking to you know
cast dispersions on on on on
um on the MMR vaccine I'm really
just just pointing out that in the same
way that the federal health authorities
do not have any issue in my
opinion giving an impression of what
these products can do how harmful they
were before there was a vaccine and
misleading the public with regards to
MMR vaccine I don't think they have an
issue misleading the public regards to
covid-19 vaccine I think it's kind of
the same type of approach I I I I should
say for what it's worth I think most
public health authorities and medical
professionals are well-meaning I think
that they really they they believe that
they are um um you know they don't know
they just they have assumptions about
these products they're well- meaning
they think that they are uh they really
need to no matter what get you to take
it because that's going to save
everybody but you know when you step
back and you're not emotional or
religious about these products and
you're just look at the data they paint
a very different picture and it's
unfortunate that we can't have those
kind of objective
discussions um and so um you know as I
point out same hysterics apply to
covid-19 vaccine I say you know I'll say
it again everyone should be free to get
one uh government should be free to
persuade the public but when they
can't that's where it ends and think
about it after all did our government
tell us the
truth about the deaths in the clinical
trial of covid-19 vaccines no I I don't
think they went and publicized that at
all remember here it is again this this
this this this yeah
um uh conflicted Regulators I feel like
we've really covered this pretty well so
I'll just go super quick who's
responsible for vaccine safety not
pharmaceutical companies they're immune
so all of that responsibility was
transferred over the the Secretary of
HHS it's actually included in one
section of the United States code this
was part of the 1986 act it's called
literally mandate for safer childhood
vaccines that's what it's called it's
got three simple sections section one
make them safer section two form a task
force the head of the FDA CDC NIH and
make recommendations to the head of HHS
and how to make them safer in section
three every two years submit a report to
Congress describing how you made him
safer okay well guess what let's let's
work backwards did they submit that
biannual report to Congress is required
by section c never once we sued them
because they wouldn't give us any of
their reports never once have they
submitted this ban report to Congress as
required by the Mandate for Savor
childhood section c how about section
Department search did not loc at any
records how about the task force well
again we sued them the task force was
disbanded in 1998 so they had it for a
while but it doesn't exist so they're
not doing the easy stuff if they don't
if they're not submitting the biannual
report to Congress and they don't have a
task for on how to make it safer you
think they're doing the hard part of
actually making it safe dur under
Section A I think the presentation up to
this point probably answers that
question why did they abandon safety uh
I would argue to do because they are
conflicted they're utterly conflicted
they're responsible promoting vaccines
as well as safety so you know when the
Department of Transportation was
responsible for promoting Transportation
they said oh wait you can't also be
responsible for investigating disasters
because you can't like be glab handing
with industry like go make more planes
go fly more routes and then say oh
you're very bad and what you right so
they created the national Transportation
safety board they separate the promotion
from the safety function same thing with
energy Department of energy promotes
nuclear energy power plants to be
created the nuclear Regulatory
Commission regulates their safety I
can't walk into nuclear power plant and
say build more power plants hey buddy
how you doing you know slap them in the
back give them incentiv and then and
then slap them around when they not safe
but with vaccines we keep them in the
very same they're both within HHS okay
so one of them is going to win out and
the promotion function wins out but if
that weren't bad enough
as I mentioned earlier the 1986 Act
created a vaccine injury Compensation
Program where you Sue there it is the
quote from the law in all proceedings
brought by the filing of a petition of
vaccine Court the secretary shall be
named as the respond the Secretary of H
you're literally suing federal health
authorities for vaccine injury they're
statutorily required to defend against
any claim that a vaccine causes injury
if they create any studies that show a
vaccine causes injury is an admission
against interest is the most incredible
conflict you could imagine enough you
got rid of Market forces you have
utterly conflicted The Regulators and if
that weren't bad enough there's a
revolving door between regulators and
Pharma it's all over the internet you
could look at it all the former heads of
the CDC and FDA and regulators and where
they work now and where they're getting
paid and obviously we have that
government report um in terms of covid
vaccine one more thing I would point out
in that regard is that um I mentioned
the vaccine injur Compensation Program
that at least offers some Moda
of compensation for those injured by
vaccines even though you have to fight
the doj you don't get article three
judge you get a special Master you don't
get any Discovery as a right I can't
depose any of the farm companies I can't
get Discovery so you know you fight with
your hands behind your back against
Department of Justice that gets full
discover gets everything that they want
in terms of experts nonetheless they've
paid out over $4 billion in Damages with
a $250,000 cap in pain and suffering and
for death claims but when it comes to
covid vaccine injury
when it comes to covid vaccine injury
basically there's all you the only
remedy right now is the counter injury
Compensation Program who is the try or
effect that's really deciding your claim
you do not know what is exactly the
standard not sure who's the expert
they're going rely upon you don't know
can you confront them no is there a
hearing no is there any due process no
it is the equivalent of fill out a piece
of paper go to your backyard dig a hole
put it in the ground cover it up water
it and wait for money to grow I mean
that's essentially what the cicp is
we've already sued uh this we've sued in
federal court we right now in Louisiana
and in Texas to declare it
unconstitutional because you know when
you afford a remedy of some kind right a
process it's got to meet basic
constitutional due process if you don't
know who the triy f you don't get a
hearing you can't confront who's making
the decision you can't rebut their
evidence I mean it's the
most I cannot think of something more
offensive to do process you basically
submit something and you just wait how
long indefinite you have no idea oh you
only have one year to file but they can
take five years to decide your claim and
to date they since they only have a few
million dollars by the way you don't
have any you have no chance of getting
any real compensation they've
adjudicated only a tiny fraction of the
cams and they've only agreed to
compensate even I forgot some tiny tiny
percent and each of them got about an
average of a few thousand do for
devastating lifelong injuries that's
what the cicp program is it's designed
it's it's a it's basically a policy
organization our hope is to strike it
down and we um and and U and and I think
that I'm hopeful that we'll be able to
do that as
unconstitutional okay so
um uh this brings us to the last part
which is the idea of inform consent and
I think this really to me wraps and
wraps everything we've talked about
today uh and uh
um which is what is informed
consent and to me this is It's it's the
lack of respect for this basic principle
that led to so many of the issues if
they didn't mandate masks and stay at
home and vaccines and this stuff I don't
think you'd be having this hearing
persuade folks tell them they do if they
want to do it great if you're 90 years
old and you have a million comorbidities
and you want to still go to the coffee
shop it's America you should be able to
do it you're 16 and you're 18 and you're
totally healthy and you want to live in
your basement and wear seven masks and
vaccinate every day you should be able
to do that too because that's freedom
this
America informed consent is where you
get informed to whatever degree the
doctor is going to give you then you
decide whether to consent and that's it
that's what it should
be saying I don't consent but now you
can't get a job and you can't go to
school you can't go in the military you
can't go in public transport what the
heck is that that's not informed consent
that's I'm going to inform you and you
better consent or else that's what that
is is that's not informed consent that's
not Freedom seven basic questions that
you would ask I think in my opinion
before you decide whether you should do
a medical intervention and that the
government should respect your right to
do one is will the manufacturer stand
behind its product does the manufacturer
stand behind his product and on this um
thing there are links where you can see
which vaccines are covered by the 86 act
which are covered by the pra act and a
letter you can send to your
pharmaceutical company asking them to
wave that immunity because if they won't
stand behind their product do you think
it's wise to inject it in your
body I don't know some people don't and
they should be free to make that
determination in this country and say
you know what if the makers of this
product won't stand behind it and
compensate me if I'm injured why should
I take that
risk two did his clinical trial prove it
was safe we' looked at that pretty
closely I should be able to say that's
not good enough to inject that product
into me or or my child with that kind of
data I want a better trial and until you
do it
no did the post relationship studies
prove it safe we reviewed that same
principle should be able to look at that
I'm educated enough to look at Pub Med
and read the studies you know I
shouldn't even say educated enough
they're in English anybody can read them
anybody can figure this stuff out I
should able to say no without penalty
are the benefits what are the benefits
prob be able to look at them and decide
it's not for me
for whatever reason can you determine if
the risks outweigh the benefits well if
you don't know the safety profile how do
you do that and a lot of product these
products you don't know the safety
profile and I should be able to say I
don't want it on that basis alone
whatever the benefits are till I know
the real risk profile I should be able
to say no without penalty can you trust
the people recommending the product can
you trust Dr Peter marks at the FDA
who's going out making just a minute
everybody get the shot before it's even
authorized don't worry I won't have
cognitive distance if I not tell you
oopsie I just told you to take a shot
that hurts you or how about Dr Edwards
who's on the vaccinologist in the dsnb
who was a fiser consultant adviser right
before she was on the
dsnb or look or the members of the
advisory committee that you know
numerous reports Congress and other
reports have found are conflicted I
should be able to say you know
what I'm not sure I trust those
recommendations without penalty
and maybe you have a moral objection to
the product I'll show you one more video
and I'm pretty much done um so you might
say listen I don't want to participate I
believe abortion is murder some people
think that some people don't it's
America is free to their opinion and for
those who think that maybe they don't
want to participate in products that
involve abortion so let's take a look at
one video for it's a few minutes exactly
that
topic your work related to vaccines how
many fetus have been part of that
work my own personal work too I'm going
to hand you what's been marked
plaintiff's consider
41 can you familiar with this article
Dr yes are you listed as and all on this
article
yes this study took place at The wiar
Institute correct
yes starts to correct
yes how many fetuses were used in the
study described in this article uh quite
a few
so this study involved 74 ft is
correct I don't remember exactly how
many turn to page 12 the
study you 76
76 and um these fuses uh were all three
months or older when AB boarded correct
yes and these were all normally
developed fetuses correct yes what
organs did you harvest from these
fetuses well I didn't personally Harvest
any but uh a whole range of tissues were
harvested by
coor and these pieces were then cut up
into little pieces right yes and they
were
cultured yes okay um some of the pieces
of the fetuses were pituitary
gland that were that were chopped up
into pieces okay included the lung of
the fetuses yes okay included skin yes
kidney yes yes spleen yes heart yes and
tongue I don't recall but it probably
yes um
so I just want to make sure I understand
in in your entire
career and this is just one stud so I'm
gonna ask let me ask you again in your
entire career how many fetuses have you
worked
with well I don't remember the exact
number but quite a few when we were
studying them originally before we
decided to use them to make
vaccines that any sense I mean this one
study had 76 how many other studies do
you have that you used a beast I I don't
remember how you're you're aware are you
aware that the one of the uh objections
to vacination by the Pless
cases the inclusion of aborted fetal
tissue in the development of vaccines
and the fact that it's actually part of
the ingredients of vaccines yeah I'm
aware of those objections the Catholic
church has actually issued a document on
that which that individuals who need the
vaccin should receive the vaccines
regardless of the fact and that that I
think it implies that
m um the MMR vaccine and the and the
Chicken Box vaccine each have in each
vial in each vial administered have
millions of pieces
millions of cellular debris and DNA from
the aborted from the culture cell on
abor fetus in every single dose some
people don't some people moral objection
to that they don't want to inject a
vaccine into their child where the
injection will result in the ult cell
line re board fetus millions of pieces
of cells and DNA from that baby being
injected into their child and they
should be able to say no again without
coercion
yes representative Penza thank you madam
chair um that is listed in is it always
listed in the ingredients sometimes you
don't see it but um it's usually listed
as MRC correct uh
mrc-5 um and then also wi38 would be uh
what it would be listed as but sometimes
actually in the for example in the um in
the cdc's excipient list it's explicitly
stated as mrc5 I believe it says DNA and
cell debris I think it's actually
something I could pull it up if you want
yeah that'd be great yeah okay sure
follow up um I just had a question about
in regards with I know in development
and stuff that they can be used but what
about specifically to do you know um uh
for Co for the co injections yes so for
the co vac vaccines the uh J&J vaccine
had um I believe it was the J&J vaccine
had the um in the vial itself it had
aborted fetal celline cultured material
for the madna and the um uh and fiser
covid-19 vaccines there's nothing in the
vial from the aborted fetal cell line
and it's not part of the manufacturing
process but when they were developing
the VAC those two vaccines they did use
a bordered fetal cells in the testing
and development of the product so they
would use so they wanted to they wanted
to see how the vaccine would work in
within human cells they use the Border
fetal cell line cells including in
humanized mice so they're you know um so
they take a they'll take a border fetal
cell lines and they will essentially
inject them into mice and so they quote
unquote humanize them and then they
infect the mice and they see how it
works so like for example I'm you know
and this is a huge industry I mean I'm
I'm aware of you know just just 100 $
million contract from HHS NIH to create
humanized mice for example um so there's
um you know there an whole industry
around and and it's and it's a big part
of the testing that that occurs there's
also a lot of um Tes and create new Bard
fial cell lines you need to grow a virus
in something okay so viruses replicate
in cells you can't grow a virus in a
Petri like you can't just grow a virus
it doesn't just it needs to grow in a
Cell it takes over the celling machinery
so if you're going to grow a virus um
you know the rubella vaccine for example
that Dr styly pla can created which is
why he used so many aborted babies he
was trying to find a cellular medium to
grow the rebella virus so they tried
like the heart they tried the eye they
Tred the tongue they you know they take
and they use lots and lots and lots of
babies try to figure out which what to
use um and so um a lot of times they'll
use cells human cells to grow them in so
either cells um that have essence or
don't so um they'll take either cell
lines that meaning they'll replicate for
a certain number they have a a seed
stock and eventually they'll run out and
then they got to get make more or in
some instances they actually modify the
cells and and and render them Immortal
so they make basically like they're like
cancerous so like there's a kidney a
canine there's a dog kidney a dog uh
cell line that they use that they've
rendered Immortal that BAS basically
will replicate for forever and they use
that to create a certain flu shots for
example representative
beler thank you madam chair and to just
delve a little bit more into this I want
to be I want to be very specific and
clear to cure any confusion that I might
have on this issue because when I was
deciding back in late 2020 and early 21
whether I would move forward for with
receiving any vaccination I did have to
tackle this idea I am a
Baptist and I'm looking here at a fact
check from The Washington Post uh
subheadline democracy dies in
darkness that says the vaccines were
developed using aborted fetal cells is
false this information I also heard from
the government to assuage people of any
concerns before they took this uh
particularly with the MRNA vaccine so
just to be
clear were there
any uh aborted tissues utilized and
developing the MRNA vaccines yes it's
exactly in the manner I just described
and and it's categorically I mean I've
uh litigated around this issue uh we uh
got an injunction against the Air Force
as I mentioned at the beginning on
behalf of over 10,000 service members
who uh refused covid-19 vaccine
religious grounds preventing the Air
Force from expelling them and one of the
primary objections they had was the
involvement of the then existing
covid-19 vaccines which for J&J and the
and madna and fiser mRNA vaccines and I
can tell you
categorically that the MRNA
vaccines have as I said earlier in the
development and the testing they
involved portic fetal cell lines they're
not in the ingredients they're not in
the formulation so if that argument if
that article is factchecking the the the
point that they're not in the
ingredients and in the formulation then
it's correct um but they're wrong that
it did not involve the border of fetal
cells it
categorically 100% did in the testing of
those products thank you and just to
clarify the article uh the the claim
that they are saying is false is the
vaccines were developed using aborted
fetal cells which is apparently patently
untrue uh the same claim I do recall
being made by government officials at
the time because again I was tackling
the same issue um and I would just have
to go back to the testimony that from
the deposition we heard earlier where it
was suggested that it was okay to tell a
noble lie in order to get the population
to take up this vaccine thank
[Music]
you uh uh represent pull is off yeah I
and um I actually can provide you with
the support um let me make a note to
show that they
were the involvement of aborted fetal
cells with
mRNA I'm happy to do that um and in fact
I will tell you that the one vaccine
that they claimed had no
involvement let's put it this way the
Department of Justice did not contest
that there was a border of fudal sell
line involvement with the MRNA vaccines
when we were litigating this issue so uh
this was the Washington what
December 8th 2020 uh Washington Post
Yeah Yeah so you know so they Washington
Post the purveyors of all truth they uh
uh they're just
wrong so uh I can assure you of that um
and I will tell you the one that they
did contest was novaa they the only
vaccine the Department of Justice in our
lawsuit they claimed was not involved
with the board of fetal cells with no
acts they did not contest that the Mr
weren't by the way and they said because
one of the arguments they made is well
they so they should take the novax
vaccine but Nova but the novax vaccine
actually does involve a board of fetal
cells in development as well uh we we uh
um I need to look at what is subject to
a confidentiality agreement in that
lawsuit and what is not and I can
provide you um uh with what isn't but I
am certain that in our publicly filed
papers we I know we F argued and
explained that it of our Bo of fetal
cell lines in the development and uh and
that argument went away so some of the
soldiers were willing to actually fly
overseas because there were certain
vaccines that were not involved in Board
of fetal cell lines but they none in the
US and so some soldiers did do that
actually to make sure that they conform
with their beliefs um yeah uh you asked
me to show you the uh the excipient list
so um here is uh
here's the Mr mmrv it says mrc5 cells
including DNA and protein uh they
they've sanitized it a bit by the
way uh and then um let's see with the
vericella
vaccine same thing it says mrc5 human
diploid cells including DNA and protein
so those are the that's the culture
that's the sanitized version I mean if
you if you just go simply on online and
you just search for
mrc5 um you know you can find basically
um you know here you can buy some of it
um parent from this place and they'll
usually describe um the what it is let's
see if I happen to get lucky and pick
the right one right out of the box and
so um it's fiber
blast and
characterization it says right here MRC
F line was derived from a normal tissue
of a 14-week old male embryo by JP
Jacobs in September of 1966 so there it
is right there on the internet for you
everybody read all right um represent po
off uh I have a question about uh
uh uh scientific paper about trials for
uh fiser
vaccine uh are you aware of
uh uh whistleblower who came out from
Vis and uh uh was
um um was sharing that
uh there was UN blinding made too early
and the the process of uh double blind
study was not
followed uh do you have any information
on on fisa
whistleblower yeah I believe I know the
case you're talking about and um
there was a a review of that evidence
also published actually in the British
medical journal by in a in a in a in an
article um I am aware of that but you
know here's the thing I I mean I would
argue you don't you don't even need to
go and look at um
uh claims that are contested about these
products you just go look at the FDA own
source material that we went through
today that's not contested nobody can
argue against cuz that is their own
documentation I mean that those claims
they dispute obviously and they're
disputing it in that whistleblower
action um uh but but some of the other
stuff we've looked at is
uncontestable but yes and obviously
they're you know they're trying to get
their product license as best and as
easily and as quickly as they
can follow up and another a question if
I may you mentioned uh early data from
England and Scotland that they were
sharing some weekly data comparing
different populations could you expand
like uh what it was and what the the
data was showing before they removed
it yeah absolutely so they um um the
data was typically from some of these
countries was standardized so meaning
you know one in you know five in 100,000
wasn't just raw numbers it was
standardized on a population basis and
they were comparing the rates often of
death
hospitalizations and cases between the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated or the
on dose or TW dose and
unvaccinated and um uh over time you
know for example in uh I know for
example believe it was in Ontario Canada
initially they were just comparing those
with no vaccines to those with h uh you
know
uh who are
vaccinated well the case numbers for the
vaccinated started exceeding the case
numbers for the unvaccinated on a
population meaning on a standardized for
per 100,000 individuals so that did not
look good so then they changed the
definition I I we we um I have screen
grabs of all this actually I know this
is not a great source to you but uh on
my Twitter feed I have uh we I screen
grabbed this as they were doing it and
so they're there then they Chang the
definition to make unvaccinated meant up
until the second week after the second
dose So unvaccinated eventually became
at least one dose or maybe even two
doses compared to those who had two
weeks after the second
dose and then eventually the data they
even that didn't work after a while and
then they just got rid of the whole
thing England had similar data as well
and they were reporting it weekly until
the numbers again inverted were not
looking did not show what they wanted it
to show Scotland to those are the two I
I have a distinct memory of they were
not favorable to the policy
pronouncements of those agencies the
data stopped being
published I I'll yeah you you could
speculate but there it
is follow up so following up on uh data
and
good data from
observation so on population level um
there was Israeli data released by
Israeli government
that uh was
showing on a country level that there's
a
spike uh in
mortality uh about 4 months after covid
vaccine um in injection uh and also
there were some data again it could be
disputable but in New Zealand there was
a whistleblower who released their
Countrywide data so could you comment if
if you know of it
and uh how how reliable that data if we
can on Country level
um they identify the data but basic
Bally follow every in person injected
not injected and see if they were
injected like some anaphylactic shock
Could Happen quickly but some effects as
you showed they could take weeks or even
months to to kill a person so if we
could see it uh on a state level or on a
country level does it prove anything
yeah
um it I think it contributes to the data
from the biggest whistleblower out there
which is the who and our world in data
because if you go to those sites just
take a look at the covid number of
deaths from covid in the countries that
were highly vaccinated versus the ones
that weren't look at the
hospitalizations look at the cases I
mean uh um there were studies that have
been done on exactly that um you know
I've heard the argument that well you
know uh developing countries don't have
as good health tracking data that's not
true they can tell you down to the
0.00001% the daap vaccination rate in
their country because unlike the United
States they have centralized
healthare they have a c the All healthc
Care is provided by One Source it's a
single Source Health Care System
everybody in their country is all in one
database actually our Health Care system
is fractured the American data is
probably the worst data in the world in
terms of tracking this stuff but look at
a lot of these developing countries they
have centralized they get money from
from uh um International organizations
they have pretty robust especially when
it comes to actually vaccination
tracking because there's a ton of money
gets poured into doing that and so um
you know to your to to your point New
Zealand and these other places yes you
do have these whistle blowers who put
data out um and I think that data
confirms what we already
see Visa the death rates overall in
these countries that are highly
vaccinated versus countries that did not
um uh that are not highly vaccinated and
you would expect to have the worst
outcomes because they have less better
they don't have as good nutrition they
have uh they don't have good cute Health
Care they they don't have you know
ventilators they didn't have have all
the medical acute care we have here the
the the the standard of U um the
nutritions that we have the sanitation
but yet they had better outcomes I'm not
saying that I'm not I'm not just saying
just I'm not just saying I'm I'm just
saying that from a statistical
perspective that raises a lot of
questions just like the data put forth
by these whistle
plowers representative Penza thank you
madam chair just to kind of follow up on
what the representative just asked you
um I'm sure you're familiar with in
Israel specific because I believe I mean
they were in an uptick of um of over 90%
of um vaccine compliance and the um
their prime minister bared broker to
deal and they had an exclusive with
fizer so and I don't know where their
data is or not but isn't that like the
because we had multiple we madna and
fizer and then even J&J early on and
stuff so we had you know there was it's
mixed but they had like a like a
perfect um one you know one um one
vaccine and so I don't know what their
data looks like but that is um that's a
wealth of information correct for yeah I
mean the one they are one of the most
highly vaccinated countries in the world
and also have uh uh one of the highest
case rates in the whole
world and and like you said they were
one of the first to vaccinate and
vaccinate almost everybody in their
population represent po
off thank you for taking another
question so uh you mentioned that there
are several different Technologies
behind different vaccines and even
different techn just for covid
vaccines
so um as a state New Hampshire is
looking to expand uh authority of our
government and add new biological
product for example uh to New Hampshire
vaccine Association next week uh uh this
body will probably approve adding RSV
vaccine which is not a vaccine but more
like
monoclonal
antibodies so do you have
any thoughts about like expanding
definition of vaccine and uh also about
this new technologies when we keep
adding like so it looks like we change
definition to add mRNA vaccine mRNA
technology to definition to vaccine now
uh New Hampshire will be adding RSV
vaccine uh maybe
maybe they wanted to change definition
they won't change definition anyway what
are your thoughts on new technologies so
the so the RSV monoclonal antibodies
which is you're right it's interesting
it's on the CDC vaccine schedule even
though it's a monoclonal antibod um it's
the you know if you open the plen
vaccine textbook the medical textbook uh
they do consider monoc antibodies a form
of immunization not vaccination but
immunization because it does provide
immunity for a certain period of time
there is also they added an RSV vaccine
for pregnant women to the schedule so
they actually have both on there um I I
I I would urge
strongly um uh uh anybody considering uh
pushing That
vaccine I can't imagine mandating it in
in in any place to just look at the uh
the summaries of the pack of the uh
clinical trials in that for those
products um and look at the rates of uh
issues and complications amongst the
pregnant women that got it who didn't
and amongst the babies that uh got the
menetes and who didn't and I mean um it
speaks for itself um I don't like to say
what those because people you know like
five days H if I say that it just sounds
ridiculous unless I show it I don't have
the art we could pull it up but I'm I'm
assuming we could do you that's you now
all know were to do that on fda's
website and you could pull that up and
take a look at those on your question
about what is a vaccine what is the
definition of a
vaccine in my opinion uh you know a
vaccine what what makes something a
vaccine is is is really whether or not
it falls within the uh framework of the
um what what what are the traditional
features of a vaccine and in my opinion
those are one you uh you claim either
truthfully or not it stops
transmission true you give it immunity
to
liability three you say you need to get
it to protect yourself to me that's
that's what makes something a vacine
because um it falls within the rubric of
what's uh the what I consider to be the
problem so to speak with these products
which is the lack of Market Force is
protecting them and the
Regulatory one-sidedness and and covid
vaccines whether they're J&J whether
they're Novac whether the mrnas fall
into directly that rubric um if if they
would have put the MRNA product and they
said it's not a vaccine and they would
have said no this is a gene therapy and
they wouldn't have given it immunity and
they wouldn't have mandated it and they
wouldn't have given then yeah I think it
would have been you wouldn't think of it
as a vaccine but that's not what they
did and you know and you I can make an
argument for why tennis vaccine
shouldn't be a vaccine why why why it's
it's for something that's not even
transmissible how how about protesta
vaccine it's like the opposite of a
vaccine it actually makes I mean you
know it has the opposite effect right so
a lot of these vaccines are only
personal protection well does that mean
they're not vaccines what makes them
common it's the features I just said so
to me as long as I gave them immunity
liability and they create that
regulatory structure that is what makes
it a vaccine whether you like it or not
whether you want to call it something
else or not I mean that that is the
that's the box of the problem in my
mind
followup uh I also wanted to ask about
uh insurances so we talked today about
how CDC and FDA uh um pushes this
message uh and uh
certain doctors and we know that there
are some federal funding that comes with
it but um we had um some uh testimonies
that uh insurance industry also involved
in
promotion of certain shots and uh my
understanding is ideally it's what you
said like Market should regulate it so
if they see a better health out come and
less spending they should be promoting
it but in this situation it looks like
counterintuitive so they should see that
Health outcome in their statistics is
getting worse but they still
incentivize doctors to uh to keep High
rates of keeping U keeping
uh vaccination rates high so I wonder if
there are some additional finding if if
you are aware that comes to insurance
companies to do that or if there are
some disconnect that doesn't allow them
to see like what product is helping
population and what product is not yeah
I mean if if um
reducing injuries from vaccines would
help in improve the profitability of
insurance companies then yeah I think
they might have an interest
in what you just said in in in in
looking at that issue but it it uh it
wouldn't as far as I understand the
insurance industry first of all the
federal government um
uh vaccine for Children's Program
basically guarantees
payment for anybody who can't pay for a
vaccine so these insurance companies are
guaranteed to get paid and they're
guaranteed to get reimbursed with
federal dollars there's also some State
programs about 50% I think between
federal and state programs of vaccines
are paid for with public money something
like that so the insurance company
that's guaranteed payment right they
know they're going to get paid they
don't have to worry about that period um
separately um my understanding and and
you really should talk to Insurance
experts about this but you know they
have depending on the state because
insurance law is obviously State
dependent it varies by States but you
know they they they make a profit margin
basically uh you know certain kind of
often regulated profit margin so in some
ways the more that you have to uh pay
for insurance the more that Medical Care
needs to be provided the greater the
premiums and as long as the market will
bear it it actually ends up resulting in
a greater increase in the percentage
that they can make but I'm I'm no
insurance expert you know that's my
that's what I I I've been told but you
should verify that with somebody who
actually let's looked at this directly
I'm I'm giving you secondhand
information that I that you shouldn't
rely upon for that
point but yeah I'll add this
too you said one other thing I forgot to
address absolutely this that the
insurance companies are sitting on the
uh on data that could help elucidate the
injuries caused by these products they
are sitting on we talked about earlier
the ICD9 and now 10 codes um and and so
within
every for each person that they ensure
especially if it's a captive pay
environment meaning if the insurer is
also providing the medical care like a
Kaiser right then they have um
presumably really good data for every
person in their Network they can really
do comparisons good comparisons between
those who have gotten the product and
those who haven't since seen the health
outcomes but I'm not really sure that in
the business of doing
that um so we had an infectious disease
doctor in here testifying before us and
he made a statement and I don't know if
the committee remembers but uh when we
were talking about the covid vaccine Etc
and he said within the next five years
he see he believes the cancer rates will
rise
exponentially um and based on some of
the information you showed uh in your
previous slide um I think that your data
May support some of that well let's hope
he's wrong I hope
so represent
Penza just a uh thank you madam chair
just a quick question about the
insurance um piece that was brought that
was brought up is there a um do you
think there's a any pathway um for that
getting that data because I I never
really thought of that that would be um
gosh that that would be everything that
we would need to know because of course
especially the largest insurers in the C
in the country you know whether it be
Blue Crush Blue Shield ETA whatever the
largest
are I mean um and you know this is
something obviously you need to talk to
ledge counsel about but I mean could you
pass a law that says that they have to
publicly disclose de identify
uh copies of all their ICD9 10 n data of
at least all New Hampshire
residents I like
that yeah just make it publicly
available and let scientists do
studies so uh so you know we were going
through informed consent and uh um you
know I said eight questions the seventh
was maybe you have a religious objection
um we did um you know the good news is
that right now there's there were six
states where there were only medical
exemptions but now there's five because
Mississippi um has a federal judge has
ordered we in lawsuit that we uh we were
grateful to be able to bring has uh uh
uh ordered that Mississippi restore
religious exemption in the same way that
um you know if you can keep Walmart open
during the pandemic you should let
churches stay open if you can have a
secular exemption to vaccines to attend
school um then you should be able to
have a religious one and the judge
agreed with that that's the Tandon
Fulton and so forth Supreme Court
precedent Co has brought certainly some
good precedents in that regard and we're
thankful for that uh so you know
Mississippi has affirmed that and we're
bringing that same case in West Virginia
right now um and and uh um we've got
cases in in other states as well so our
hope is to um you know restore the the
the the right to informed consent um
even if it's just on a religious basis
at least everybody should have the
ability to make that choice um you know
they shouldn't have to adopt the what I
would consider to be often the beliefs
and they are beliefs no different than
any religious beliefs that that you will
often hear about these products you'll
hear the slot I believe in
vaccines they'll say vaccines are the
only thing that can save us from the
pandemic I thought that was the kind of
language usually reserved for uh uh you
know for God and so forth the only
person that can save us apparently it
was only the vaccines and you heard that
all the time some people found that to
be even offense to their core beliefs
again nobody should be coerced to
abandon their beliefs for the beliefs of
Health authorities and the last question
is can your doctor exercise true
independent medical judgment when it
comes to these products and I think
we've seen a lot today about why that
potentially May may not be the case and
in particular when it comes to medical
exemptions and this is a true problem
nationally which that medical exemptions
should be like all other medicine it's
based on clinical judgment you let the
doctor decide most of medicine involves
clinical judgment you go into your
doctor review your symptoms and he makes
a judgment or she makes a judgment call
what medicine prescrib you whether you
should get a medicine not get a medicine
medicine to be sure involves a lot of
science but it also involves a lot of
Art and that involves making a judgment
call that we let doctors do every single
day for virtually every single medical
procedure that you get but when it comes
to vaccines that's pretty much the only
Arena that I'm aware of where we tell
the doctor States literally tell the
doctor no you don't get to exercise
medical judgment if you want to Grant a
medical exemption it must meet the cdc's
contraindication for cost list a narrow
policy based list of what is or is not a
contraindication and precaution it
should not be that way and I urge all
states to address that issue so um you
know wrapping it up what's in formed
consent again you get informed then you
decide what the consent and at the end
of the day you should uh if the state
should not uh compel above that and this
is my last slide it's my own tweet how
about that um it's my pin tweet because
it's my favorite one and I'll read it to
you it says mandates are the tool of
bullies criminals and dictators if a
patient refuses a medical product after
being conveyed its benefits and risk
then that is called informed consent
they were informed and did not consent
mandating over this subjection is
immoral and a liberal and let me really
drive this point home because I mean
this and and I I I you know
I I think of all the issues that we
confront in society this this is
probably one of the most important civil
rights issue that we're going to face
going into the next few decades okay
because your body is the commodity of
pharmaceutical sales literally Your Body
Is Right your body your children's
bodies are and and throughout history
you know to be sure freedoms we talked
about this earlier they come with their
own risk freedom of speech comes with
risk freedom of assembly freedom of
religion right they can be risky people
can say things that are wrong you looked
at the website earlier that gave wrong
information yeah sure can lead people
astray but throughout history when we
look at what has caused the most harm in
humanity in my in my opinion the
greatest harm to humanity has always
been governments that believe that they
know better than you how to live your
life and that it was a dictator it was a
king it was a central Authority that was
going to decide for you what you can or
cannot do that has wrought more
destruction and harm throughout history
on on on on the on the world more than
any pestilence or disease and and when
you look back through the course of
history and we and you know one of the
wonderful things especially as the
principles of this country have
developed over the last 200 and
something years is we've come to
understand that principle here and I
think up until recently we it was is a
basic part of you know the ethos in this
country which is that we protect the
rights of even the most vile
speech in order to protect the rights of
everybody to have free speech right um
we let the you know neo-nazis walk
through sko Illinois Jewish Community
because protecting their speech protect
all of our speech is as reprehensible as
we found that speech right as long as no
violence is
involved we protect it and and um you
know how quickly that ethos was lost
over the last few years how quickly we
abandoned the basic principle for a
little bit of safety um and and it was
very scary for me personally to see
happen it was very heartened when it
went the other way as well but um um he
dictators and and those throughout
history the resort to mandates to
censorship to bullies always happens
when what when you can't conve convince
on the merits you think dictators
immediately just start beating you no
they first tell you what to do it's only
when you don't listen that they beat you
they mandate they censor you put you in
the goog or whatever throw you out of
your job throw you out of school you
know they they shun you that is what
dictators that's what bullies do we in a
free democracy old school mean liberal
IDE ideas
right versus being
illiberal government should try to
persuade on the merits that's what you
should do Health
authorities take this vaccine you should
take it it's great it's safe effective
here's the data but if they can't and
you say no that should be the end of the
story should be true for masks it should
be true for everything because people
are smart on a population level you know
why you need to resort to mandates
because when there's real questions
about safety and efficacy that's why you
need to resort to mandates because uh uh
there's real issues if there were no
issues you wouldn't need
mandates so so um that's my um you know
that's my my ideological Bend and my
bias in terms of these products uh it is
that um you know if we let if we let the
pharmaceutical
industry continue the lobbying efforts I
know they do on all 50 states to get rid
of exemptions to get rid of uh uh uh um
to vaccines let to add more vaccines to
the schedule to first it was preschool
then it was elementary school then it
was high school then it was College then
it was healthcare workers then it's
Preschool teachers right then during the
pandemic now was going into a
store what if that system could have
they if that stuck during Co and thank
God it didn't there's no doubt that you
would load more products onto it why not
right think about it it's it's a
mandated guaranteed Market liability
free why wouldn't you add more products
to it it would be silly from a business
perspective not to and you know um and
for all those out there who say well I
love vaccines and I love masks and I
love all those products great you should
free to get them but if if everybody
doesn't stand up and say the line is you
can't mandate it the day will come when
maybe there's a product that that person
doesn't want and now they can't get a
job or out of their home so what rights
do they have left right so now they're
home they can't get a job they can't go
to school can't parti in Civil Society
so they got a right to freedom of speech
by themselves assembly by themselves
religion to the wall that's why I really
believe that this is such a critical
civil rights issue this idea that the
government can tell you what you must
inject or put on your body to
participate in Civil
Society whatever
dangers it might
present not wearing a mask the greater
danger is letting the government have
that Authority because I don't think
that it it will stop and if you're going
to do it at least at least remove the
liability protection it's incredible
that the most uh the products that have
the most uh uh Protections in term of
able to see the pharmace companies are
the ones that you would mandate um so in
any event that's um um in terms of New
Hampshire's approach to covid vaccine
Which is far better than most States and
to be commended for that for sure um
that would be my uh what I would testify
to in terms of thoughts going forward um
in terms of reflecting back on what did
happen during Co and in the future in
terms of what what should be thought of
as the primary uh issue to to to avoid
which is
really don't mandate just let people
choose represent po
off thank you so uh I I agree with your
assessment on proper role of government
and civil liberties but we hear from
from the opposite side that um we need
to
consider benefit to society and if too
many people experience symptoms uh and
get sick uh it put too much pressure for
example on medical
industry and similarly uh one example is
uh smoking and Indo smoking people used
to smoke smoke ins in inside New
Hampshire state house but now government
stops it so you don't get secondhand
smoking here so the same argument that
sometimes um
some government intervention and some
mandate is needed to prevent pressure
for example on medical industry oh I
appreciate those two comments actually I
think they're great points and let me
address both of them in terms of the
first one the idea that well we have to
reduce the burden on the medical care
system first of
all if you accept that argument I want
to remind you that the number one killer
during the entire pandemic was not covid
in America number one killer was C
disease was heart disease that was the
greatest burden on our medical system so
is the argument that to in order to
reduce the burden on the medical system
we're now allowed to mandate
stattin should we be allowed to mandate
exercise should we be allowed to mandate
folks from eating too much saturated fat
I mean if you're going to argue that we
could take away civil liberties in order
to reduce the burden on the medical
system
then I don't then then there's nothing
that the government really can't mandate
again I'll say it again absolutely you
there might be some harm and giving
people freedoms right may maybe it's
true maybe it would have been a bit more
of a burden um on the medical system if
we let people choose the covid vaccine
remember it doesn't mean you can't get
it it just means for those that don't
want it you can't coerce them that's
what it means persuade them if it's so
great if the product is so good then why
can't you persuade people to take it do
I need to persuade you to eat to drink
water to go to sleep no why because
there's really no question about safety
and efficacy why don't you need to
mandate me to you know to engage in
basic functions and if the medical
intervention is going to be one that
really will have a cost benefit that's
far better then wonderful persuade on
the merits this idea that you have to
crush civil liberties in order to
protect the medical system is a very
dangerous slippery slope and I don't
think it holds up to scrutiny because
what it does is it means that they can
mandate anything second I do not view
prohibiting smoking the same as
mandating a product that is that is
saying you can't do something that's
totally different you can't equate
saying you can't smoke in the state
house building with you must get an
injection of this product into your body
to come into the state house building or
you must wear you must wear a mask on
your face to come into the state house
building they're not the same at all in
my opion at all one does not require me
to do anything sure it prohibits me from
doing something in a certain environment
but you can't you can't equate the
infringement on civil individual rights
between those two
actions represent Penza I know it's
getting so late thank you madam chair um
I just I I had a couple questions just I
I know you must be familiar and I'm on
the CDC website right now um in regards
with the
covid-19 um vaccines
so um so you have the 2023 2024 formula
for ages 6 months to 11 years but that
formula even though they it's weird
because all the documents that go with
it and I've been reading them since I've
been here um are all say that they still
have eua on it even though then they say
authorized so not they're still using of
course the eua formula so it's not
approved correct for that group 6 months
to 11 years yeah it depends uh yes so
depending on the age and the product um
and and whether you're talking about the
initial version the B veent version the
new updated version some are e eua
authorized and then some are licensed
and some are and some are now um being
uh basically treated like a flu shot I'm
sure you're aware of that where they're
going to update it now annually um and
um and release it I mean I I essentially
if you look at the guidance we're going
to have a new covid vaccine every year
at this point and it's going to be
treated like a flu shot and they're now
developing a single dose flu plus covid
vaccine that they're intending to give
to everybody follow up um thank you
madam chair yes I'm familiar with that
um dual shot and so I just when we were
going through some stuff here in um in
New Hampshire in regards with you know
mandates that were um coming down really
from you know what we consider Private
Business even though you know hospitals
you know they're open to the public
they're taking in tons of government
money you know I know that argument
there's not really any such thing as a
private business anymore but um one of
the the largest hospital in the state
uh sent out a memo to all of their
employees because their um a lot of the
arguments were were you know this is not
a um it's eua so it is of course you
know it's um hasn't been approved yet
and the and the um the CEO of the
hospital sent this out to the employees
and it stated um hey you don't have to
worry about it anymore this was when and
I can't pronounce it comti or yeah I
call it katti everybody pronounce it
different okay Kady um had been
approved but lo and
behold that got approved but there
weren't any of them and there weren't
any of them that were going to be out
and be ready to be injected in anybody's
arms for
months and that wasn't talked about at
all so it was kind of like oh you don't
have to worry about it anymore everybody
that's concerned you know uh it it has
been authorized go get it but when they
were going to go get it to be able to
keep their jobs they were actually still
getting the same exact thing so you know
I just that that I mean misinformation
lies in a sense to encourage people to
have that uptick was really for the
medical for all these healthcare workers
was huge did you see that type of things
happening because you're in Arizona that
happened a lot in New Hampshire
especially in our in um in our Medical
field yeah it happened across the entire
country because the CMS mandate the
federal CMS mandate on on healthcare
workers was upheld by the US Supreme
Court if you remember there were two
cases that went up the oath one which we
we also um uh we we filed it on behalf
of a car dealership that had more than
100 employees or all the other car
dealers less than 100 employees we were
one of the cases up in the Supreme Court
on the oath but I didn't and then there
was the CMS case which we weren't
involved with and then the CMS case the
Supreme Court upheld that mandate on
Healthcare workers um you know when you
think about what I was saying earlier
about religious beliefs with regards to
these products here is the medical
profession for a product they
knew did not stop transmission
nonetheless and was saying we can't
overburden the Health Care system was
willing to throw out doctors nurses and
healthc Care Professionals over a
product that was at best personal
protection I mean uh you know it
requires a leap of faith to do do that
because they don't that makes no logical
sense it's not logical you know it only
makes sense if you're making emotional
belief based decisions that don't
comport with you know just reason logic
or evidence so yes I did we did see that
all over the country now the um the CMS
mandate did not anull the potential to
get a title 7 religious exemption under
federal law so title 7 requires
employers nationally to give
accommodations for religious beliefs in
different states and different employers
were more or less accommodating during
the pandemic our you know our firm
helped thousand hundreds thousands I
don't know the exact with thousands
overall I don't know how many of our
healthare workers get exemptions to the
covid-19 vaccine mandates on title seven
grounds on religious objection grounds
often because of uh interaction with the
boorder of fetal cells uh despite the
Washington post's claim from December of
uh of a number of years ago so um so
yeah that we did see that and and and I
I would suggest to you that a potential
solution could be that if you wanted to
um you know if if there were a New
Hampshire law that said that upon the
receipt of a religious an exemption for
religious accommodation it cannot be
questioned that you that just must be
accepted um then that would create the
exceptions in that scenario for those
medical healthcare workers um actually
in Arizona a bill went all the way um
went through on that and I believe it
ended up getting unfortunately vetoed by
the governor but it did pass to to to
create what I just said to protect those
healthcare workers who uh wanted to make
evidence-based
decisions repres
leus are you familiar with any cases and
do any people have standing who actually
tried to get medical exemptions and were
denied when they could show that they
were actually verifiable I I mean um
religious exemptions such as for the
aborted fetal cells Etc oh yeah oh we
have lots of cases so obviously our case
against the Air Force and the army uh we
didn't do the Navy or or the uh the
Marines we did the air force of the army
we got injunctions in both those cases
for individuals in both branches the
military who for on religious grounds do
not want a vaccine we represent uh we
also have an employment practice at the
firm um and our employment practice is
heavily focused on representing
individuals who have been fired for
refusing a covid-19 vaccine on religious
grounds actually that's almost all our
cases we have numerous class actions
against employers around the country
they're all title seven cases so um um
we have lots of those um and uh uh and
obviously we brought the case in
Mississippi to restore Rel exemption so
we do a lot of work in that area I mean
listen the First Freedom under the
Constitution and the in the Bill of
Rights in the First Amendment and the
First Freedom in the first amendment is
the freedom of religion right I mean
that is what this country is founded on
was the idea that you can come here you
can live out your convictions and you
know back back when that uh amendment
was written you know religion was
something far broader I think the most
Americans think of it today people think
of religion today as like Sunday um but
really back then it was your it was um
it was how you lived your life right it
was you be able to come to this country
and be able to live your convictions
right and and and that's not just going
to church on Sunday that's being able to
live my convictions and as a free person
not have the government crush them and
so you know when if I'm you know
somebody should be able to say look you
guys are treating this product like it's
you know like it's a a deity I mean you
know if I'm going to
attribute properties to something that
it doesn't have you know I can say well
look at this this product stops
transmission when uh it doesn't I mean
I'm not saying that's idol worship but
I'm saying that I'm saying that you know
uh it's akin
to taking something that's just an
inanimate object and giving it
properties it doesn't have and saying
this is the only thing that will save us
some people say ah
that's not where my convictions lie I
believe in something else and she should
be able to do that without you know
penalty or per and and
Punishment followup so people I know
there are people in the state I know
there are people in other states who
were
fired o and had asked for religious
exemption what should they do okay so um
uh without giving legal advice to
anybody individually okay just speaking
generally um if you have if somebody has
for example um sought a religious
exemption they have a limited period of
time to file with the EEOC which is the
or the state equivalent of the EOC and
whatever state they're in a claim for
for religious discrimination if they
don't do that Unfortunately they could
be bored from then bring a claim the EOC
or the state equivalent typically has
six months then investigate they will
then issue a decision on whether they
believe there has or has not been
discrimination um at that point um the
you know there's often a potential
discussion with the employer and uh the
council for the employee and if they
can't resolve it the employee gets a
right to sue letter and uh a case is
brought in federal court and like I
mentioned we have cases like that around
the country uh we even have it against
pharmaceutical companies who fired
employees for refusing roage exemptions
are some interesting cases so absolutely
I mean employees should be well aware
that title 7 protects their right to
have a religious uh to to to live their
faith to live their beliefs and if they
have a religious objection to
vaccination title 7 um requires their
employer to provide them a reasonable
accommodation which was thankfully
recently clarified of the US Supreme
Court to be you know um they really have
to try and accommodate those individuals
I mean some of the folks that got fired
are so ridiculous that we represent like
they work from home they work from home
and they're fire because they wouldn't
get covid
vaccine I mean you want to talk about
religious beliefs wow that's that
requires an amazing level of belief
ideology you want to I don't know what
you want to call it it's unfortunately
these products can't just be treated as
products that's what they are I can
assure you they were not given to Moses
at sin they are just products and you
know and unfortunately they for I think
for some folks um they have taken the
place
of uh Something to Believe In You know
they maybe don't have a lot of uh uh
things that and so you know they they
really they believe in these products in
a way that people have religion in other
areas of life um and I I see it all the
time um people get very upset and worked
up when they talk about these products
very quickly even though they're just
products I i' love to see people get
that excited about uh you know uh uh you
know uh some other products anyway
please sorry thank
you seeing no other questions I would
truly like to thank you uh for being
here today um I have learned so much
um about vaccines and clinical
trials um and you it's been a wealth of
information and I think it will go a
long way in assisting us with our report
um for the state um so
set thank you for having me and thank
you for for holding these hearings I
mean it's so important really I mean U
uh what happened during the pandemic
could have easily just been forgotten
and everybody could have just moved on
but you're not doing that you're looking
back because if we don't learn from
history as we all know we're bound to
repeat it so thank you very all of you
very much and uh I I uh um uh thank you
yes thank you so much all right um call
this meeting adjourned and I will see
you all here back at 10: a.m. tomorrow
morning all
right wow